ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORIDA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE-THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. ARAMBULA BARRICADE
HAND BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE RIVAS ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH.
STONE T. VALIDATORS VIA FOOD
WELL VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER
WICKS. WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WE ARE THE WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN YOU
MOM YES SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD.
THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. HELP US TO KNOW ONE
ANOTHER BETTER. AND TO LIVE AS
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. REVEAL TO
US ALSO YOUR BEAUTY HOLINESS
AND PURITY. AWAKEN OUR HEARTS
LOVE AND GRATITUDE. FOR YOUR
INFINITE GOODNESS AND BOUNTIES
UPON UPON US ALL. LORD JOIN US
ALL TOGETHER IN YOUR LOVE AND
GIVE US YOUR HEAVENLY PEACE I
MEAN. THANK YOU MARK YES SIR WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
CHOW. READY BEGIN I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AND
ASIAN. ISRAEL THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED. REALLY OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY SCHIRMER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY APRIL
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE ASSEMBLY MINUTE SEVEN AM
THE HONORABLE DAVID CHIU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEVENTY TWO FOR
PRESIDING TO PROXY PROGRAM DESK
PRINCIPLE CLERK RUSSELL C.
TOMAS READING ROLL CALL THE
FOLLOWING PLACE BONTA MORNING
LOCAL SEVENTY RADIUS MOVES AND
MISTER FLOOR AT SECONDS. THAT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL. BE DISPENSED
WITH PRESENTATIONS HAVE
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE%
GOVERNOR. THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON. MOVING TO
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. MS RAISE
YOUR RECOGNIZE HER PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR'S PLEASE MOVE THE
FOLLOWING ARE BUILT. PLEASE
REFER. PLEASE MOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE INACTIVE
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
AB TWELVE AWAITING AND ITEM
NUMBER FORTY FOUR AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN- DONNA. THE CLERK WILL
NOTE. EVEREST'S WE ARE MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE
UP ASSEMBLY THIRD READING ITEMS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN WE ARE STARTING A FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY EIGHT. BY
MISS CLARK SILVA AND THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE SIXTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND OTHERS MAC LEADING TO
HOUSING. THIS QUICK SILVA. GOOD
MORNING MADAM SPEAKER MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB SIXTY EIGHT WHICH UPDATES
THE STATE WIDE HOUSING PLAN BY
EXPANDING THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT IN ORDER TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS THE STATE'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HOMELESS.
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS LAST YEAR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
ISSUED A REPORT THAT FOUND THAT
THE STATE LACKS AN EFFECTIVE
APPROACH TO PLANNING AND
FINANCING DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT BOTH THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL. WELL
THIS BODY IS TAKING DRASTIC
STEPS TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS
INSPUR HOUSING PRODUCTION MUCH
NEEDED IMPROVEMENTS MUST BE
MADE TO MORE EFFECTIVELY PLAN
FOR DEVELOPMENT OF FOUR. OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHERE WILL
HAVE THE GREATEST IMPACT THE
STATE HAS DEDICATED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN INVESTMENTS IN NEW
HOUSING. IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE STATE HAS THE TOOLS
AND RESOURCES NEEDED FOR SOUND
WELL COORDINATED PLAN THAT
EFFECTIVELY USES ITS FINANCIAL
RESOURCES. EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY AND PROVIDES THE
MOST IMPACT TO SUPPORT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS CLARK SILVA
SEEING NO DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CORPORAL ALL
MEMBERS. YOU DECIDE ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIGN OF A.
WELL CLOSER ALL TIED UP. HIGHS
SIXTY. NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM.
SEVENTEEN AB FOUR SEVENTY THREE
BY MISTER CHOW THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SEVENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO
AND ACCORDING TO PUBLIC RECORDS.
MISTER CHOW EMAIL ME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY
THREE RE CODIFIES AND WE
ORGANIZES THE PROVISIONS OF A
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
WITHOUT MAKING ANY SUBSTANTIVE
CHANGES TO THE ACT. THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I ASK
FOR YOUR IDOL. THANK MISS CHAO.
SEEING NOEL SEEKING RECOGNITION.
ON THE ITEM. CARCLUB GIRL. WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE A. THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE REAL TIGHT BUT I SIXTY
TWO KNOWS. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FOR THE PAST TO WE WILL PASS TO
ON FOR ITEMS NAY AND WERE TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FIVE ITEM.
TO ONE. AB WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEN ON FILE ITEM. TWENTY TWO.
MEMBERS WE ARE NEXT GOING TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM ELEVEN. THIS
IS FILE ITEM ELEVEN. AB EIGHTY
NINE BY MISTER JONES SAWYER THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
EIGHTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE THE PEACE OFFICERS.
MISTER JOHN SAWYER. GOOD
MORNING MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB EIGHTY NINE THE
PEACE OFFICER EDUCATION AND AGE
CONDITIONS FOR EMPLOYMENT AT OR
THE PEACE THAT RELYING ON
DECADES OF DATA SHOWCASING MARC
MATURE AND BETTER EDUCATED
OFFICERS ARE LESS RELIANT ON
EXCESSIVE FORCE THE PIECE THAT
WILL INCREASE THE CURRENT
MINIMUM EDUCATION AND H.
STANDARDS FOR ALL NEW
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS.
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS I'VE HAD
A ROBUST CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND I HAD AND I'VE
HAD HEARD THE CONCERNS
REGARDING THE IMPACT THIS BILL
MAY HAVE ON THE RECRUITMENT
POOL ESPECIALLY ON RECRUITS OF
COLOR. IN RESPONSE I AM WORKING
WITH SENATOR PORTANTINO WHO
AUTHORED A SIMILAR BILL AND THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION TO CRAFT A
COMPREHENSIVE COMMONSENSE.
POLICE REFORM BILL. IN ADDITION
AS AN AFRICAN. IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE EVERYONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME A PEACE
OFFICER. THE PIECE THAT WILL BE
AMENDED IN THE SENATE BECAUSE
OF THE COLLABORATION MISTER
PORTANTINO I MYSELF MAY AS THE
AUTHOR MISTER PORTANTINO WILL
BE THE PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR. SO
THAT WE CAN MERGE BOTH BILLS
THAT COMBINES BOTH H. ND
EDUCATION TOGETHER IN ADDITION
MAKING THE AGE PART MUCH MORE
ROBUST. THAN IT HAD EVER BEEN
BEFORE. ADD A DELAY IN. FOR
POST TO CREATE A LAW FORCED A
SOCIAL DEGREE AS WELL AS RAISE
THE AGE REQUIREMENTS TO TWENTY
ONE YEARS OLD TO ALIGN WITH THE
MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. ONCE
IMPLEMENTED ALL CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICER CANDIDATES MUST
BE TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD AND
OBTAIN NEITHER EITHER AT THE
NEWLY CREATED LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATES DEGREE. OR A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN THE
DISCIPLINE OF THEIR STUDENT
WITH ONE OF THE BEST TUITION
FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEMS
IN THE NATION LAW ENFORCEMENT A
WILL BE CALM AND ACCESSIBLE
OPTION TOWARD A CAREER IN
POLICING FOR CALIFORNIA'S MOST
DIVERSE. HIGHER EDUCATION
STUDENT POPULATION. WHILE THE
DUTIES OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS HAVE DEVELOPED OVER
TIME THEIR ENTRY QUALIFICATIONS
HAVE FAILED TO EVOLVE TO MEET
THE CURRENT DEMANDS OF THE JOB.
WHEN ELEVATED EDUCATION ENTREAT
STANDARDS ARE EXPECTED OF OUR
EDUCATORS AND HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS IT IS CRUCIAL
THAT WE ALSO DEMAND ARREST. THE
BIT THAT DEMAND THE BEST OF OUR
PEACE OFFICERS IMPROVING
CONDITIONS FOR EMPLOYMENT WILL
STRENGTHEN COMMUNITY TRUST IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND ENSURE
PUBLIC SAFETY ESPECIALLY FOR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. OF COLOR WHO
DISPROPORTIONATELY FALL VICTIM
TO EXCESSIVE FORCE AT THE HANDS
OF POLICE OFFICERS AS WE MOVE
THIS PROCESS FORWARD. I REMAIN
COMMITTED. TO WORKING WITH ALL
STAKE HOLD. IN THE ONES THAT
ARE NOT FAMILIAR. WITH THE DEAL
THAT HAVE BEEN STRUCK. VERY
RECENTLY BOB WITH THE PEACE
OFFICERS AND ALSO IN THIS.
DISCUSSION PORAC. SO THAT WE
MOVE THIS FOR ENDING. THE BILL
THAT HOPEFULLY EVERYONE WILL BE
PROUD OF THEIR CAN MOVE FOR. AS
WE MOVE THIS. AGAIN IF THIS FOR
I COMMITTEE. TO NOT ONLY WITH
THE PEOPLE. I'VE ALREADY STRUCK
A DEALWITH BUT PEOPLE OUTSIDE
WHO DON'T DON'T KNOW ALL THE
DEEP DEAL POINTS RIGHT NOW WITH
THE SHERIFF'S. OR OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE WILL CONTINUE. I
REPEAT WILL CONTINUE TO LET
THEM KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO
ALL WORK TOGETHER. BOB PASSING
IN PASSING IS TIMELY AN OVERDUE
THE PEACE ACT WILL
PROFESSIONALISE AND TRANSFORM
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
MARKETER TRANSITION IN
ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSES
BEHIND EXCESSIVE FORCE. ON
BEHALF OF CENTER PORTANTINO.
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION ARE CORRECT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THEY EMISSIONS SAWYER
MISTER COOPER YOUR RECORD AS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M
GONNA WILL PULL MY TODAY FALL
WITH SEEN SOME AMENDMENT AND IF
YOU LOOK- IT UNDER THE BILL
RIGHT NOW I WOULD NOT A BEEN A
LONG OFF I WAS YEARS- WHEN I
WHEN THE CAT- I HAD COULD TWO
YEARS OF COLLEGE- MY
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREES IN
BUSINESS AND I GOT LATER ON SO.
IT'S TOUGH I MEAN LOOK AT MOST
pPOLICE ACADEMIES IN THE STATE
THE VAST MAJORITY ARE NOT PAID
YOU PAY TO GO THROUGH YOURSELF
SO THE SIX MONTH POLICE ACADEMY
AND IF YOUR PARENTS BECAUSE THE
HOME IN WHICH OFF THEM. OR
YOU'RE WORKING A JOB IN IN
DOING DOUBLE DUTY SO IT'S VERY
TOUGH FOR SOMEONE THAT'S WITH
LIMITED MEANS IT MAKES IT VERY
VERY HARD SO THINK ABOUT IT
SEEKS PEACE TWENTY ONE YOU GET
PAID TO GO THROUGH LAPD YOU
KNOW BLACK SAID THERE'S A LOT
OF ACADEMIES I WAS HERE. 90%
DON'T PAY YOU TO GO THROUGH
BECAUSE- I THINK THERE'S A
MONEY TO. THINK IT. IF SOMEONE
CABINET SIX. THE DEPARTMENT'S
PAY. VERSUS SOME OF THE GRASS.
COMES CAB. YOU HIGHER MODEL SHE
SAID MONEY. THEN YOU'VE PUT
TRAINING THEY PASS OR FAILED
FOUR MONTH. THOUGH YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S HOW. A CAN
ARE SO. MY WE CAN IS THAT WE
LIMIT WHO. DO THIS. THE PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND- WHO HAVE A LOT OF
WOMEN ALONG FOR. PERIOD SO-
IT'S TOUGH FOR. IN YOU KNOW SO
LITTLE THINGS WERE. YOU KNOW.
YOU CAN HAVE SOME OF THE ARM
FOR DEGREES BUT IT'S JUST
BECAUSE- SENSE IS WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO. SO LIKE I SAID I.
UNDER THE BILL RIGHT NOW I
WOULD NOT MADE IT. IN A LAWFUL
COME IN AND SOME IN THE MIDDLE.
SO I THE AUTHOR WORKING ALSO OF
THOSE THINGS THAT TO. THAT SO-
WE HAVE TO BE. CAREFUL WITH IT
THE- LIKE I SAID MOST. FROM
YOUNG AND INCOME FROM A YOU
KNOW. A DIFFICULT BACK OF HOW
THE- THAT'S NOT GOING TO GET IT.
YEAH YOU GO TO COLLEGE FOR TWO
YEAR. BUT GREAT. RISK WORK IN
THE SAME TIME. SO IT'S A MATTER
OF. SO OF WILL MY VOTE LOOK FOR
TO SEE WHAT THE- ARE IN- I WILL.
A LITTLE SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS COOPER. MATH YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU. SPEAKER I
WANT TO. THE OFF FOR WORK. HARD
THIS. I DO LOOK FORWARD TO.
WHAT AMEND. LOOK AS THIS GUY.
TO THE- I DO HAVE GREAT
CONCERNS THE AG REQUIREMENT-
IT SOMEBODY WHO TO TWENTY ONE.
YEARS SERVING IRAQ LEAD. COMBAT
OPERATION- TO QUESTION THE OF
WITH YEAR OLD A I THINK WE TO
HAVE INS ON BECAUSE I KNOW A
LOT OF MY AND WOMEN. THAT
SERVED THE ARMED FORCES THAT IT
OF A LOT AT TWENTY ONE YEARS
OLD THEY SHOWED A LOT OF
EMOTIONAL INTELLIGENCE AND AN
ABILITY TO GET THINGS DONE. SO
TO SAY THAT ARE ARE YOU DOES
NOT HAVE THAT CAPABILITY AYE I
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT AND
I'D IKE TO ASK A LOT OF THE
POINTS THAT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
ELK GROVE MADE- WITH HIS
EXPERTISE. IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AS WELL SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THIS MOVE FORWARD OUT OF
RESPECT FOR YOUR WORK I'M GONNA
LAY OFF TODAY. ON AND WOULD
LOVE TO HELP WITH THE
CONVERSATIONS MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK IMAGE MATHIS.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE BILL MISTER
JONES SAWYER YOU MAY CLOSE AND
OUT AND I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS HERE NOBODY SPECIAL
MISTER COOPER MR LAW MY MIKE I
HERE PUBLIC. AND- MISTER MATHIS-
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT YOU STATE
ME AS I GO JUST. HOPEFULLY GET
OUT OF THIS CHAMBER AS WE GO
THROUGH THE SENATE. SO THAT WE-
ARE A TO CRAFT THAT A LAYS ALL
THE FEARS AND CAN. OF IN FACT
TALKING TO CRUISE- EVEN IF YOU
REQUIRE SIX UNITS- HAVING TAKES.
DEGREE WE KNEW NEED TO LOOK IT.
MISTER NOT EVEN HAD DISCUSSION
THE MIDDLE. AND WHETHER AND
WHAT OF SKILL SET THE DETAINEE.
SO IT'S A ROBUST DISCUSS GOING
ON OR EVEN GIVING. CREDITS TO
INTO THAT MAY BE MAY. OR MAY
HAVE BEEN A THE MILITARY
ADVERSE CONDITIONS BUT THEY MAY
HAVE A SKILL SET. THAT MADE ME
SHOULD BILL OR GIVE THEM A CALL
SO CAN COME. EARLIER OR SOONER
BECAUSE THEY A GOOD DAY A
SKILLED THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
NEEDS- THEY MAY BUILD PTO
PATIENTS WHILE THEY'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF. SO IT'S ALL WHITE
OPEN I URGE ANYONE WITH IN
IDEAS TO ME. GET TO THE POLICE
ALL ASSOCIATION AND OPEN-
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE THE
HAPPEN AND- I NOTICES THE
STRANGE BEDFELLOWS BUT I THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
DEFINITELY WORK. NOT ONLY FOR
IN THIS CHAMBER- NOT ONLY FOR.
PEACE OFFICERS. FOR CALIFORNIA.
PERSPECTIVE AS RIVAL. THANK YOU
MISS JONES SAWYER WITHOUT THE
CLEAR WILL- OPEN THE ROLE. HER
DESIRE TO VOTE ON VOTED AS TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OF.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A HIGHS.
FORTY WE NOTICED. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. CLOSER. HI WE. OVER
THERE ALL. CLOSE THE ROLE.
MISTER JONES SAWYER IS HAPPY.
HIGHS FORTY TWO KNOWS. TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES EVERY BACK IN
FILE ORDER. WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEMS
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY FOUR.
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY
UNFOLLOW THEM. TWENTY FIVE. WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX. FILE ITEM TWENTY
SIX EIGHT AB TWELVE OH SEVEN.
INCORPORATE SOME WIGGLE TWELVE
OH SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER Q.
THE WEBER AND OTHERS AND ACT
WITHIN THE PUBLIC HEALTH DOCTOR
WHERE YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE OH SEVEN AND
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. IF WE
DO NOT LEARN FROM OUR PAST THEN
WE WILL BE DOOMED TO REPEAT IT.
AB TWELVE OH SEVEN HELPED US
LEARN FROM OUR PAST SO THAT WE
CAN CHART A BETTER PATH FOR OUR
FUTURE. AB TWELVE OH SEVEN WILL
ESTABLISH THE PATHWAY THROUGH
PANDEMICS PASSPORT. THIS TASK
FORCE WILL BE TASKED WITH
ANALYSING LESSONS WE HAVE AND
CONTINUE TO LEARN FROM THE
COBIT PANDEMIC AND DEVELOP
STRATEGIES TO NAVIGATE FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. THE NEXT
PANDEMIC IS NOT A MATTER OF IF
BUT WHEN. THIS CURRENT PANDEMIC
HAS TOUCHED THE LIFE OF EVERY
CALIFORNIANS EVERY BUSINESS N
OUR STATE HAS CHANGED THE WAY
WE LEARN. ANORAKS AND JUST LIVE
OUR DAILY LIVES. AB TWELVE OH
SEVEN MAKES MODEST INVESTMENT
TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
ROAD MAP FOR FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS SO THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS THE DEFICIENCIES WE
THOUGHT IN OUR CURRENT RESPONSE
TO THE CALL THAT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND ALLOW US TO BETTER
PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE. THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION. AND I
THINK YOU AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DR
WEBER MISS REAVIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE OH SEVEN
AS A PROUD JOIN AUTHOR. I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR HER WORK ON THIS
ISSUE AND BRINGING HER PUBLIC
HEALTH. EXPERTISE I REALLY
THINK WE NEED THIS TASK FORCE-
TO LEARN- WHAT WE NEED TO DO
FOR THE NEXT PANDEMIC AND SO
THAT OUR STATE IS BETTER
PREPARED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS RIVERS. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS IT
IS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIGN OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE- DOES THAT ABOUT. CLICK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE AND TWENTY
SEVEN. THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT AB TWELVE NINETEEN BY MR
BERMAN. SACRAMENTO SOME PEOPLE
TWELVE NINETEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN AND ACCORDING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. MR BERMAN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWELVE NINETEEN
WOULD REINSTATE THE VOLUNTARY
NATURAL HERITAGE PRESERVATION
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM WHICH WOULD
SAVE THE LIMITED FINANCIAL
RESOURCES OF THE STATE OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR QUALIFIED NON
PROFIT. WHEN ACQUIRING PARK IN
HABITAT LANDS ARE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. DAVIS
BERMAN SAYING NO DISCUSSION. OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM. CABALLERO.
THE SENATE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AT ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENT ABOUT. THE CLARK WELL.
THE. YEAH WELL CLOSE ALL. OVER
THE ROLE. LOCAL CLOSER ALL. I
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
MOVE BACK IN THE FILE. TO TAKE
UP ONE OF MISS GONZALEZ IS
ITEMS. THIS IS. GOING TO BE
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN. ASSEMBLY
BILL. TEN SEVENTY FOUR. THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AND OTHERS AND ACCORDING TO
EMPLOYMENT THIS GONZALEZ EMAIL
BUT- THANK THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TEN SEVENTY FOUR
LATINO CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL
WHEN A SERVICE CONTRACT IS
TERMINATED EXISTING LAW GIVES
TWENTY YEAR EXISTING OFF FROM
TWENTY YEARS AGO UNDER THE
DISPLACED JANITOR OPPORTUNITY
ACT PROVIDES JANITORIAL AND
BUILDING. MAINTENANCE SERVICE
WORKERS THE ABILITY TO CONTINUE
WORKING UNDER NEW CONTRACTOR
FOR A SIXTY DAY TRANSITION
PERIOD. AB TEN SEVENTY FOUR
MAKES A NARROW CHANGE BY SIMPLY
ADDING SIMILARES SIMILARITY
SITUATED HOTEL WORKERS WHO
PROVIDE FOOD AND CLEAN SERVICES
UNDER A CONTRACTOR TO THIS
EXISTING LAW. THE LAW ONLY
APPLIES IF THE NEW CONTRACTOR
HAS MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES IN THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE THAT TO BE CLEAR
EXISTING LAW AND THIS BILL DOES
NOT REQUIRE NEW CONTRACTOR KEEP
HOTEL WORKERS ON BOARD IF THEY
HAD A- PERFORMANCE OR CONDUCT
ISSUE AT WORK. OR THE NEW
CONTRACTOR SIMPLY DOES NOT NEED
ALL THE WORKERS TO PERFORM THE
SERVICES UNDER THE CONTRACT.
THIS BILL TARGETS A LOW WAGE
WORKFORCE MADE UP OF
PREDOMINANTLY LATINO AND
IMMIGRANT WORKERS IN AB TEN
SEVENTY FOUR MINIMIZES THE
MEDIA DISPLACEMENT OF ALL
WORKERS IMPACTED WHEN HOTELS
TREATING SERVICE CONTRACTORS
AND ENSURES THAT THERE IS A
REASONABLE TIME FOR TRANSITION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ.
MISTER FLORES YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN OPPOSITION AB TEN SEVENTY
FOUR- FOR ONE OF VERY IMPORTANT
REASON AND- IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED THROUGH THE HOTEL
INDUSTRY THROUGH THE LAST YEAR
OF THIS PANDEMIC THEY HAVE BEEN
ABSOLUTELY DECIMATED. WE'VE
ASKED THEM TO SHUT DOWN. WE'VE
ASKED THEM TO EMPLOY. IN HOUSE
ALMOST PEOPLE THEY'VE BEEN A
PARTNER. WITH KOBE NINETEEN
THROUGH THIS ENTIRE YEAR AB TEN
SEVENTY FOUR. DOES ONE THING IT
HAMPERS THEIR ABILITY TO RE
OPEN. COMING FROM A BUSINESS
PERSPECTIVE IF WE HAVE TO TRACK
DOWN AN EMPLOYEE GIVE THEM TWO
WEEKS. THEY'RE GONNA BE STAYING
AT HOME. THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
COLLECT UNEMPLOYMENT. MEANWHILE
THE BUSINESSES REMAINING SHUT
DOWN BECAUSE BY LAW WE'RE
MANDATING HOW THEY RE OPEN. I
DO NOT THINK THAT IS THE
PROJECT OF OR THE JOB OF THIS
LEGISLATOR TO DICTATE HOW
PRIVATE BUSINESSES REOPEN. WE
NEED TO GET OUR EMPLOYEES BACK
TO WORK. AND THE ONES THAT WANT
TO GET BACK TO WORK ARE
KNOCKING ON THE DOOR READY TO
GO. THE READY TO WORK NOW THE
ONES THAT ARE STILL COLLECTING
UNEMPLOYMENT DON'T REALLY WANT
TO GET BACK TO WORK IN A LOT OF
REASONS FOR A LOT OF REASONS SO
I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE. TO LAY
THIS BILL DOWN TO VOTE NO AND
LET'S GET EMPLOYEES BACK TO
WORK AND- LET'S LET OUR
BUSINESSES REOPEN PROPERLY
THANK YOU. HEY MISS FLORA
MYSTERY THIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN AND
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF-
ASSEMBLY BILL- ONE ZERO SEVEN
FOUR AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS- THIS
IS A- A PRIORITY BILL FOR
CAUCUS AND AS WE KNOW THE
COVERT NINETEEN- THIS PANDEMIC
HAS PLACED ON PRESIDENT STRAIN
ON OUR SERVICE AND HOSPITALITY.
INDUSTRY AND ITS IMPACT ON SOME
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE LOW WAGE
EARNERS THIS IS CERTAINLY A
COMMON SENSE APPROACH. TO SURE
THAT WE DO WHAT WE CAN TO
SUPPORT A THESE VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS HERE IN OUR STATE AND
TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES WITH
THAT- THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TAKING THIS RIVAS SAYING. NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. J.
NOTATIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM MS GONZALEZ YOU MAY CLOSE
I JUST WANNA BE REALLY CLEAR
AND FORTUNATELY- WHAT THE- WHAT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO. AREA
WHAT'S REFERENCE SCENE IS
ACTUALLY NOT WHAT'S IN THIS
BILL THAT THAT IS THE PIECE OF
THE BILL THAT WE TOOK CARE OF
IN THE BUDGET ACTION IMMEDIATE
BUDGET ACTION AND IN FACT- THIS
BILL WHICH USED TO BE ON THE
CHAMBERS OPPOSITION LIST IS NOT
EVEN THAT ANYMORE BECAUSE IT'S
SO NARROW WHAT IT DEALS WITH
ITS CONTRACTORS IN THE FUTURE.
THERE ARE HOTELS THAT DON'T
DIRECTLY EMPLOY THEIR
HOUSEKEEPERS AND FOOD SERVICE
WORKERS AND THEY HAVE A
CONTRACTOR COME IN TO PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES MISTER SAYS THEY
CAN'T KEEP SWITCHING
CONTRACTORS TO GET RID OF-
WORKERS FOR EXAMPLE MAYBE
THEY'RE FORMING A UNION AND
THEY DON'T LIKE THAT- IN IT
JUST PROVIDES THOSE WORKERS A
CHANCE TO PROVE THEMSELVES TO
NEW CONTRACTOR HOWEVER IF THE
NEW CONTRACTOR NEEDS TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF WORKERS OR OR-
THERE'S PEOPLE WHO CAN BE FIRED
FOR BECAUSE I ALLOWS THEM TO
DO THAT AS WELL THIS IS NOT.
I'M IN ANY WAY DEALING WITH THE
IMMEDIATE RE OPENING OF HOTELS
THIS IS THE CAR THAT BASICALLY
WHAT WE HAVE FOR JANITORS IT'S
BEEN SUCCESSFUL FOR TWENTY
YEARS IT HAS NOT PUT JANITORIAL
CONTRACTORS OUT OF WORK THIS IS
THE SAME THING FOR THOSE
SIMILARLY SITUATED SERVICE
WORKERS IN HOTELS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE ABOUT.
AND WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
WELL. CLOSE ROLE TIED UP HIGHS
FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWENTY. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE A MOVE TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN. AB TEN FORTY THREE BY
MISTER BRIAN. CORRECT ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN AND
OTHERS NOT LETTING HOUSING.
MISTER BRYANT YOU MAY OPEN.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB TEN FORTY THREE THE
BILL THAT ADDS A VITAL NEW
DEFINITION TO OUR STATE HOUSING
LAW. ACUTELY LOW INCOME. AB TEN
FORTY THREE THE BILL THAT
ESTABLISHES A FRAMEWORK FOR
ADDRESSING PEOPLE AT RISK OF
HOUSING AND SECURITY AND ON THE
BRINK OF HOMELESSNESS BY ADDING
AN OPERATIONALIZED IN. A NEW
DEFINITION TO A HOUSING LAW
IT'S A WAY THAT WE CAN TARGET
OUR SCARCE RESOURCES AND WITH
THAT DIRECTLY IMPACTS THOSE WHO
ARE MOST AT RISK OF FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS. RIGHT NOW
STATE LAW HAS FOUR CATEGORIES.
TO ADDRESS HOUSING INCOME
BRACKETS OFF THE MEDIAN INCOME
IN THE LOWEST ONE IS 00230%
THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR US. TO
UTILIZE ZERO TO FIFTEEN
PERCENTAGE CATEGORY AS WELL
THAT WE CAN TARGET OUR
RESOURCES WHERE THEY'RE MOST
NEEDED. THIS FRAMEWORKS
CURRENTLY BEING USED IN LOS
ANGELES IN L. A. COUNTY TO OVER
A HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS THAT FALL INTO THIS
CATEGORY. WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN TARGET OUR
RESOURCES WHERE THEY MATTER THE
MOST. WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
FAMILIES THAT ARE ON THE BRINK
OF LOSING THEIR HOME BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD A CAR PAYMENT
THEY CAN'T AFFORD A MEDICAL
EMERGENCY THEY CAN'T AFFORD ANY
CRISIS. HAVE THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED ESPECIALLY COMING OUT OF
THIS CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL ONLY SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRIME. MS
RIVAS HERE RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TEN FORTY THREE.
ALSO AS A PROUD JOIN AUTHOR-
YOU KNOW AS THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC- CONTINUES AND
EXACERBATED OUR CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING AND- HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS. WE MUST DO EVERYTHIN.
TO ASSIST OUR MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES AND I THINK AB FOR.
TEN FORTY THREE IS A STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION. I WANT TO THANK
MY NEW COLLEAGUE. FROM LOS
ANGELES. FOR HITTING THE GROUND
RUNNING AND ALREADY DIVING INTO
THIS POLICY ISSUE. AND MAKING A
DIFFERENCE. I ASK THAT YOU JOIN
US IN THIS EFFORT- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS REAVIS AND
WITH THAT. CLARK CALL THE ROLL
THERE'S A. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE CONCERNED
ABOUT. WELL. CLOSE ROTH IRAS
FIFTY. NO SEVENTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE OING TO
MOVE TO TAKE UP MR TANG'S ITEMS.
THIS FIRST ITEM IS FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY NINE SIXTY
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO AB
NINE SIXTY BY MR TANG CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE NINE SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLY BUT RETAINING
ACCORDING TO PAROLE MISTER K.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER QUITE
OFTEN WHEN WE DO THE STATE'S
BUDGET. THERE'S ALWAYS A
RESOURCE THAT PEOPLE WANT MORE
OF. IT OFTEN PEOPLE HAVE A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME ACTUALLY
IDENTIFY AREAS WHERE THEY WANT
TO CUT. IN THE STATE BUDGET.
THE ONLY ITEM THAT GENERALLY
EVER COMES UP IS PEOPLE WOULD
LIKE US TO SPEND LESS MONEY ON
OUR CORRECTION SYSTEM. PARTLY
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T WORK THAT
WELL PARTLY BECAUSE IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE AND PARTLY BECAUSE WE
INCARCERATED WAY WAY TOO MANY
PEOPLE. WELL THIS LAST YEAR WE
SAW REALLY HOW SCARY IT WAS
WHEN YOU DON'T DO OR ARE ABLE
TO TAKE CARE OF YOUR CORRECTION
SYSTEM WITHOUT HOPE IT SPREAD
THROUGH OUR PRISON SYSTEM. WE
SAW TWO HUNDRED FOURTEEN PEOPLE
DIE OVER FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
CONTRACTED COVERT. A. B. NINE
SIXTY STREAMLINES PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE COST
AREAS. IN OUR CORRECTIONS
SYSTEM WHICH IS REALLY AROUND
THE MEDICALLY FRAGILE INMATES.
AB SIXTY STREAMLINED OUR
MEDICAL PAROLE PROCESS IT
DETERMINES IN ADS CARE
CHARACTERISTICS TO ALLOW PEOPLE
TO BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAL
PAROLE WHICH IS. IF A PERSON
NEEDS HOSPICE CARE OR HAS
DEBILITATING PAIN OR
DEBILITATING DISEASES.
CHRONOLOGICAL AGE OR A
COMBINATION OF THESE FACTORS.
QUITE OFTEN THESE FOLKS ARE
GETTING MEDICAL PAROLE BECAUSE
THEY FRANKLY CAN'T MOVE CAN'T
FUNCTION FOR THEMSELVES. YET
EVEN THOUGH THIS IS ONE OF THE
MOST EXPENSIVE. THESE ARE SOME
OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE INMATES
TO TAKE CARE OF BETWEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN
ONLY FORTY EIGHT INDIVIDUALS
ACTUALLY GOT. MEDICAL PAROLE.
THIS BILL RELEASED HELPS TO
STREAMLINE THIS PROCESS. THE
BILL CORPORAL PLAN PANEL WILL
INCLUDE- PATIENTS PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN A CIVIL SERVICE
PSYCHOLOGIST OR SOCIAL WORKER.
A DIRECTOR OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AT THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE.
SERVICES AND AGAIN THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE FOR PAROLE BUT IT
JUST MAKES IT. A LITTLE MORE
FUNCTIONAL WITHOUT OUR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON A. B. NINE SIXTY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHANG. SEE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CARPAL
OF THE ROLE. THIS OUT OF IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A.
WELL
CLOSER ALL CHINA AS FORTY TWO
NOSE NINETEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MISTER KING WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TAKE UP THIS NEXT ITEM.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE IT UP
THIS IS FILE I'M TWENTY NINE
FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE MEMBERS.
MR TANG'S AB. THIRTEEN OH
EIGHT. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
OH EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUSTICE RECORDS MR TAKING A
MAKE IT ALL BUT- THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB THIRTEEN OH
EIGHT BUILDS UPON MY AB. TEN
SEVENTY SIX WHICH STREAMLINED
ART EXPUNGEMENT PROCESS. TOO
OFTEN PEOPLE HAVE CRIMINAL
RECORDS BUT THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
IN THE ABILITY TO EXPUNGE THEM.
QUITE OFTEN IT'S WAY TOO
COMPLICATED WAY TOO DIFFICULT
AND WAY TOO EXPENSIVE TO
ACTUALLY DO IT SO UNFORTUNATELY
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO HAVE THEIR
RECORDS EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO EXPLAINS THE- IMPACT
ABILITY GET HOUSING IMPACTS
ABILITY TO GET EMPLOYMENT. THIS
BILL PICKS UP WHERE MY ORIGINAL
BILL STARTED. AT THIS POINT WE
HAVE A STREAMLINED EXPUNGEMENT
PROCESS RUN OUT OF R. TWENTY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. STARS
STARTING FROM THIS POINT
FORWARD. WHEN WE ORIGINALLY DID
THE BILL WE WANTED TO GO FROM
HERE BACKWARDS TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE. NOW THAT WE HAVE
A DATABASE THAT'S BEING BUILT
THERE SHOULD BE A FAIRLY SIMPLE
PROCESS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR.
ON A. B. THIRTEEN OH WAIT JUST
TO GIVE PEOPLE A SIMPLE WAY TO
GET THEIR RECORDS EXPUNGED- AND
THEN ALSO IN A VERY STREAMLINED
WAY TO SUBMIT THAT THEY'RE
ARE TO BE ABLE TO DO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN CALENDAR.
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR MISTER
SPEAKER WITHOUT OBJECTION- IF
UNDER THIS PROCESS THIS
PROPOSED BY THE BILL IF THE
RECORD IS EXPUNGED WITH THE
SAME INDIVIDUALS HAVE THEIR
RIGHT TO POSSESS FIREARMS-
RESTORED. WELL IT'S A GOOD TIME
THE QUESTION I ACTUALLY DON'T
KNOW BUT I'M HAPPY TO. GET BACK
TO YOU ON THAT. MISTER COOPER
WE ARE RECOGNIZED I CAN
ACTUALLY ANSWER THE QUESTION
SO- ON THE CCW PERMITS THERE
ARE FOLKS THAT HAVE AVE THEIR
RECORDS EXPUNGED. AND GOTTEN
CCW PERMITS IN CALIFORNIA. THAT
IS A FACT. WAS THAT A MIKE DROP.
LEGISLATURE SO THAT SEE NO
ADDITIONAL. DISCUSSION OR MIKE
DROPS MISTER TEAM YOU MAKE
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH I JUST JUST
VERY QUICKLY AGAIN- THESE ARE
RIGHTS THAT PEOPLE READY HALF
WE'RE JUST MAKING GOVERNMENT
WORK A LITTLE BIT BETTER AND
EASIER FOR THEM WITHOUT RESPECT
FOR US RIGHT VOTE ON A. B.
THIRTEEN AWAY. CLICK LIBERAL
MEMBERS. IT IS OUT OF IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOTHES ARE ALL
TIED BUT I FORTY SIX NO SIXTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. LET'S SEE
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM THIRTY WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A FIVE THIRTY ONE
THIS IS MISTER BLOOMS A. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR CORRECT
SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AND
OTHERS NOT CLEAN SOLID WASTE
MISTER BLOOM EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT ALONG WITH-
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM LONG BEACH
A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR TO
IMMEDIATELY AND COMPREHENSIVELY
MODERNIZE THE CALIFORNIA
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
LAW I THINK IT'S WELL
UNDERSTOOD ON THIS FLOOR THAT
THE BOTTLE BILL IS IN NEED OF
ATTENTION STATUTORY CONSTRAINTS
OF LIMITED RECYCLING PAYMENTS
AT A TIME WHEN GLOBAL SCRAP
PRICES HAVE DECLINED AND THESE
TWO BLACK ONE TO FINANCIAL
PLEDGES HAVE. RESULTED IN THE
CLOSURE OF MORE THAN ONE
THOUSAND RECYCLING CENTERS IN
THE LAST FIVE YEARS LEAVING
MANY COMMUNITIES WITH FEW IF
ANY REMAINING CENTERS FOR
EXAMPLE MY DISTRICT HAS JUST
ONE REMAINING RECYCLING CENTER.
WITH THE CLOSURE OF RECYCLING
CENTERS HAS COME A DROP IN THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
RATE FROM 80% AS RECENTLY AS
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO LESS THAN
SEVENTY PERCENT. IN TWENTY
TWENTY THIS IS THE WRONG
DIRECTION IN AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
FOUR UPDATES PROGRAM RULES TO
SUPPORT EXPANDED AND INNOVATIVE
RECYCLING OPTIONS. WHILE
REINVESTING MORE THAN SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
IN UNREDEEMED FUNDS TO PROVIDE
TARGETED INCENTIVES FOR LOW
VOLUME COMMUNITY BASED
RECYCLING CENTERS ACROSS THESTATE. IT INCREASES FUNDING FOR
RURAL RECYCLING CENTERS TO
OFFSET HIGHER TRANSPORTATION
COSTS. AND IT PROVIDES MATCHING
LOANS TO BRING FIVE HUNDRED NEW
RECYCLING CENTERS TO UNSERVED
AND UNDERSERVED AREAS OF THE
STATE. LET ME BE CLEAR FUNDING
FOR THESE INCENTIVES COMES
EXCLUSIVELY FROM EXISTING
BEVERAGE INDUSTRY PAYMENTS AND
REDEEM FUNDS. WE CAN MODERNIZE
THIS IMPORTANT RECYCLING
PROGRAM QUICKLY AND SUSTAINABLY
WITHOUT ANY GENERAL FUND OR
RATEPAYER DOLLARS. THIS MEASURE
IS SUPPORTED. BY A REMARKABLE
COALITION OF RECYCLERS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS AND EVEN SOME IN THE
BEVERAGE SECTOR. I THANK YOU
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANKS FOR THE MISTER
FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR MOVING
FORWARD ON THIS. REALLY
TRAUMATIC EVENT WITH RECYCLING
WHEN THE WORLD MARKET CRASHED-
WHEN CHOI CHINA ACTUALLY
WOULDN'T RECEIVE ANY MORE OF.
THE GOODS THAT WE SENT. NOW ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I'M HOPING
FOR OUT OF THIS CONVERSATION IS
THAT WE WORK TOWARDS CREATING
AN ECONOMY IN OUR OWN STATE OF
RECYCLING INSTEAD OF SENDING
ALL OF OUR PRODUCTS OVERSEAS.
AND INCENTIVIZING THESE THESE
ECONOMIES. WE USE A CLEANER
TECHNOLOGY TO. ADVANCE THIS
PROCESS IN OUR OWN STATE.
REDUCING GHGS ARE ON SHIPPING
AND TRANSPORTATION AND ALL THAT
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE CREATE
REAL TIME JOBS ARE ARE MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IN CALIFORNIA I
APPLAUD THIS I HOPE THAT WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE TECHNOLOGY ADVANCES IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE DO OUR OWN
RECYCLING HERE. I ASKED FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE ADMISSIBILITY MAY CLOSE
IF YOU WISH THANK YOU AMEN TO
ALL OF THAT. AND WITH THAT
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS- DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS BETTER SERVER WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
NINE OH ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX BY MR
MEDINA. CAN COVERAGE SOME
PEOPLE FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND
OTHERS IMMACULATE IN THE SUIT
FINANCIALLY MR MEDINA THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX MODERNIZES
STREAMLINES AND EXPANDS ACCESS
TO THE LARGEST STATE FINANCIAL
SYSTEM. CAL GRANT SAYS TO.
CALIFORNIA'S FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM SUPPORTS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS
SEEKING POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND A BETTER LIFE
EVERY YEAR. NEVER THE LESS THIS
PROGRAM WAS DESIGNED SIX
DECADES AGO AND NO LONGER MEETS
THE NEEDS OF THE STATE'S
STRUGGLING COLLEGE STUDENTS.
NEARLY EVERY YEAR OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT DO NOT RECEIVE THE
AWARD. FOR THESE STUDENTS THE
LACK OF CAL GRANT SUPPORT CAN
BE THE DECIDING FACTOR BETWEEN
ATTENDING AND TAKING ON DEBT.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX WILL DO
THE FOLLOWING DAY. CONSOLIDATES
THE THREE CAL GRANTS IN TWO. I
KNEW CAL GRANT TWO AND A CAL
GRANT FOR PROGRAM THE CAL GRANT
TO WILL GUARANTEE AN AXIS AWARD
FOR ALL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WELL CAL GRANT FOR
WILL MAINTAIN A TUITION FEE
AWARD TO STUDENTS ATTENDING AN
ELIGIBLE FOUR YEAR INSTITUTION.
AB EIGHT FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
ALSO REMOVES. AGE LIMITS TIME
SINCE HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
AND GPA ELIMINATING THE NEED
FOR THE COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS. AND FINALLY AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX WILL ALIGN
STATE AND FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID
POLICIES TO CREATE A MORE
COORDINATED PPROACH TO
INVESTMENT IN COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY. I AM PLEASED TO
HAVE WORKED ON THIS FOR THE
PAST FEW YEARS WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SACRAMENTO
MISTER MCCARTY SENATOR LEYVA
STUDENTS GROUPS AND SEE SEX I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR MEDINA MR
MCCARTY. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
IS A- HUGE BILL FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR OUR
STUDENTS ARE COLLEGE STUDENTS.
WE KNOW TWO THINGS THAT COLLEGE
IS REALLY EXPENSIVE. FIVE TIMES
BECAUSE OF NON TUITION COSTS WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WE HAVE THIS
AMAZING CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT'S AN ENTITLEMENT IF YOU
APPLY WHEN YOU'RE A SENIOR IN
HIGH SCHOOL. BUT IF YOU APPLY
WHEN YOU'RE TWENTY YEARS OLD.
TWENTY FIVE TRYING TO GET YOUR
LIFE BACK ON TRACK AND GOING TO
COLLEGE AND APPLY FOR THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS. YOUR ODDS OF
GETTING A CAL GRANT ARE ONE AND
TWELVE. SO WE HAVE. A PROGRAM
THAT RASKIN'S ACCESS BERG CAL
GRANT. SO THIS BILL COUPLED
WITH OUR BUDGET ACTION WILL
MAKE COLLEGE MORE AFFORDABLE
AND ACTUALLY MAKE COLLEGE. DEBT
FREE IN CALIFORNIA NOT FREE
COLLEGE BUT DEBT FREE COUPLED
WITH OUR EXISTING CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS WITH EXISTING
RESOURCES STUDENTS CAN COULD BE
ABLE TO GO TO COLLEGE. GET A
DEGREE ALONG WITH USING THEIR-
FAMILY INCOME WHEN THEY FIRST
APPLY WORKING FIFTEEN HOURS A
WEEK AND NOT HAVE TO TAKE OUT
SO MUCH DEBT AND GRADUATE WITH
TWENTY OR THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN DEBT. THAT'S AN
ISSUE IMPACTING SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL I
APPLAUD MR MEDINA FOR LEADING
AND AGAIN THIS IS ALSO COUPLED
WITH OUR BUDGET PACKAGE THAT WE
JUST. A PASSED YESTERDAY IN THE
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CARTY MISTER
BENNETT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M
ARISE TO APPLAUD THE AUTHOR AND
THE OTHER- MEMBERS THAT HAVE
WORKED ON THIS BILL AND JUST
TO. APPLAUD THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN MAKING COLLEGE. TUITION
FREE ARE FREE VERSUS DEBT FREE
AND THE ONE IS ACHIEVABLE-
RIGHT NOW AND THAT IS WHY I
REALLY APPLAUD THE DISTINCTION
BEING MADE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MUCH BETTER SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. FOR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CARCLUB THE
ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSER ALL TIE THAT I
SIXTY NINE KNOWS ONE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS IN FILE
ORDER THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE AB FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX BY
MISTER MCCARTY CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS NOT LIVING REAL PROPERTY
MR MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS IS A BILL RELATED
TO RACIAL HOUSING COVENANTS
THAT STILL EXIST. AN IMPORTANT
BUT OCT BUT ACTUALLY-
DISAPPOINTING CHAPTER OF OUR
UNITED STATES IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY THAT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA MONICA ALSO DISCUSSED
YESTERDAY. THESE ARE
ESSENTIALLY THE WORDS ON
HOUSING DEEDS WHICH SAY
ESSENTIALLY WHITES ONLY- WE GOT
RID OF THOSE AND WATER
FOUNTAINS DECADES AGO BUT THEY
STILL EXIST WHEN PEOPLE GO AND
BUY A HOME OR GO THROUGH THEIR
DEEDS. OR THEIR- HOUSING
COVENANTS THIS BILL WILL TAKE
PRO ACTIVE STEPS TO REMOVE
THESE RACIST COVENANTS WHICH
ARE A PRIVATE AGREEMENTS
BARRING NON WHITES FROM
OCCUPYING OR OWNING HOMES. WELL
THESE ARE PRIVATE. DEALS
PRIVATE PRIVATE AGREEMENTS-
THEY WERE AN IMPORTANT TOOL BY
GOVERNMENT TO SEGREGATE
NEIGHBORHOODS. OF COURSE TODAY
THEY ARE UNENFORCEABLE ANY
LEGAL BUT THE REMAIN HOUSING
DOCUMENTS THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
I KNOW WHEN I BOUGHT MY FIRST
TIME IN TAL PARK TWENTY SO
YEARS AGO OUR REALTOR SAID HEY
YOU'RE GOING TO SIGN THIS BIG
STACK OF PAPERS NOW FOR YOUR
NEW HOME. I KNOW YOU'RE
BIRACIAL I KNOW YOUR WIFE IS
MEXICAN AMERICAN YOUR OF YOUR A
DIVERSE FAMILY DON'T DON'T READ
THOSE WORDS ON PAGE FIFTY SEVEN
THAT SAY SENSUALLY WHITES ONLY
SO WHAT WE DID WE WENT READ
PAGE FIFTY SEVEN. AND I
COULDN'T BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE
STILL IN THESE IN THESE
DOCUMENTS THAT EXIST TODAY WILL
THEY STILL ARE TODAY. SO IF
ANYTHING WE LEARNED THAT LAST
YEAR THE YEAR OF GEORGE FLOYD
IS TAKING A LOOK AT THE RACIAL
INJUSTICES THROUGHOUT OUR
COUNTRY AND ONE THING THAT WE
SHOULD DO IS REMOVE THESE
WHITES ONLY SIGNS LIKE THEY'RE
HAVING WATER FOUNTAINS
THROUGHOUT OUR HOUSING.
COVENANTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
THIS IS A COMPLEX ISSUE I
REALIZE THATWE HAVE PARTIES
THAT ARE ARE ARE WORKING WITH
THAT SOME ARE. PROPOSING A
DIFFERENT PATH- THE UNLESS
AMENDED AND WE'RE WORKING WITH
OUR- LAND TITLE ASSOCIATION THE
REALTORS TO MAKE SURE WE DO
THIS RIGHT. BUT THE FACT
REMAINS IS THAT. MOST FRANKLY
EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA AT THE
END OF THE INTERESTED PARTIES
IN THIS ONE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN GET RID OF THESE.
HARMFUL COVENANTS THEY'RE NOT
AN FORCIBLE BUT THE PAINFUL
MEMORIES. LINGER ON. MEMBERS
THIS WEEK WE ALL GOT A BOOK
FROM OUR LOCAL REALTORS IN OUR
OFFICE THAT. THIS TITLE THE
COLOR OF LAW. A FORGOTTEN
HISTORY OF HOW OUR GOVERNMENT
SEGREGATED AMERICA. PERMISSION
TO READ MISTER SPEAKER. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. JUSTICE ONE NOTE
FROM THAT I THINK JUST TALKS
ABOUT WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY. WE
AS A NATION HAVE AVOIDED
CONTEMPLATING REMEDIES BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT ARE
COMFORTABLE DELUSION THAT OUR
SEGREGATION HAS NOT RESULTED
PRIMARILY FROM. STATE ACTION
AND SO WE CONCLUDE THERE IS NOT
MUCH WE ARE REQUIRED TO DO
ABOUT IT. BUT ONCE IN TRENCHES
SEGREGATION IS DIFFICULT TO
REVERSE AND THE EASIEST COURSE
IS TO IGNORE IT. WHAT WILL THIS
BILL WILL MAKE SURE WE DON'T
IGNORE IT AND COME UP WITH
REMEDY SO INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS
CAN EASILY GO. TO OUR LOCAL
COUNTY OFFICIALS REMOVED THE
BERRIES IT CAN CHANGE THE
CONFIDENCE ON THE ROUND AND
ALSO WE CAN ADDRESS THE REST OF
THE BOOK THE HOUSING CALIFORNIA
HAS THESE CABINETS. MISTER
SPEAKER ASK YOUR IDOL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MCCARTY. SEEING
NO MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION
ON THIS BILL. CARCLUB RURAL.
ESERVER ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. WHAT
IS THAT ABOUT. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY TE
ICE FIFTY TWO NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO BE BACK IN THE FILE.
TO FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN THIS IS
MISS GONZALEZ IS AB. TWO FIFTY
SEVEN. FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
TWO FIFTY SEVEN Y MISS
GONZALES. AND THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIFTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORENA
GONZALEZ AND ACCOLADES OF THE
FOOD FACILITIES AND EMPLOYMENT.
THIS GONZALEZ YOU MAIL THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWO FIFTY
SEVEN BEGAN TO ADDRESS A LONG
STANDING ISSUE IN THE FAST FOOD
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY BOOK BY
ALLOWING WORKERS A VOICE ON THE
JOB THROUGH A STATE WIDE FAST
FOOD SECTOR COUNCIL MADE UP OF
EMPLOYERS WORKERS AND STATE
AGENCIES. THERE NEARLY FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX THOUSAND FAST
FOOD WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA SEND
70% OF WHOM ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR.
FAST FOOD WORKERS EXPERIENCE
SOME OF THE LOWEST WAGES IN THE
STATE ALONG WITH WAGE THEFT
HARASSMENT AND UNSAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS. AND DEMOCRATS ONLY
FURTHER MAGNIFIED THE
SYSTEMATIC PROBLEMS UCSF STUDY
FOUND THAT FOOD WORKERS FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS WERE SOME OF
THE MOST AT RISK OF CONTRACTING
DIE FROM POPE IN NINETEEN WITH
LINE COOKS TAKING THE TOP SPOT.
WORKERS HAVE FILED NUMEROUS
COMPLAINTS DOCUMENTING
VIOLATIONS OF COVERT SAFETY
MEASURES PUBLIC HEALTH LAWS AND
LABOR LAWS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
ESTABLISHMENTS 89% WERE NON
COMPLIANT WITH AT LEAST FIVE OF
SIXTEEN TO FIND ELEMENTS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE FOR
PREVENTING COVE IN NINETEEN.
ONE NOTABLE EXAMPLE A FAST FOOD
RESTAURANT LOS ANGELES
ILLEGALLY FIRED FOUR EMPLOYEES
WHO PROTESTED WORKPLACE
CONDITIONS THAT WERE UNSAFE FOR
MANAGING THE SPREAD CODED. HERE
IN SACRAMENTO- OUTGROW RATHER
WE HAD A MANAGER WHO ACTUALLY
REQUESTED PP FOR THE WORKERS IN
THE FACILITY BUT BECAUSE THE
OWNER OF THE MCDONALD'S DIDN'T
BELIEVE IN COALBED HE REFUSED
THAT MANAGER ACTUALLY ENDED UP
QUITTING UNFORTUNATELY THE
WORKERS WHO WORK THERE COULD
NOT HAVE A WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE THE
STANDARDS ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FIFTY SEVEN EMPOWERS WORKERS A
LARGE FAST FOOD ESTABLISHMENTS
WITH THE ABILITY TO SHAPE THEIR
OWN WORKPLACE STANDARDS THROUGH
A STATEWIDE FAST FOOD SECTOR
COUNCIL. THIS BILL HOLD
CORPORATE FRANCHISORS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ENSURING THE
FRANCHISEES COMPLY WITH HEALTH
SAFETY AND EMPLOYMENT STANDARDS
WE EXPECT ALL EMPLOYERS TO
ABIDE BY ADDITIONALLY AB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN WOULD PROHIBIT
RETALIATION AGAINST WORKERS WHO
SIMPLY EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT TO
FILE COMPLAINTS ABOUT UNSAFE
WORKING CONDITIONS. THE END OF
THE DAY WE CALL THESE WORKERS
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WOULD THEY
ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO WORK AND
FEED OUR FAMILIES WHILE WE
STAYED HOME IN CLOSE QUARTERS
WITH LOW PAY. AND OFTEN NO
BENEFITS THESE ARE WORKERS THAT
ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
STATE AND HAVE NEVER HAD A
VOICE ON THE JOB. BECAUSE OF
THE STRUCTURE OF MANAGEMENT
THERE IS ALMOST NO WAY TO
ACTUALLY ORGANIZE FAST FOOD
WORKERS. IN THE ONLY WAY THEY
CAN HAVE A VOICE ON THE JOB IS
THROUGH THIS KIND OF SAID TWIRL
COUNCIL. EIGHT A COUNCIL THAT
WOULD GIVE THEM A VOICE ALONG
WITH THE CORPORATIONS AND THE
FRANCHISEES IN GOVERNMENT THE
PEOPLE WERE MAKING THE RULES.
ANYTHING THIS COUNCIL WOULD
DECIDE COULD ALWAYS BE UNDONE
BY THE LEGISLATURE IF IT WENT
TOO FAR. BUT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CHANGE THEIR
WORKPLACES WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A
FIFTEEN DOLLAR MINIMUM WAGE
THAT IS HAPPENING IN THE UNITED
STATES BECAUSE OF FAST FOOD
WORKERS BECAUSE THEY LEAD THE
WAY BECAUSE WE GAVE THEM A
VOICE IN THE MEDIA. TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN. BUT IT'S TIME THEY
HAVE A VOICE IN THE WORKPLACE
AS WELL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
CONSEILS MISPRINT HARBATH. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I WASN'T
TRYING TO SPUR US SPEAK OF THIS
ITEM. BUT I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
OF YOU HAVE EVER WORKED IN A
FRANCHISE. WHEN I WENT TO
BERKELEY I DO NOT HAVE MONEY I
WORK THREE JOBS. ONE OF THEM
WAS AT A SANDWICH SHOP. AND IF
YOU WANT TO TELL YOU KNOW
EXACTLY WHICH ONE ON BANCROFT
I'M TALKING ABOUT. I WAS
SEXUALLY HARASSED THERE. AND I
WAS WORKING FOR TWENTY FIVE WAS
LIKE I CN WORKING FOR TWENTY
FIVE MANY PLACES. I QUIT. AND
I'VE ALWAYS FELT QUITE GUILTY.
THAT I LET THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO
PUT IT DIDN'T HAVE THE OPTION
TO JUST QUIT AND GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE AND- VIDEOTAPE A HUNDRED
WORDS A MINUTE AND COULDN'T GET
THE EIGHTY DOLLAR DOLLAR JOB ON
CAMPUS- AND AT THE TIME IT
REFLECTIVE. VERY OFTEN ABOUT
THAT EXPERIENCE. BUT IF THERE
HAD BEEN A UNION THERE I WOULD
HAVE GONE TO THAT UNION REP AND
I WOULD HAVE BEEN PROTECTED. SO
WE THERE IS AND THIS IS THE
ROOM TOUCH CODE IT DOESN'T
TOUCH THIS. THERE ARE SOME
THINGS. I THINK WE NEED TO DO.
FOR THESE VERY VULNERABLE
WORKERS. THERE SOMETHING'S
ABOUT THIS BILL I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT. BUT WE KNOW WE HAVE A
AUTHOR WHO WORKS HARD. AND I
TRUST THAT WILL CONTINUE
WORKING TOGETHER. AS THIS GOES
TO THE SENATE SHOULD LEAVE THE
HOUSE TODAY. SO WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO IT TO GIVE THE OFFER
THE CHANCE TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON IT. BECAUSE OF PEOPLE LIKE
ME. NOT OF COLOR AND YOU CAN
IMAGINE. THOSE PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND OTHER WOMEN. AND MAYBE
TRANSGENDER FOLKS IN LGBT
FOLKS. WHO FEEL MORE
VULNERABLE. AND GIVE US A
CHANCE TO PROTECT THEM. THANK
YOU. THERE IS BOERNER HORVATH.
MR COOLEY. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I RISE ON THIS BILL
AND I HAVE. CERTAINLY NOT
LOOKING TO PICK A FIGHT WITH
ANY PART OF OUR STATE'S
WORKFORCE. BUT HONESTLY I LOOK
AT THIS BILL AND I'VE BEEN
LOOKING A BILL FOR MORE THAN
FORTY YEARS AND I JUST FIND IT
SHOCKING. AND I SORT OF FEEL ON
BEHALF OF THE MEMBERSHIP I HAVE
TO SAY I FIND IT SHOCKING. THIS
BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A COUNCIL
COMPRISED OF ELEVEN INDIVIDUALS.
ANY SIX OF WHOM CAN PASS A
POLICY. BY STATUTE. THIS THE
POLICIES ADOPTED BY THE SIX
PEOPLE. OVERRIDE AND ALL OF
FIGHT ANY REGULATIONS IN THIS
SPACE. THEY OVERRIDE STATUTES.
SO WE ARE A SOCIETY COMMITTED
TO THE RULE OF LAW. MEDIATED BY
INSTITUTIONS OF GOVERNANCE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND
LEGISLATURE. TO EMPOWER SIX
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE AUTHORITY
TO FEDERAL. AND JUST OVER RULES
THE STATUTE IS SHOCKING IT'S
SORT OF TO GO BACK TO ENGLAND
IT STARTS CHAMBER STUFF. DO YOU
HAVE A GROUP OF PEOPLE MAKING
RULINGS THAT ARE THEIR VIEW OF
WHAT'S RIGHT AND OVERRIDES%
EVERYTHING ELSE. IN THE FORTY
YEARS OF READING BILLS. I HAVE
NOT SEEN A PROVISION THIS
SWEEPING. AND SOLE UNDERMINING
OF THE RULE OF LAW. IT'S- I
JUST FEEL IT IS A SO BAD
FORMULA. AND IF THIS IDEA TAKES
ROOT HERE EVERY SECTOR WILL
LIKE THIS SORT OF THING. YOU
KNOW I BELIEVE THAT THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS THERE SHALL
BE NO LOCKS UP BY STATUTE THE
STATUTE OF STEP BY BILL IT RUNS
THROUGH THE TWO HOUSES IT'S
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR TO
CONFER UPON ANY BODY THIS SORT
OF VAST AUTHORITY AND IT'S-
IT'S JUST. EXTERNALLY
PROBLEMATIC- PERMISSION TO READ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. VERBATIM
FROM THE BILL THE COUNCIL FOR
PROVIDE DIRECTION TO AND
COORDINATE WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
SECOND BRANCH AGENCIES LOCAL IS
REGARDING HEALTH SAFETY
EMPLOYMENT A FAST FOOD
RESTAURANT WORKERS THE COUNCIL
SHALL PROMULGATE MINIMUM FAST
FOOD RESTAURANT EMPLOYER
STANDARDS INCLUDING AS
APPROPRIATE STANDARDS ON WAGES
WORKING CONDITIONS AND TRAINING
AS A REASON THAT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE TO PROTECT THOSE
FOR THE WELFARE PRESS FOR
RESTAURANT WORKERS- TO THE
EXTENT THERE IS A CONFLICT
BETWEEN STANDARDS RULES
REGULATIONS. ISSUED BY THE
COUNCIL. AND THE RULES OR
REGULATIONS ISSUED BY ANOTHER
STATE AGENCY. THE STANDARD
RULES OR REGULATIONS ISSUED BY
THE COUNCIL SELLER PRIVATE FAST
FOOD RESTAURANT WORKERS. AND
FRANCHISEES ARE FRENCH DOORS
SOURCE AND THE CONFLICTING
RULES OR REGULATION OF THIS
DIVISION AGENCIES SHALL NOT
HAVE FORCE OR- EFFECT. WITH
RESPECT TO- RESTAURANT WORKER
FRANCHISEE'S DECISIONS MADE BY
THE COUNCIL REGARDING THE
STANDARDS SHALL BE MADE BY
AFFIRMATIVE VOTE OF AT LEAST
SIX. OF THE COUNCIL MEMBERS IS
ONLY ELEVEN. SO A SIMPLE
MAJORITY OF ELEVEN. MAKE THESE
RULES OVER ACT SO I JUST FEEL
THIS IS SUCH A BAD. CONCEPTION
FOR THE RULE OF LAW SO I'M SORT
OF STAND WITH THE MAGNA CARTA
AND AGAINST STAR CHAMBER IN ANY
SETTING. THAT'S NOT TO SAY
THERE IS NOT. LEGITIMACY ON
BEHALF OF PEOPLE IN OUR SOCIETY.
BUT I JUST FEEL I HAVE TO STAND
UP AND OBJECT TO THIS BECAUSE
THE WAY IT'S PUT TOGETHER.
ORIGINAL. HAMISH COOLEY DR
QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I'M I
AM NOT YET DECIDED BUT I HAVE
THE SAME CONCERN IS MR COOLEY.
IF THE AUTHOR IS WILLING TO SAY
IN HER CLOTHES THAT YOU'LL TAKE
THAT PART OUT THEN I CAN GO UP.
OTHERWISE I CAN'T. THE OTHER
CONCERN I HAVE IS THERE SIMPLY
ISN'T ENOUGH ENFORCEMENT EVEN
FOR CURRENT LAW. EVEN FOR
CURRENT LAWS. AND I WOULD ASK
THE AUTHOR THAT YOU WORK TO
GET. BETTER ENFORCEMENT TO GET
MORE INSPECTORS OUT THERE TO
GET MORE PEOPLE TO ENFORCE THE
LAWS WE HAVE ALREADY. IF YOU
CAN ADDRESS THOSE TWO IN YOUR
CLOTHES I MAY BE ABLE TO GO UP
THANK YOU. I THANK THE COURT
MISS CARILLO. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKERS AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FIVE SEVEN
THE FAST RECOVERY ACT IN BEHALF
OF WORKERS IN THE FIGHT FOR
FIFTEEN AND A UNION IN FACT
WHEN I WAS WITH THE C. I. U. A
FEW YEARS AGO THIS IS WHEN WE
LAUNCHED THE FIGHT FOR FIFTEEN
WHEN I WAS A MEMBER OF SEIU
UNITED LONG TERM CARE WORKERS
NOW PART OF THIS YEAR YOU
TWENTY FIFTEEN. AND IN FACT
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE THAT WE
CAN DISCUSS AROUND THAT BUT
THAT'S CALIFORNIA LOOKS TO
RECOVER FROM THE PAD PANDEMIC
THE STATE FACES A VERY REAL
CROSSROADS RETURNED TO THE
SCHOOL THE STATUS QUO OR
REVITALIZED CALIFORNIA BY
EMPOWERING AND PROTECTING THE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO CARRIED
US THROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC
DURING THE DEPTHS OF KOVAN
NINETEEN WHEN RESTAURANTS WERE
FORCED TO SHUT DURING GROCERY
SHELVES WERE EMPTY HALF A
MILLION CALIFORNIA FAST FOOD
WORKERS TO PUT ON THEIR
UNIFORMS TO FEED THEIR FAMILIES
FROM BEHIND THEIR COUNTERS
GRILLS. AND DRIVE THROUGH
WINDOWS THEY DID SO IN THE FACE
OF HARROWING CONDITIONS LIKE
BEING GIVEN DOGGIE DIAPERS AS
MASS BEING DENIED PAID SICK
LEAVE OR QUARANTINE PAY AND
EVEN RETALIATION WHEN THEY
SPOKE UP AGAINST THESE ISSUES
LARGE FAST FOOD COMPANIES LIKE
MCDONALD'S ARE NOT POSITION TO
RETURN TO PRE PANDEMIC PROFIT
LEVELS WITH GROWTH EXPECTING.
MOVING FORWARD. I PERHAPS MANY
OF YOU KNOW BUT I ACTUALLY
WORKED FOR MCDONALD'S WHEN I
WAS A TEENAGER. AND I STILL
HAVE MY- MY- NAME BADGE- THERE
IS A VERY REAL STEREO TYPE WHEN
IT COMES TO THE WORKERS AT FAST
FOOD RESTAURANTS. THAT THEY ARE
TEENAGERS PART TIME FAST FOOD
WORKERS. BUT HERE IS THE REAL
PICTURE AND MANY OF THOSE I WAS
SEVENTEEN AT THE TIME MANY OF
THOSE WERE MY COLLEAGUES. WOMEN
MAKE UP TWO THIRDS OF THE FAST
FOOD WORKERS NATIONWIDE. ONLY A
QUARTER OF FAST FOOD WORKERS
ARE TEENAGERS WHICH IS ABOUT
25% 80% OF THE WORKFORCE IS
MADE OF LATINO BLACK API AND
IMMIGRANT WORKERS. THESE
NUMBERS ARE. THE MAY INCOME
EARNERS OF. STE AND- IN REFLECT.
THE COMMUNITY HARDEST HIT BY
THE PANDEMIC INCLUDING MY OWN.
IN STEERING CALIFORNIA TOWARD
AN EQUITABLE RECOVERY WE CANNOT
LEAVE BEHIND ESSENTIAL WORKERS
LIKE THE MEN AND WOMEN. WHO
MAKE UP THE FAST FOOD INDUSTRY
AND THAT IN OUR STATE THEY HAVE
SERVED US. AND NOW WE MUST
RETURN. THAT FAVOR BY HELPING
THEM GAIN A STRONG VOICE AND- A
WAY TO HOLD. THEIR BOSSES
ACCOUNTABLE. MANY OF THEM HAVE
BEEN LEFT BURNT VULNERABLE THEY
HAVE BEEN LEFT ALONE. THEY HAVE
BEEN LEFT WITHOUT RESOURCES
MANY OF THEM DID NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE COVERT NINETEEN.
TESTING MUCH MORE SO THE COVERT
NINETEEN VACCINE WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON EQUITY EFFORTS WHEN IT
COMES TO THOSE EFFORTS. THIS IS
WHY WE ARE HERE TODAY OUR WORK
IS TO REPRESENT THE PEOPLE THAT
DON'T HAVE LOBBYIST. THAT DON'T
HAVE POWER IN THIS BUILDING
THAT'S HOW WE MAKE THIS HOUSE
THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE BY
PROTECTING AND ENSURING THAT
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. THAT WORKED
AND SUFFERED THE MOST
THROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC ARE AT
THE FOREFRONT OF THE COME
CONVERSATION WHEN IT COMES TO
EQUITY. AND PROTECTION THIS IS
WHY I'M SUPPORTING THIS BILL
THIS IS WHY I URGE ALL OF YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL LET'S NOT
JUST TALK ABOUT ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND PROTECTING THEM.
BUT LET'S ACTUALLY DO IT AND
LET'S DO IT BY VOTING I AM AB
TWO FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS CHRISTMAS KALRA. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. IN A LITTLE
OVER A YEAR AGO I WAS AT A
MCDONALD'S AT FIVE AM AS A
NUMBER OF WORKERS THAT ARE
GOING ON STRIKE- FOR THE WEEK.
WENT ON STRIKE SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE THIS IS AS COLD IT WAS
REALLY HITTING US HARD AND THE
PARTICULAR RESTAURANT DIDN'T
HAVE ANY SAFETY PRECAUTIONS
WEATHER SPORTS A GLASS OR
PROPER SANITATION EQUIPMENT OR
WHAT HAVE YOU. SO THE WORKERS
COURAGEOUSLY WENT ON STRIKE.
THEY RETURNED ON THAT FRIDAY AT
FIVE AM. AND TO THEIR DELIGHT
THE MANAGEMENT ACTUALLY DID PUT
HIM MEASURES FOR THEIR SAFETY
NOW THAT WAS A GOOD CASE
SCENARIO GOOD OUTCOME THE MAD
THE THAT RUSSIA COULD EASILY
JUST INSPIRED THEM. ABOUT A
BEEN THE END OF THE STORY. AND
THE REALITY IS THAT FOR SO MANY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS. OF OUR
WORKERS THAT IS HOW THEY LIVE
THEY LIVE AT THE WHIM. OF WHAT
THEIR EMPLOYER CHOOSES TO DO OR
NOT. AND YOU KNOW WE CAN HAVE
THIS TALK ABOUT- FOR FORTY
YEARS THIS OUT OF THE OTHER.
BLESSED RECORD HOP WHAT'S
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST FORTY
YEARS FOR WORKERS TO OUR FAST
FOOD WORKERS TWELVE. WE'LL GO
WAGE WORKERS OVER THE LAST
FORTY YEARS. THEY HAD BECOME
LESS SOME POWER. THEY HAVE
THEIR WAGES HAVE REMAINED
STAGNANT EVEN WITH US
INCREASING MINIMUM WAGES STILL
HASN'T KEPT UP. WITH THE COST
OF LIVING INCREASES. AND THIS
PROPOSAL IS ACTUALLY. A VERY
THOUGHTFUL WAY FOR US TO CREATE
INDUSTRY WIDE STANDARDS WHERE
THEY DID WHERE IT DOESN'T EXIST
RIGHT NOW. AND SO IT'S NOT SOME
FAR FETCHED IDEA OF QUITE THE
OPPOSITE IT'S ACTUALLY A VERY
THOUGHTFUL WAY. OF HELPING TO
GUIDE OUR STATE HOPING TO GUIDE
OSHA- BUT WHICH WE ALWAYS GOT I
JUST OF THE BILL LAST YEAR THAT
WAS SIGNED THAT DIRECTED
ACTIONS THAT OSHA NEEDS TO TAKE
IN TERMS OF PROTECTING WORKERS.
SO THIS IS NOT UNCOMMON AND I
THINK IT'S ACTUALLY MUCH MORE
THOUGHTFUL THAN US HAVING TO
COME BACK EVERY YEAR AND DO ONE
OFF BILLS HERE ONE OF BILLS
THERE INSTEAD WE WILL ACTUALLY
HAVE. A COUNCIL. THAT WE HAVE.
THROUGH OUR SPEAKER. THE
ABILITY TO APPOINT. FOLKS WITH
EXPERTISE IN THESE AREAS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. TO ADVISE AS TO
WHAT INDUSTRY WIDE STANDARDS
MAKE THE MOST SENSE AND I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE I WOULD LIKE
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AS WE NEED
MORE MORE OSHA INSPECTORS
ABSOLUTELY SIGN ME UP. WE NEED
TO PUT MUCH MORE IN TWO
INSPECTORS OSHA INSPECTORS WE
NEED MULTI LINGUAL OSHA
INSPECTORS FAR MORE THAN WE
HAVE NOW SO I ABSOLUTELY WILL
COSIGN THAT AND IF THIS BILL-
IS SUCCESSFUL AND IS SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR OUR NEXT STEP
SHOULD BE ABSOLUTELY TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES WE GIVE TO OSHA AS WE
SEE IN THIS PANDEMIC. IS THAT
LACK OF ABILITY FOR OSHA TO DO
INSPECTIONS THAT HAS LED. TO
NOT BE ABLE TO KEEP UP WITH SO
MANY OF THE SAFETY STANDARDS
FALLING BELOW BUT WE SHOULD ALL
BE CONSUMED WILL BE SHUT OFF
CONSIDERED THE STATUS QUO AND
SO. THERE'S A REASON WHY THE
NUMBER ONE PROFESSION THAT'S
DIED DURING TWELVE IT OR COOKS
THESE ARE COOKS A FANCY
RESTAURANTS. YOU KNOW OF YOUR
FOUR STAR RESTAURANTS. THE ARE
CLOSE ABOUT WOULD REST THAT
HAVE BEEN. THE NUMBER ONE
PROFESSIONALS DIED FROM COLD.
AND SO IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT WE
HAVE WILL BE PUT IN PLACE. AND
ACTUALLY ORGANIZED A MECHANISM
TO PUT FORTH HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS FOR THE FAST FOOD
SECTOR. AND SO YOU KNOW. I GET
I GET AGAIN LET'S NOT FALL INTO
THIS. FEAR MONGERING TRAP THAT
SOMEHOW THIS IS SOME. YOU KNOW
VOTED GOVERNMENT OVER REACH IS
QUITE THE OPPOSITE THIS IS A
WAY FOR US. TO PROTECT THOSE.
IN OUR PUBLIC THOSE THAT ARE
WORKING EVERY SINGLE DAY. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE- THAT WE- CAN
REMAIN SAFE SO WITH THAT I
HEARD YOUR AYE ABOUT. THINGS
KALRA MR SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. LOOK I APPRECIATE
THE ROBUST DEBATE FOR AGAINST
IN THOSE WHO HAVEN'T MADE A
DECISION YET. AND WHAT I WANT
TO REMIND EVERYBODY IT IS WE
SPENT A YEAR OR SO. TALKING
ABOUT EQUITY. BUT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN NEIGHBORHOODS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IS EVERYTHING BUT EQUITY. LET'S
TALK ABOUT PEOPLE WHO HAD TO GO
TO WORKING KERN ZOOM
COMFORTABLY FROM HOME. LET'S
TALK ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE FIRED
THAT THEY NEED MASKS. LET'S
TALK ABUT THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO STILL
HAD TO SHOW UP TO WORK. AND
BARELY MADE A MINIMUM WEIGHT.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT. FOLKS
WHO IN MANY CASES WHO OWN HOMES.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOLKS WHO
ARE CONTINUOUSLY CUT HOURS
DURING THE WORST OF A PANDEMIC.
AND WE ALL WANT TO SEE I GET IT
WILL WANT TO SEE SMALL
BUSINESSES CONTINUE TO THRIVE
IN CALIFORNIA. BUT THEN I WILL
ADMIT THAT THEY ARE GOOD ACTORS
OUT THERE NO WAS NEGATING THAT.
BUT WHAT WE SAW ACOSTA CALVIN
WHAT WE SAW IN OUR BACKYARDS
WHAT I SAW IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
WHERE THE LARGE CHAIN FAST FOOD
COMPANIES WHO MADE HISTORIC
PROFITS BECAUSE WHEN WE ALL
DROVE AROUND OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
WE SAW. THAT DOES IN SOME CASES
A SMALL BUSINESSES CLOSED. THE
ONES WHO MADE ON PRESIDENT OF
PROFITS WERE THE ONES WHO ALSO
TREATED IN MANY CASES THE
WORKERS THE WORST AND WE SAW
THIS. WE SPENT OVER A YEAR
TALKING ABOUT EQUITY. WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IN THIS BILL
IS BASIC RIGHTS. SO THAT WHEN
SOMEBODY ASKS FOR MASKS OR
SOMEBODY SAID THAT THEY MAY BE
UNHEALTHY WORK STANDARDS BUT
THEY'RE NOT FIRED BUT THEY'RE
NOT REDUCED HOURS. WHEN
SOMEBODY ASKED FOR DIGNITY AT
WORK. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO COULDN'T ZOOM. WHO
BARELY MADE A MINIMUM WAGE WHO
COULDN'T PAY THEIR BILLS. AND
WE'RE ALL SET WE DON'T WANT TO
GO BACK TO THE NORMAL THIS
PANDEMIC IS OVER. AND THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE THOSE.
JOBS. WHO WERE HIT THE HARDEST
DURING A PANDEMIC. GIVE US THE
ABILITY. GIVE US THE ABILITY.
TO PROTECT LOW INCOME EARNERS.
CALLING COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
GIVE US THAT ABILITY BECAUSE
THERE'S NONE OF THAT WAS NO
PROTECTION DURING A PANDEMIC
AND THERE ARE NO PROTECTIONS IN
MANY CASES FOR MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHEN THEY GO TO
WORK. LOOK ALL SAY THAT'S
BECAUSE MOST OF YOU GUYS KNOW
MY HISTORY MY PARENTS CAME HERE
THERE ARE UNDOCUMENTED. YEAH MY
DAD MY DAD CLEAN TAPE. CLEAN
TABLES AT A RESTAURANT AND-
EVENTUALLY HE BECAME THE GUY
WHO FLIPPED THE BURGERS AND I
WAS A BIG DEAL FOR US AT HOME.
BECAUSE SOMETIMES WHEN THERE
WAS FOOD LEFT OVER SOMEBODY TO
WANT YOU TO GET HOME WE HAD. WE
ARE NOT LOOK WE ARE LOOKING TO
PROTECT. THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WORK EXTREMELY HARD AND HAVE NO
PROTECTIONS AND PUT THEIR LIVES
ON THE LINE DURING A PANDEMIC.
GIVE US THAT OPPORTUNITY. TO
HAVE A BID TO GIVE A VOICE TO
THOSE. WHO JUST DON'T HAVE IT.
FORTUNATELY MOST OF US HERE.
WELL SINCE THE MOST OF US HERE
HAVE HAD THE ABILITY TO ZOOM IN
MANY CASES FOR THE THINGS THAT
WE DO. AND WE'VE BEEN BLESSED
TO DO THAT. BUT WHEN YOU'RE A
MINIMUM WAGE WORKER. AND YOUR
KIDS ARE DEPENDING ON YOU TO
PAY FOR RENT AND FOOD AND MANY
OF THE KIDS IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
ONCE I WENT HUNGRY EVERY NIGHT.
THEY DON'T OFTEN HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO DO OR THAT VOICE.
AND THIS BILL WILL GIVE THEM
THAT VOICE. TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. WHEN THEY GO TO
WORK. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE AFTER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
SANTIAGO MR KILEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I THINK THAT THE ISSUES
RAISED BY THIS BILL AND WITH
RESPECT TO THIS PARTICULAR
SECTOR ARE NOT WITHOUT MERIT
AND THAT'S NOT EVEN TO MENTION
ALL THE STUFF THAT'S BEING PUT.
IN OUR FOOD- BUT I DO THINK
THAT THIS IS A BAIL WHERE ALL
OF THE ARGUMENTS IN FAVOR ARE
ACTUALLY ARGUMENTS AGAINST FOR
THE REASON CITED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RANCHO CORDOVA
THAT IF THESE PROBLEMS REALLY
ARE SO SEVERE THAN THEY DESERVE
TO BE TREATED WITH THE DIGNITY.
OF THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WHICH CAN PRODUCE CHANGE IT IS
NOT JUST LEGAL AND JURIDICAL
BUT CULTURAL IS MORE DURABLE
MORE MEANINGFUL. WHEREAS WE
ABDICATE OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
SOME UNELECTED BOARD THAT
ACTUALLY MINIMIZES THE ISSUES
THAT ARE AT STAKE I SUGGESTED
OF A- I THINK AVERAGE KELLY
MISTER SMITH. YOUR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I
RISE IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN. THIS BODY IS
KILLED MANUFACTURING JOBS IN
THE STATE. AIRLINE JOBS IN THIS
STATE. CONSTRUCTION JOBS IN
THIS STATE AND NOW WE'RE GOING
AFTER MINIMUM WAGE JOBS THE
FRANCHISEES IN EVERYONE OF OUR
DISTRICTS IS OWNED BY A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER. IT'S NOT THE
BIG GOLDEN ARCHES OR THE BURGER
KING OR WHATEVER BIG FRANCHISE
THEY ARE OWNED BY INDIVIDUAL
FAMILIES IN OUR DISTRICT. I'VE
SAT HERE AND I'VE LISTENED AND
I'VE LISTENED AND WE KEEP
KILLING JOBS IN CALIFORNIA. THE
MINIMUM WAGE JOB IS NOT A
CAREER. TO PAY FOR YOU TO GO TO
SCHOOL IT'S PAY FOR YOU WHEN
YOU'RE OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
TRANSITIONING INTO COLLEGE.
IT'S NOT A CAREER BUT WE P. PUT
REGULATIONS ON THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS SO WHEN THEY
CLOSE THE NEXT FRANCHISE IN
YOUR DISTRICT. YOUR GOAL WHAT
HAPPENED WE KEEP COULDN'T SO
MANY REGULATIONS ON THESE
BUSINESS OWNERS THEY CAN'T TAKE
IT NO MORE. I VERGE A NO VOTE
ON THIS BILL. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM MS GONZALEZ YOU MAY
CLOSE ALL RIGHT I WANNA BE VERY
CLEAR I WISH THAT SOME FOLKS
WHO SPOKE ON THE FLOOR WOULD
COME ASK ME BEFOREHAND BUT I
I'LL BE VERY CLEAR NUMBER ONE
THE APPOINTMENT TO THIS BOARD
IF YOU WILL PROVIDE SIX
LEGISLATIVE APPOINTEES OF THE
ELEVEN THE OTHER FIVE COME FROM
THE GOVERNOR THIS IS NOT JUST
SOME RANDOM BOARD THAT THAT
WILL MAKE DECISIONS. AND IT'LL
INCLUDE CORPORATE FRANCHISE OR
FRANCHISEES AND WORKERS ALSO
INCLUDES OSHA AND LABOR
COMMISSIONER BECAUSE IT'S TRUE
WE DO NEED BETTER ENFORCEMENT
OF EXISTING LAWS WE DO NEED
BETTER LAWS QUITE FRANKLY AND
ALL OF THESE ARE PROBLEMS. IN
THE PAST WHEN THE REASONS IT'S
SO IMPORTANT FOR THE WORKER TO
HAVE EIGHT A SECTORIAL COUNCIL
IS WE'VE NEVER PROVIDED WORKERS
WITH THE VOICE YES WE CAN PASS
THINGS HERE. AND I CAN TELL YOU
WHAT THE WORKERS THINK ARE ONCE
BUT UNTIL THE WORKERS
THEMSELVES HAVE A VOICE IT'S
POINTLESS. THEY'RE NOT
EMPOWERED TO SUGGEST IT LIKE WE
HEARD FROM PEOPLE WHO WORKED.
IN FAST FOOD RESTAURANTS TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT IT IS THAT
THEY'RE FACING TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT IT IS THAT THEY NEED AND
WHAT TYPES OF SUPPORT THEY
NEED. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEKING
TO DO IN THIS BILL. I AM MORE
THAN HAPPY I DON'T KNOW OUR
DOCTOR COURT- MY COLLEAGUE-
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SINCE I'M
SO GOOD WHICH WELL I THINK. AND
I AM ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON A PIECE OF
LEGISLATIVE RUBIO AND I
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT MAKES
PEOPLE NERVOUS RIGHT WE'RE NOT
USED TO SAYING. ARE WE DON'T
THINK WE'RE USED TO SAYING A
COUNCIL COULD MAKE THESE
DECISIONS BUT I DO WANT TO
REMIND THIS THIS FLOOR. THAT
FOR NINETY YEARS IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAD A WAGE BOARD FOR NINETY
YEARS AND APPOINTED WAGE BOARD
THAT MADE ALL THE DECISIONS. ON
ON WAGE ORDERS. THIS IS NOT A
NEW IDEA IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE TOOK IN FACT FROM THOSE WAGE.
ORDER THE WHAT THE WAGE BOARD.
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS
BECAUSE THE UNITED STATES HAS
NEVER SEEN SOMETHING LIKE THIS
WE'VE NEVER REALLY EMPOWERED
WORKERS TO HAVE A VOICE
THROUGH. A SECTORIAL COUNCIL.
WHAT OTHER COUNTRIES DO. AND
QUITE FRANKLY IT WORKS QUITE
WELL THE FACT IS REMOTE REMIND
BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
BARBARA. SAID IN OTHER
COUNTRIES AT THE SAME
RESTAURANTS. THEY THEY ARE
EITHER WORKERS PROBABLY NOT
TWICE AS MUCH AS THEY DO HERE
BECAUSE THEY NOT ONLY GET WAGE
INCREASES BUT THEY ALSO HAVE
PAID SICK DAYS AND HOLIDAYS IN
HEALTH CARE. IN A BIG MAC COSTS
ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN CENTS MORE.
ALL RIGHT SO THERE ARE THIS
SEEMS TO WORK IN OTHER PLACES.
TAILORING IT TO FIT WHAT WE'RE
USED TO AND WHETHER IT'S A
BARGAIN CONTRACT IF YOU WELL
OUR OUR OUR- GOT TO BE CAREFUL
HOW WE SET IT EIGHT EIGHT
AVERAGE NEW REGULATIONS OR
WAGES. WE HAVE IN THE PAST
ALLOW PEOPLE TO GO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION AN COME BACK AND
GET IT RATIFIED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. THIS IS SOMETHING
WE CAN DO AND WE CAN LEAD THE
NATION BECAUSE GUESS WHAT
EVERYTHING EVERYBODY SAID WAS
TRUE YOU KNOW WHO DIED DURING
THE PANDEMIC. COOKS DIET COKES
THAT MCDONALD'S AND BURGER KING.
PEOPLE WHO MADE IT YOUR FOOD IN
ALLOWED YOU TO PICK IT UP
THROUGH A WINDOW AND GO HOME
AND BE SAFE WITH YOUR FAMILY
THAT'S WHO DIED. IT'S THE SAME
PEOPLE DURING THE TWO WHO CAME
TO US AND SAID HEY WE HAVE
PROBLEMS WE HAVE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PROBLEMS AND YOU
KNOW WHAT WE COULDN'T GET A
BILL OFFICE FLOOR. TO PROTECT
THOSE WORKERS WE PROTECTED
OURSELVES. WE PROTECTED THIS
INSTITUTION BUT WE NEVER SEEM
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE WILL TO
PROTECT THOSE WORKERS. SO IT'S
TIME AND- WE LOOK OURSELVES IN
THE MIRROR. AND SAY DO WE
ACTUALLY THINK THESE HUMAN
BEINGS. THESE MOTHERS AND
FATHERS AND KIDS AND BROTHERS
AND SISTERS DESERVE THE RESPECT
TO HAVE A VOICE ON THE JOB
DESERVE THE RIGHT TO TELL THEIR
STORIES ABOUT BEING SEXUALLY
HARASSED AT WORK ABOUT NOT
HAVING PP ABOUT BEING AN UNSAFE
WORKING CONDITION ABOUT BEING
RETALIATED WORK ABOUT NOT
HAVING ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY THE-
RENT. MAYBE WE COULD QUIT
PAYING PEOPLES RENT IT JUST
ENSURE THAT THEY MAKE ENOUGH
THAT THEY CAN PAY THEIR OWN DE
AMOR AT. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IT'S TIME WE
GIVE WORKERS A VOICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT BUT.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
RESEARCH PRESIDING VOTE.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF.
MS
GONZALEZ WAS A CALL. MEMBERS
BACK IN REGULAR FILE ORDER. I
BELIEVE WE LEFT OFF AT FILE
ITEM THIRTY FOUR WE'RE- GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY. ON FILE
ITEM THIRTY FOUR. AND PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS
THIRTY FIVE AND. THIRTY SIX. I
BELIEVE WE'RE- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TAKE ADAM UP MISS RIVAS.
SHOW THAT WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
A FILE I'M THIRTY FOUR MEMBERS
THIS IS AB TWENTY SEVEN BY MISS
RIVAS FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR. AB
TWENTY SEVEN. BY THREE OF US
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THREE OF US AND OTHERS IN
EQUITY THE HOMELESS CHILDREN
AND USE ANA UNACCOMPANIED
YOUTHS AND CLEARLY WAS HERE THE
CORRECT IMMEDIATELY.
THREE OF US YEAR ALBUM I THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SEVEN
A LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PRIORITY AND A BILL THAT IS
SPONSORED BY OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF EDUCATION. AB
TWENTY SEVEN IS THE
REINTRODUCTION OF LEGISLATION
FROM LAST YEAR AND CONTINUES TO
ESTABLISH A COMPREHENSIVE
POLICY APPROACH TO ASSIST LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TACKLING THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. THE BILL
ESTABLISHES A STANDARDIZED
PROCESS FOR IDENTIFYING
HOMELESS STUDENTS THIS MEASURE
ALSO CREATES THREE
GEOGRAPHICALLY LOCATED COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP. LOCAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS TO IMPLEMENT
BEST PRACTICES USED IN
IDENTIFYING AND CONNECTING
HOMELESS STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO SERVICES. OUR
CURRENT PROCESS FOR IDENTIFYING
HOMELESS CHILDREN FAILS TO GIVE
THEM A FIGHTING CHANCE TO
SUCCEED. A RECENT UCLA STUDY
FOUND THAT OVER TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY NINE THOUSAND STUDENTS IN
THE K. THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM IN
OUR STATE ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THIS IS ENOUGH TO
FILL DODGER STADIUM ALMOST FIVE
TIMES OVER. IDENTIFYING
CHILDREN WHO MIGHT BE HOMELESS
IS THE FIRST STEP TO ENSURING
THAT THEY HAVE A FIGHTING
CHANCE TO SUCCEED IN SCHOOL AND
IN LIFE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS RAMOS
SAYING NO DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. SEVERAL OF THE
ROAD. ALL MEMBERS ARE DESERVE A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE HI
BUT I SIXTY TWO KNOWS HERE ON
THE URGENCY I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
HERE ON THE MEASURE THAT BILL
PASSES. YEAH BACK IN FILE ORDER
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN
AB. THREE FIFTY. THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME WIGGLE FREE FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE APPROVED
ONE ACTIVITY TO AGRICULTURE. IT
SHOULD BE APPROVED BY. THANK
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THREE
FIFTY CREATES A THREE YEAR
PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR LANDOWNERS IN
CRITICAL OVERDRAFT BASINS TO
HELP EVALUATE THE IMPACTS ON
THE PROPERTIES FURTHER
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA. AND
CREATES MANAGEMENT PLANS TO
ACCESS ECONOMIC. VIABILITY AN
ALTERNATIVE TO USE FOR THEIR
PROPERTIES I RECENTLY READ
RECENTLY AMENDED THIS BILL TO
INCLUDE ALL CRITICAL AT
OVERDRAFT BASINS IN THE STATE
pOPPOSITION. THIS BILL HAS NO-
THIS BILL ENJOY THAT BARK
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
NO VOTES. I THINK I THINK WE
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. THE CARD CLUB THE
ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. ESERVER. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A HIGHS
FIFTY SEVEN. NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT WHERE
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE. AB SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE BY MISTER BERMAN
CORPORATION. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN AND OTHERS AND I
REALLY THE PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. MR BERMAN
HE MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES THIS
ONE'S A BIT OF A PASSION
PROJECT FOR ME COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE STEPPING UP TO
MEET THE BASIC NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS HOWEVER FINDING THESE
RESOURCES OFTEN INCLUDES
NAVIGATING DISCONNECTED
SYSTEMS. THAT CAN BE CONFUSING
FOR STUDENTS AB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE WILL PROVIDE A COORDINATED
AND INTEGRATED APPROACH TO MEET
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS BY
ESTABLISHING A BASIC NEED
CENTER AND BASIC NEEDS
COORDINATOR ON EVERY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU IS. FOR SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CABALLERO.
WE DESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSER
ALL TIED UP AS FIFTY EIGHT
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS
IS FILE ITEM FORTY AB NINE
FORTY FIVE AM MISTER RAMOS THE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS AND OTHERS AND I RELATING
TO PEOPLE'S MISTER ROBERTS YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
NINE FOUR FIVE. WHICH HELPS
INSURERS THE NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS CAN WEAR TRIBAL
REGALIA AT COMMENCEMENT
CEREMONIES STUDENTS ALREADY
HAVETHAT RIGHT UNDER THE U. S.
AND CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTIONS
BUT SOME LOCAL EDUCATION
OFFICIALS STILL OBJECT AND
BANNED OBJECTS OF CULTURAL OR
RELIGIOUS SIGNIFICANCE AT THE
CEREMONIES. THIRTY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND CIVIL RIGHTS
GROUPS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CONTINUED TO RECEIVE COMPLAINTS
FROM NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES ABOUT SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS WHO REFUSED TO
LET STUDENTS WERE TRIBAL
REGALIA. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN MY GOOD FRIEND OF
ALASKA NATIVE- TODD GLORIA WHO
NOW IS THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO MOVE FORWARD A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION A. B. TWELVE
FORTY EIGHT. HOWEVER THE
PROBLEM PERSISTS IN SPRING
TWENTY TWENTY FOR EXAMPLE THE
ACLU RECEIVED A COMPLAINT FROM
A MEMBER OF THE ARMENIAN ROOTS
AND TRIBE- WAS TOLD BY SAMBAR
DINO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT HE WAS NOT ALLOWED TO WEAR
AN EAGLE FEATHER AT HIS
GRADUATION CAP. EAGLE FEATHERS
ARE PRESENT FROM FAMILIES
MOVING FORWARD WHERE THEY'RE
EATING IN OUR CASE EATING A
MEAL AND PRESENTING THAT THAT
FEATHER TO THEM SO THAT BRINGS
THE WHOLE SPIRIT OF THE FAMILY
FORWARD IN A MAJOR
ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR EDUCATION IN
THE YOUNG PERSON'S LIFE. WE
SHOULD NOT HINDER THAT AS A
STATE WE SHOULD ALLOW PEOPLE TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
CARRYING THEIR CULTURE FORWARD
ESPECIALLY GREAT ACHIEVEMENTS
IN EDUCATION. AB NINE FORTY
FIVE WOULD CREATE A TEN MEMBER
TASK FORCE WITH NINE MEMBERS
THE TASK FORCE WILL BE CHARGED
WITH IDENTIFYING SOLUTIONS TO
THIS ONGOING PROBLEM AND BE
NAMED THE TASK FORCE TO STUDY
DEVELOP BEST PRACTICES TO
PROTECT PEOPLE RIGHTS PEOPLE'S
RIGHTS. TO WEAR TRADITIONAL
TRIBAL REGALIA OR RECOGNIZE
OBJECTS AS RELIGIOUS OR
CULTURAL SIGNIFICANCE AS AN
ADORNMENTS AT SCHOOL GRADUATION
CEREMONIES ALSO THE YUROK TRIBE
ONE OF THE LARGEST TRIBES HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA A
MEMBER WAS ALSO DENIED WEARING
TRADITIONAL REGALIA. I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE IN SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE TO
SHARE THEIR CULTURE MOVING
FORWARD. IN GREAT ACHIEVEMENTS
IN EDUCATION. THANK YOU MISTER
ROBERTS. SEEING NO MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
THE CLERK LEVEL THEY'RE ALL.
MEMBERS. WE DESIRE TO ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF A DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL YOU VOTE I FIFTY SEVEN
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES IN
FOLLOW ORDER THIS FOLLOWED
FORTY ONE AB TEN SIXTY SIX BY
MISTER BLOW. THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME PEOPLE TEN SIXTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AND
OTHERS AND I REALLY IN THE
WATER QUALITY. MISTER BELOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS WE'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH
THE BEACH REPORT CARD WHERE ONE
CAN LEARN WHETHER I'M THERE ARE
HARMFUL SUBSTANCES IN THE WATER
AT THE IN THE OCEAN WATER THAT
WE SWIM IN ITS UBIQUITOUS
AROUND THE STATE NOW WE'RE ALL
GRATEFUL FOR THAT INFORMATION.
WELL AB TWO TEN SIXTY SIX
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH BY
CREATING A UNIFORM SET UP
STATEWIDE MONITORING STANDARDS
AND PROTOCOLS FOR TESTING
BACTERIA IN HIGH USE FRESH
WATER BODIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. VERY SIMILAR TO THE
BEACH REPORT CARD WOULD BE
APPLIED TO HI USE FRESH WATER
BODIES ARE WOOD- BECOME COMMON-
A MONTH FRESH FRESH WATER
BODIES. THE FINDINGS WOULD THEN
BE POSTED IN A SINGLE PLACE FOR
WATER QUALITY DATA TO BE
PUBLICLY SHARED. AB TEN SIXTY
SIX REQUIRES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA WATER QUALITY
MONITORING COUNCIL IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS
AND THE PUBLIC TO PROPOSE TO
THE STATE WATER BOARD A
DEFINITION. OF A MONITORED
FRESH WATER RECREATION SITE ON
OR BEFORE DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THIS BILL
WILL ADDRESS A KEY PUBLIC
HEALTH CHALLENGE THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS FACE AN OUTDOOR
RECREATION AND THAT IS ENSURING
THAT THERE ARE SCIENCE AND
HEALTH BASED BACTERIAL
STANDARDS. ONGOING WATER
QUALITY MONITORING AND PUBLIC
MOST IMPORTANTLY PUBLIC
NOTIFICATION FOR FRESH WATER
RECREATION WHERE NEEDED BECAUSE
THE WATER ISN'T ALWAYS AS CLEAN
AS WE WOULD LIKE IT TO BE. AND
YOU NEED TO KNOW IF YOU'RE
GOING TO SWIM OR IF YOUR
CHILDREN ARE GOING TO BE
SWIMMING IN THAT WATER. WHAT'S
GOING ON. THE BILL WAS AMENDED
SIGNIFICANTLY IN APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND I BELIEVE THAT
THE CHANGES MADE THE- TO THE
BILL. WILL ALLEVIATE ANY
CONCERNS HOWEVER I'M COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK WHICH ONE. THE SEEING NO
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION.
CLICK LIBERAL. WE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS HER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MY RESEARCH SERVER.
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE EYES
FIFTY KNOWS EIGHT THAT MEASURE
PASSES. IN FILER THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY TWO AB ELEVEN THIRTY
BY DOCTOR WOULD. AND THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
AND OTHERS IMMACULATE IN THE
HEALTHCARE COSTS DR WOULD YOU
MAIL. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN THIRTY WHICH WILL CREATE
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WITHIN THE OFFICE
OF STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING
AND DVELOPMENT. ACCORDING TO
RECENT POLLS HEALTHCARE COSTS
ARE A SIGNIFICANT CONCERN IT
ONLY CONTINUE TO GROW EIGHT OUT
OF TEN CALIFORNIA SAY THAT
MAKING HEALTHCARE MORE
AFFORDABLE IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT OR VERY IMPORTANT
PRIORITY FOR THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE. THE CONCEPT OF
A COMMISSIONER OFFICE CHARGED
WITH COST CONTAINMENT IS NOT A
NEW ONE THERE ARE ALREADY SIX
STATES THAT HAVE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IN PLACE AND THEY'RE
SHOWING RESULTS SADLY
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ONE OF THOSE
STATES. THERE ARE HUGE
DIFFERENCES IN THE COST OF
HEALTHCARE IN DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE STATE WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHY IN PARTS F
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COSTS ARE
30% LOWER AND HEALTH CARE
OUTCOMES ARE BETTER. IN HIGHER
COST NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE PAY MORE AND GET LESS LESS
FAVORABLE OUTCOMES WE NEED TO
USE THIS INFORMATION TO
ENCOURAGE SYSTEM WIDE
IMPROVEMENTS. I KNOW THIS
CONCEPT MAKES PEOPLE ON ON
COMFORTABLE PARTICULARLY
STAKEHOLDERS. BUT THE COST OF
HEALTHCARE IS MAKING YOUR
CONSTITUENTS MORE THAN
UNCOMFORTABLE. THEY'RE WORRIED.
THEY'RE FRUSTRATED THEY'RE
ANGRY AND THEY'RE REACHING A
BREAKING POINT. OUR QUEST TO
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY ACCESSIBLE
AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE TO
EVERYONE WILL NEVER BE
SUSTAINABLE UNTIL WE CONTROL
THE GROWTH THE COST THE COST OF
GROWTH IN IN PROVIDING CARE.
HEALTH CARE COSTS ARE AFFECTING
EVERYTHING WAGES THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF FAMILIES DECISION
AS TO WHETHER STE TO SEEK CARE
OR CONTINUED KERR. PEOPLE ARE
WORKING LONGER IN STEYNING JOB
THEY MIGHT WANT TO LEAVE
BECAUSE OF HEALTH BENEFITS WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO CHANGE
THESE THINGS. MOST OF YOU
RECALL THAT A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO THERE WAS LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD HAVE REGULATED RATES
WITHIN THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
LET ME BE CLEAR THIS BILL DOES
NOT DO THAT. AB ELEVEN THIRTIES
APPROACH IS BASED ON DATA AND
TRANSPARENCY BY CREATING OFFICE
RESPONSIBLE FOR COLLECTING AND
ANALYZING MARKET INFORMATION
AND ESTABLISHING COST SECTOR A
SECTOR COST TARGETS. WE HAVE
ACCEPTED A MENACE FROM EVERY
STAKEHOLDER GROUP IS OFFERED
THEM PRO AND CON AND WE
ACCEPTED EVERY MINUTE NO BUT
OUR PROCESS HAS BEEN OPEN
COLLABORATIVE AND WILL CONTINUE
TO BE THAT WAY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THE COST OF HEALTHCARE
SPENDING HAS BEEN RISING BY
TWICE THE RATE OF INFLATION
SINCE MY FIRST YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN.
WE NEED TO WORK TO CORRECT HIS
ALARMING TREND WHILE WORKING TO
INCREASE QUALITY AND ACCESS TO
CARE. ACCORDING TO AN OCTOBER
TWENTY NINETEEN ARTICLE IN THE
JOURNAL OF THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF EVERY DOLLAR SPENT
ON HEALTHCARE IS WASTED. THINK
ABOUT THAT IF YOU TRANSLATE
THAT TO CALIFORNIA THAT'S
BETWEEN FIFTY EIGHT AND SEVENTY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
THAT'S WASTED MARGINAL DISK
DECREASES IN WAIST ALONE WOULD
LIKELY BRING SPENDING CLOSER TO
OR LOWER THAN THE RATE OF
INFLATION WE NEED THE SYSTEM TO
BE BEGIN TO THINK AND ACT
DIFFERENTLY THAT'S THE GOAL
HERE. DATE AND TRANSPARENCY THE
KEYS TO UNDERSTANDING IMPROVING
OUR SYSTEM WE CAN'T FIX WHAT WE
DON'T UNDERSTAND. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS ISSUE AS I
DO WITH EVERYONE OF MY BILLS.
MEMBERS I HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT
THE EIGHT INTENT OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO BELIEVE THAT
TACKLING GROWING COST OF HEALTH
CARE IS AN EXTREMELY. OR VERY
IMPORTANT PRIORITY FOR THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WOULD MR VOEPEL. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I SPENT
THIRTY NINE YEARS IN THE HEALTH
INSURANCE BUSINESS. DESIGNING
HEALTH PLANS DOING ACTUARIAL
STUDIES WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH MANY OF THE MAJOR
INSURANCE COMPANIES. WHEN I
FIRST WENT INTO THE BUSINESS
THERE WAS OVER THIRTY FIVE
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA DOING. HEALTH
INSURANCE NOW THERE'S LESS THAN
ELEVEN OR TWELVE DEPENDING UPON
THE AREA SOME AREAS ONLY HAVE
ONE. PROVIDER SOME HAVE TWO OR
THREE SO THE MORE YOU TRY TO
CONTROL HEALTH COSTS. THE MORE
YOU WILL BE. ACTUALLY MAKING
THE PROBLEM WORSE HERE'S WHY
THERE IS DISPARITY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IS A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN UCLA MEDICAL
CENTER AND ANOTHER SMALLER
MEDICAL CENTER SOMEWHERE ELSE.
YOU HAVE CYCLES IN THE
INSURANCE BUSINESS THERE ARE
CYCLES WHERE RATES ARE SOMEWHAT
STEADY OTHER TIMES REACTING TO
MARKET FORCES THE RATES GO UP.
MANY TIMES CORPORATIONS WILL
SELF INSURE. IF THEY SELF
INSURE IT DEPENDS UPON THEIR
ACTUARIAL EXPERIENCE AS FAR AS
THEIR CLAIMS GO IF CLAIMS ARE
HIGH YOU HAVE TO RAISE YOUR
PREMIUMS NOW THAT BRINGS ME
ALSO TO A POINT. OUR.
POPULATION IS AGING. AND
BETWEEN AGE FIFTY FIVE IN EIGHT
SIXTY TWO BEFORE SOMEBODY OR
SIXTY FIVE BEFORE SOMEBODY CAN
GO ON MEDICARE THAT IS THE
HIGHEST MOST EXPENSIVE BRACKET.
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE HAS
TO APPROVE. ANY RATE INCREASES
AND THAT IS A ELABORATE DANCE
THAT'S DONE BETWEEN COMPANIES
PROVIDERS EVERYBODY. SO WE
ALREADY HAVE REGULATORY RULES
GREATLY ENFORCE THIS PARTICULAR
BILL. REALLY WILL. BRING A
HEAVY HAMMER OUTSIDE THE
INSURANCE DEPARTMENT OUTSIDE
INSURANCE MARKET PLACE THAT WE
REALLY DON'T NEED RATES ARE
GONNA GO UP NO MATTER WHAT.
BECAUSE THAT IS THE NATURE OF
THE BEAST IT WILL BE TWO TO
THREE TIMES HIGHER THAN CPI
THAT IS SIMPLY IT. RIGHT NOW
WE'RE SPENDING ALMOST 18% OF
OUR GDP ON HEALTHCARE. IT WILL
GO 220% THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HEY MISS VOEPEL MISTER FLORA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND THEN MISTER
CHAIR ITS PROS A START ON
HEALTH WITH YOU IN IN HEALTH TO
YOU EXPRESSED THAT IT WAS NOT
YOUR INTENT TO CAPTURE SMALL.
YOUR PHYSICIAN PRACTICES. I'M
IN ONE OF THOSE EGGS- THE
MEMBERS THAT YOU TOOK. IT
EXEMPTED. THE INDEPENDENT-
INDEPENDENT PHYSICIAN PRACTICES
BUT THERE IS NO DEFINITION TO
THAT. SO I WAS JUST CURIOUS IF
YOU CAN HELP US TO FIND OUT AND
IF YOU'RE WILLING TO COMMUTE TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THAT
PARTICULAR TO DEFINE THAT
DEFINITION OF WHAT THAT
ACTUALLY MEANS APPRECIATE YOU
CAN. DO IT IN A CLOSE. THANK
THANK YOU I'M HAPPY TO CHECK
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER IT NOW- OUR
INTENTION IS TO EXEMPT THE
SMALL- INDEPENDENT PRACTICES.
THOSE SMALL PROVIDER PRESS
GROUPS THAT ARE NOT FEELING
WITH LARGER GROUPS WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO CAPTURE INDIVIDUAL
DOCTORS. IN SMALL TOWNS THAT'S
NOT THE IDEA WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THE CHI COST DRIVERS. THE OUT
LIARS THAT ARE THAT ARE-
COMMANDING- THE MARKET AND
DRIVING PRICES HIGHER SO WE ARE
WE WERE WORKING TO CLARIFY THAT
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDER WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT. THANK AFTERWARD. THAT
THEY CAN MISS FLORA. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS. SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. DR
WOULD YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
AND- RESPONDING TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE SAN DIEGO AREA THIS
BILL ISN'T JUST ABOUT INSURANCE
THIS IS BILL IS ABOUT-
HOSPITALS PROVIDERS DRUG
COMPANIES AND INSURANCE IT'S
ABOUT THE ENTIRE SYSTEM THE
CONSOLIDATION YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS PRECISELY THE PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE THAT'S LEADING TO
HIGHER COSTS. AND SO THAT THAT
IS ALSO SOMETHING THAT WE
LOOKING AT IN THIS ISSUE WE
HAVE TO GET OUR ARMS AROUND
THIS ENTIRE THING AND- I HOPE
THAT YOU'LL JOIN WITH ME AND
SUPPORT THE EIGHT IN TEN
CALIFORNIANS WHO THINK THIS IS
A PRETTY SERIOUS PROBLEM
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. AND
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE- WE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE
RESERVE A. CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY FOUR
MINUTES TWELVE. THE MEASURE
PASSES OVER TO PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FILE ITEM FORTY THREE. AS
WELL AS FORTY FOUR THAT BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE MR
MCCARTY. THIS IS FIVE FORTY
FIVE AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN.
CARBERY SYMBOL THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY
AND ACTIVATING THE STUDENT
HOUSING MAKING APPROPRIATION-
FOR MISTER CARTY EMAIL BUT I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL IS AN EFFORT TO INCREASE-
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
AND A HOUSING CRISIS. WITH
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY IS NOT
ALWAYS TUITION AS WE DISCUSSED
EARLIER WITH MR MEDINA IS
MEASURE THE COST OF COLLEGE ARE
HOUSING BOOKS FOOD
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING BEING
THE NUMBER ONE COST DRIVER-
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A
REVOLVING FUND TO HELP THE
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA THE CSU AND
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUILD
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR OUR
STUDENTS. THIS IS ALSO A PIECE
AND A PRIORITY IN OUR STATE
BUDGET THANK YOU ASK THE RIVAL.
THANK GOODNESS FOR HURTING.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS. USER TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS HER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
A HIGHS. SIXTY ONE. NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY SIX AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE BY MISTER GIBSON
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AND
ACCLIMATE TO TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
MISTER GIBSON EMAIL BUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBER AND THE INTEREST OF
TIME- I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIVE WHICH SEEKS TO. ACHIEVE A
DIGITAL EQUITY AND PUBLIC
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING THIS BILL
SEEKS TO TRANSFER TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY- TO
THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
SERVICES FUNDS- SPECIFICALLY
THE BROADBAND PUBLIC HOUSING
ACCOUNT AND SET A GOAL OF
CONNECTING ALL RESIDENTS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE OR POSSIBLY
SOONER. THIS IS NOT GENERAL
FUND MONEY OR DOLLARS IT
CURRENTLY A FOCUS ON THE
TELECOMMUNICATION TELE CONNECT
SURCHARGE THIS- THE FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR GRANTS AND LOANS
TO CONNECT RESIDENTS TO
BROADBAND NETWORKS AND TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO THOSE WHO
LIVE IN PUBLIC HOUSING S. AS
WELL AS BOTH RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I VOTE.
ON FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. DAMOS
GIPSON. SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CORPORAL IS THAT A VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS OF A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL
AND TALLY THE VOTE. HIGHS FORTY
THREE KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE. ARE
MAKING DECENT PROGRESS WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A LUNCH BREAK AND
RETURNED PROMPTLY TO THE FLOOR
AT ONE PM TO RESUME BUSINESS
PLEASE RETURN. AT ONE PM SO WE
MAY RESUME TAKING UP ITEMS.
THIS IS RECESS UNDER CALL THIS
IS RECESSED CENTER CALL OF THE
SPEAKER. PLEASE RETURN PROMPTLY
AT ONE PM SO WE MAY PERCEIVE
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE ARE
TESTING THE LUNCH TIME TO
CONCLUDE AT ONE THIRTY. WE WILL
RETURN TO THE FLOOR PROMPTLY AT
ONE THIRTY TO RESUME THE
BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE THIS IS
RECESSED UNDER CALL THE
SPEAKER. IN PLEASE RETURN TO
THE FLOOR AT ONE THIRTY. SO WE
MAY PROCEED.
MEMBERS WE ARE
RESUMING SESSION. PLEASE RETURN
OF THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
DEVELOPER. PRIME MEMBERS WE ARE.
CONTINUE BUSINESS. WE'RE THIRD.
LOOKING FOR MR LEVINE TO TAKE
UP HIS ITEM. WE ARE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY. ON FILE ITEM.
FORTY THREE. PASS TEMPORARILY I
FOUND FORTY THREE AND WE ARE.
LOOKING FOR MISTER GIBSON TO
TAKE UP HIS ITEM. WHERE IS THIS
IS FILE ITEM. FORTY SIX. A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. UPON HIS
MARRIAGE TO BE DISPENSED WITH
THAT ITEM ALREADY. WHAT A PASS
TEMPORARILY FORTY SO THIS IS.
FILE ITEM. FORTY EIGHT FILE
ITEM. FORTY EIGHT. AC ARE.
EIGHTY SEVEN. CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON RELATIVE TO NATIONAL GUN
VIOLENCE AWARENESS DAY. MISTER
GIBSON ON THE RESOLUTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. I RISE TO PRESENT ACR
EIGHTY SEVEN. WHICH WOULD
PROCLAIMS TOMORROW JUNE THE
FOURTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
AS NATIONAL GUN VIOLENCE
AWARENESS DAY EVERY DAY MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED AMERICANS ARE
KILLED BY GUN VIOLENCE ALONE
SIDE MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY WHO ARE SHOT AND WOUNDED.
GUN MURDERS OCCUR. IN OUR
STREETS OUR HOMES. EVEN JUST
LAST WEEK IN SAN JOSE AT THE
WORKPLACE. THESE GUN VIOLENCE
TAKES PLACE AT SCHOOLS MOVIE
THEATERS CHURCHES SPORTS VENUES
AND SO ON CALIFORNIA ALONE SEES
ABOUT THREE THOUSAND GUN DEATHS
EVERY YEAR AND IN THE LAW IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES THERE
WERE THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
HOMICIDES IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY. THAT IS ALMOST A
HUNDRED MORE HOMICIDES THEN IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND IS
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF LOS
ANGELES SEEN IN THE LAST DECADE.
THESE ARE NOT JUST NUMBERS ON
PAPER. AND THIS COLBERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS ONLY MADE
CIRCUMSTANCES WORSE. IN MY
COMMUNITY. WHERE GANG VIOLENCE
IT HAS PLAGUED EVEN CHILDREN
ARE NOT SAFE FROM GUN VIOLENCE
COMPTON WHICH I REPRESENT HAS
ONE OF THE HIGHEST UNSOLVED
MURDER RATES IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THE PROBLEM IS ONLY GETTING
WORSE I ALSO GREW UP. AND NOW
REPRESENTS THE WANTS COMMUNITY
WHICH HAS MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED HOMICIDES BETWEEN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND TWO
THOUSAND FIVE I KNOW HOW IT
FEELS TO LOSE SOMEONE NEAR
DEATH SOMEONE THAT YOU LOVE
VERY MUCH. MY HEART STOPS.
EVERY AND EVERY TIME. YOU HEAR
THAT SOMEONE IN YOUR COMMUNITY
HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES IN THIS
SENSELESS GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITY LAST YEAR MEMBERS.
MANY OF YOU KNOW ON APRIL THE
FIFTH TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
MY SON AND HIS FIANCE WAS
WALKING DOWN THE STREET.
THEY'RE WALKING DOWN THE STREET.
BOTH OF THEM WERE SHOT. ANOTHER
GENERAL'S WORK ON HIS CAR WAS
SHOT IN THE HEAD. AND ANOTHER
GENTLEMAN LOST HIS LIFE. ALL
BUT WALKING DOWN THE STREET TO
GET OUT OF THE HOUSE DOING THIS
PANDEMIC THANK GOD HE LIVES.
THE GERMANS WORK WORK ON HIS
CAR HE LEAH. IS MY SONS GROW
GIRLFRIEND SHEILA BUT ONE
GENTLEMAN DIED AS A OF THAT. SO
I FEEL GUN VIOLENCE IN A
DIFFERENT. AND SO TO HAVE THIS
ACR COME BEFORE US ACR EIGHTY
SEVEN TO COMMANDED TO RECOGNIZE
THE NATIONAL GUN VIOLENCE
AWARENESS DAY IT'S ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT MEMBERS BECAUSE- I
LIVED IT I'VE SEEN IT HAPPEN
AND IT HAPPENS ON A DAILY BASIS
ONLY IN CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY MEMBERS ASK A
STRONG AYE VOTE ON A ON. ACR.
EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISS
GIPSON. SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM
MISTER GIBSON WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS. SHE GIVES IS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. OF
ASSISTANCE FOR CO AUTHORS. ON
THE RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
THERE ARE SIXTY THREE CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
EVERSION FILER THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY NINE. MISTER SEA IS
READY THERE'S A FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN. A. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE. CORPORATE ASSUME BILL
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN THE
CRIMES MISS GARCIA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB LET- ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE WOULD REPEAL THE
EXISTING SELF OF A PROVISION IN
THE CALIFORNIA LAW AND WILL
PROVIDE EQUITY FOR RAPE
VICTIMS. VICTIMS OF RAPE SHOULD
NOT BE TREATED DIFFERENTLY
BECAUSE OF THEIR MARCH STATUS
CURRENT LAW MINIMIZES THE
IMPACT THAT RATE PASS ON
MARRIED INDIVIDUALS AND THIS
BILL ALLOWS SIMILAR OUT. WILL
ENSURE WE HAVE SIMILAR OPTIONS
FOR BOTH MARRIED AND UNMARRIED
VICTIMS THERE ARE ONLY NINE
STATES ARE STILL DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN SPELL THREE BEEN ON
SPELL SURVEY IN CALIFORNIA. AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE PRICE IN
CALIFORNIA LAW AND WOULD
REQUIRE THE SAME SANDERS WITH
ALL RATE THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING LOCAL FOR NON SURVEY. IN
CLOSING THE QUESTION EVERY
VICTIM SHOULD NOT BE WELL OR
NOT THE ARE MERRY I WAS THE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MISTER K. HAND
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE. I KNOW THAT EVERYBODY ON
THIS FLOOR DEGREES THAT RAPE.
IS RAPE. THE VICTIM OF RAPE
WHETHER. IT IS A STRANGER WHO
ASSAULTS HER IN THAT- HIM IN
THAT WAY. OR THE PERSON TO
NEVER DROVE. RAPE IS RAPE AND
THAT IS ALL THIS DOES.
CURRENTLY IN OUR CODE WE TREAT
ALSO WRITTEN. AS IT BEING RAPED
THE PERSON YOU'RE- TO. LESS OF
A CRIME OR LESS OF I. OF OUR
OWN. AND IT IS THESE. ENERGY
TREATED THE SAME I KNOW THEY'RE
GOING TO OF DISK. AROUND WHAT
ARE THE PROPER PENALTY FOR RAPE.
THAT IS A CONVERSATION THAT WE
CAN'T SHOULD HAVE THE- BUT BILL
PENALTIES SHOULD APPLY. EVERY
SINGLE. AND EVERY SINGLE.
SHOULD GET THE SAME TREATMENT
AND THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK. RIVAL AND
THANK YOU IS BACKING. SEEING
THEIR A DISCUSS. ON THE ADAM.
CLICK LEVEL. IT IS OUR VOTE ON
THE VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBER VOTERS OUT OF OUT. CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIVE KNOWS. THAT MAY PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO UP I.
FOR THREE FILE ITEM FOR THREE
IS SPECIAL LEVINE IS AB. TWELVE
TWENTY THREE. AND THE
CORPORATION. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE TWENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN THE FIREARMS MR
LEVINE EMAIL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU
MEMBERS AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE
IMPOSES AN EXCISE TAX UPON
RETAILERS NOT CONSUMERS FOR THE
SALE OF FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION
AND ESTABLISHES THE GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION HEALING AND
RECOVERY FUND TO FUND GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MEMBERS ACCORDING TO THE GUN
VIOLENCE ARCHIVE IN THE FIRST
FIVE MONTHS OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THERE HAVE BEEN. TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY MASS
SHOOTINGS IN AMERICA FROM
JANUARY FIRST TO JUNE FIRST OF
THIS YEAR. EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
AMERICANS. WERE KILLED DUE TO
GUN VIOLENCE INCLUDING FOUR
PEOPLE KILLED ON MARCH THIRTY
FIRST AT AN OFFICE COMPLEX IN
ORANGE CALIFORNIA AND EIGHT
PEOPLE. KILLED AT A TRANSIT
FACILITY IN SAN JOSE JUST LAST
WEEK YESTERDAY. OR TWO DAYS AGO
A FIREFIGHTER TONY CARLSON.
FORTY FOUR YEAR OLD FATHER OF
THREE DAUGHTERS WAS KILLED AND
ANOTHER FIREFIGHTER IS INJURED
IN A MASS SHOOTING AT A FIRE
STATION AND I WOULD DOLCE IN
NORTHERN LOS ANGELES ON
MEMORIAL DAY. A SANTA SAN
BERNARDINO SHERIFF'S DEPUTY WAS
SHOT AND KILLED DOMINICK VAKA.
DEBBI DOMINGO DOMINICK BACA WAS
JUST FORTY THREE YEARS OLD.
MEMBERS THESE ARE NOT
STATISTICS THEY ARE HUMAN LIVES.
GONSALES INCIDENTS OF GUN
VIOLENCE HAVE INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. TWENTY TWENTY SAW 46%
INCREASE IN GUN HOMICIDES IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE WAS
THE DEADLIEST MONTH FOR GUN
HOMICIDES SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN. MEMBERS FRIENDS WHEN OUR
STATE FACED THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE DID NOT SIT BY WE
TOOK ACTION TO SAVE LIVES WHEN
OUR STATE FACED THE DEVASTATION
OF WILDFIRES FLOODS OR
EARTHQUAKES WE DON'T JUST SIT
BY WE TAKE ACTION TO SAVE LIVES
YET FOR TOO LONG. WHEN OUR
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO BE
DEVASTATED BY GUN VIOLENCE. I
ASK YOU. WHEN WILL WE TAKE
ACTION TO SAVE THE LIVES OF OUR
FELLOW CALIFORNIANS GUN
VIOLENCE WILL NOT END ON ITS
OWN. WE MUST TAKE RESPONSIBLE
ACTION TO END THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS THAT IS GUN VIOLENCE IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN THE UNITED
STATES AND WE SEE MORE AND MORE
INCIDENTS OF GUN VIOLENCE AS WE
SEE MORE AND MORE INCIDENTS OF
GUN VIOLENCE WE MUST BE
REMINDED. THAT WE ARE NEITHER
HELPLESS NOR HOPELESS TO END
THE CEASELESS BLOODSHED.
COMMUNITY BASED VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PROGRAM SUCH AS
CAL THAT HAVE PROVEN TIME AND
AGAIN TO BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY. OF PREVENTING GUN VIOLENCE
BEFORE IT OCCURS COMMUNITIES
WHICH RECEIVED GRANTS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM FUND DURING THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CYCLE. SOFT HOMICIDES
DECREASED BY THREE TIMES MORE
THAN THOSE THAT DID NOT
RECEIVE. THE SAME SUPPORT.
SACRAMENTO FOR EXAMPLE USED
CALVET GRANTS TO ENGAGE IN
INTENSIVE COMMUNITY OUT REACH
THAT RESULTED IN THE MEDIATION
OF TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
CONFLICTS THAT HAD THE
POTENTIAL TO ESCALATE TO DEADLY
MEASURES AND INTERRUPTED SIXTY
NINE CYCLICAL AND GUN VIOLENCE
RETALIATORY SITUATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY THE CITY HAD NO
JUVENILE HOMICIDES IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN
THANKS TO CALVET AND PROGRAMS
LIKE IT. THE RESULTS THESE
COMMUNITY BASED VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS PRODUCE.
IS SIMILAR IN CITIES AND
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING.
BAKERSFIELD COMPTON FRESNO
GILROY LONG BEACH LOS ANGELES
OAKLAND OXNARD PASADENA PARRIS
RICHMOND SALINAS SAN BERNARDINO
SAN FRANCISCO SAN JOSE STOCKED
IN GRASS VALLEY. GREENFIELD
JUST STINKING CITY MARYSVILLE
PARLOR SEASIDE STOCKTON AND
VALLEJO ALL SEEN MARKET
DECREASES IN GUN VIOLENCE AND
TO END GUN VIOLENCE WE MUST
ACT. TO SAVE LIVES WE WILL SAVE
LIVES BY SUPPORTING AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS LEVINE
MISTER GIBSON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE TWENTY THREE I THANK THE
GERMAN FROM SAN RAFAEL FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- WE JUST
GOT TO PASSING ACR- EIGHTIES A
DAY THAT HIGH. ON NASH GUN BY-
IT STARTS TO I HAVE TO RIDE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
SPEAKS TO THE VERY ESSENCE OF
WHAT WE NEED TO DO I JUST
ARTICULATED ON THE FLOOR A FEW
MOMENTS AGO WHAT MY COMMUNITY
IS GOING THROUGH I TALKED ABOUT
THE CITY OF COMPTON WITH THE
UNSOLVED MURDERS ARE TAKING
PLACE OUT TALKED ABOUT THE CITY
OF MORE OF THE COMMUNITY OF
WHAT'S WHERE I WAS BORN AND
RAISED ALSO TALKED ABOUT MY SON
BEING A VICTIM HERE THAT'S
BEYOND SAY. OF GUN VIOLENCE
UNDERSTAND THIS IF YOU HAVE
NEVER EVER MET OR HAD ANYBODY
YOUR FAMILY BE A VICTIM OF GUN
VIOLENCE LET ME SAY SOMETHING.
YOU'RE BLESSED. YOUR WANT TO
GET A PHONE. LIKE I GOT A PHONE.
THAT I THOUGHT MY LIFE TURNED
UP. DOWN WHEN I RECEIVED A
PHONE CALL THAT MY OLDEST CHILD
UNDERSTAND ME PUT A POINT IN.
MY FIRST CHILD WAS KILLED. BYE
HERE TO RUN MOTORS AT THREE
YEARS OLD. THEY KNOW MY SECOND
MY SECOND OLDEST. WALKING DOWN
THE STREET IN APRIL JUST GET
OUT A HOUSING IS BEYOND SAID
AND THERE'S SOME **** I'M SO.
DR. HONEST HONEST AND STAR
SHOOTING. AND TO GET THAT PHONE
CALL MAR WORLD TURN UPSIDE DOWN
MEMBERS YOU NEVER WANT TO GET
THAT PHONE CALL LIKE WE'VE GOT
BUT THANK GOD THE STORIES THAT
THEY BOTH LIVE BUT ONE MAN IN A
SENSE. DIE HE DONE THIS WAS
TAKING ON MARCH. WOULD YOU HAVE
SENT. AND THE MASSACRE TOOK
INSIDE JOSE. AT WORK WE THINK
THAT'S A WORKPLACE IS A SPACE.
BUT THIS THIS ISSUE IS BETTER
PUBLIC SO PEOPLE FOR MIGHT WANT
TO GO IT'S NOT HAVE TO DO A
THAT YOU DO NOT A GOOD ALL THAT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A WELCOME
BROCHURE. YOU HAVE A LIVE WHERE
I LIVE. THIS IS REAL WHAT IT
COMES DOWN TO GO ALL TO IT OVER
SO THEY ARE BABIES DON'T HAVE
TO BE A OF. BY GOOD VIOLENCE.
STATE WE CAN DO. PROGRAMS LIKE
CHILD. BUT THAT'S NOT SUBJECT
TO READ. YOU GIVE SOMEBODY WHO
JUST GOT OUT OF PRISON A JOB.
WHAT ALL AROUND. IF PUT RE SO
AT THIS KIDS KERN HAVE
SOMEWHERE TO PLAY IN SWIMMING I
HAVE KIDS ABOUT THIS WAS
BITTERNESS NO BEFORE. NEVER
BEEN TO THE SNOW BASE IS SEEN
IT ON TV BUT I'M NOT ACTUALLY
TOUCH NO MATTER THAT. WE HAVE
TO DO BETTER AND WE CAN DO
BETTER. AND I KNOW THIS A TOUGH
WOMEN OF YOU. IN COMMUTER THAT
YOU REPRESENT GUNS IS A
TERRIBLE KIND OF THING I GET
THE- BUT I ASKED YOU TO PUT
PRESS YOUR SELL. PUSHED WHAT
WHAT YOU'RE- IT MAY NOT BE BY
NOT BE DOING GUNFIRE. WHAT
ABOUT SOMEBODY ELSE COMMITTEE
LIKE MY CAN WITHOUT ABOUT I OF
THOSE SHOWED. WHO GIVE ME A- TO
SIT ON THE DURING THE THIRD OF
GREEN CARPET AND. GIVE US
GIPSON. MR LEE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE TWENTY
THREE THE SAN JOSE DELEGATION
INCLUDING MYSELF AND TWO OTHER
MEMBERS WITHOUT AS A AND THE
QUEEN OF SAN JOSE WAS
DEVASTATED LAST WEEK BY THE
SENSELESS MASS MURDER OF NINE
INDIVIDUALS NINE A HARDWORKING
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK AT OUR
VALLEY TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
WHICH SERVES THE ENTIRE COUNTY
WERE MURDERED IN COLD BLOOD AT
THE WORK SPACE. THEIR FAMILIES
WILL NEVER SEE THEM AGAIN AT A
LOVED ONE'S BIRTHDAY A
GRADUATION AT A WEDDING OR ANY
OTHER FAMILY CELEBRATION THE
LOSS WILL BE FELT IN OUR
COMMUNITY FOR THE REST OF OUR
LIVES. THIS LOSS SADLY THOUGH
IS NOT UNIQUE TO JUST MY
COMMUNITY WE SEE THIS BUDGET
AGAIN AND AGAIN- COMMITTEE
SUPPORT AFFLUENT FROM ALL
ACROSS THE STATE WE CONTINUE TO
SEE THE BREAKING NEWS HEADLINES
OF YET ANOTHER MASS SHOOTING
OUR NATION ON THE NEARLY WEEKLY
BASIS I FRANKLY I'M SICK OF IT
AT TIMES WE FEEL HELPLESS THIS
CARNAGE BUT WE ARE NOT HELPLESS
TO THE DEVASTATION CAUSED BY
GUN VIOLENCE WE CAN SHOW
COURAGE TODAY AND CAN ACT TO
END GUN VIOLENCE. AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE WILL PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL RESOURCES THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSES OF GUN VIOLENCE AND
ELIMINATE THIS EPIDEMIC FROM
OUR COMMUNITIES AND TODAY I'LL
BE CASTING MY AYE VOTE FOR AB
TWELVE TWENTY THREE IN HONOR OF
THE VICTIMS OF THE DEADLIEST
MASS SHOOTING IN THE HISTORY OF
SAYS THEY CERTAINLY AND THE
HISTORY OF THE BAY AREA FOR UP
DAHLE OF UP. ON MONDAY. ADRIN
BLAZE. ALEX OF FRIDGE JOSE
HERNANDEZ THIRD LARS KEPLER
LANE PAUL DO LOOK. MEDIA
TIMOTHY MICHAEL ROMEO MICHAEL
JOSEPH. REMAKING AND TOUCHET
SAYING. I IMPLORE YOU TO HONOR
THEIR MEMORY BY SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISLI. MS WICKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. MEMBERS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE IS IT AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL AND I THINK
MANY OF YOU KNOW MY HUSBAND
WAS- FIVE DAYS ON THE JOB
WORKING FOR GABBY GIFFORDS WHEN
SHE WAS SHOT IN THE HEAD. AND
SOME OF HER STAFF WERE KILLED.
MANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY WERE KILLED. AND THAT
SET HIS LIFE ON A DIFFERENT
TRAJECTORY OF COURSE BUT
CERTAINLY HERS TOO. AND THE
COURAGE AND THE CONVICTION THAT
SHE HAS EVERY SINGLE DAY TO
CONTINUE TO FIGHT ON THIS ISSUE
IS ABSOLUTELY BREATHTAKING AND
AMAZING. AND THAT'S THE KIND OF
COURAGE I'M ASKING FROM YOU OFF
TODAY. TO HAVE COURAGE I KNOW
THAT THIS IS A TAX. AND FOR
SOME OF YOU THEY DON'T HAVE
DISTRICTS LIKE MINE TAXES ARE
HARD VOTES RIGHT AND I GET
THAT. THIS IS A VERY SPECIFIC
KIND OF TAX THOUGH. AND THE
MONEY THAT IT GOES TO IS WHAT I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT TODAY
BECAUSE WE KNOW. THAT PROGRAMS
LIKE CALVET END GUN VIOLENCE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE THE DATA THAT SAYS THAT
THERE'S BEEN. ACADEMIC RESEARCH
ON THIS. THAT SAYS THAT
PROGRAMS LIKE HELD UP WHICH
INVEST IN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO DO DIRECT
VIOLENCE INTERRUPTION WORK IN
THESE COMMUNITIES. LIKE USED TO
LIVE FOR MY DISTRICT. THAT WHEN
SOMEONE IS SHOT THEY HAVE
WORKERS TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL
THAT WORK WITH THE FAMILY
MEMBERS AND THE FRIENDS OF THE
PEOPLE THAT COMMITTED TO NOT DO
RETALIATORY SHOOTINGS. THAT
REDUCES GUN VIOLENCE. WE HAVE
TO FUND THESE PROGRAMS WE HAVE
GOOD FUNDING THIS YEAR BUT WE
DO NOT HAVE ON GOING FUNDING
FOR THESE PROGRAMS. WE HAVE
GOOD LAWS IN CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY ON GUNS FOR THE MOST
PART WERE BUT ONE OF THE MORE
ADVANCED STATES RIGHT. BUT WHAT
WE HAVE IS A FLOOD OF GUNS
COMING IN FROM NEVADA. A FLOOD
OF GUNS COMING IN FROM ARIZONA
WE DON'T HAVE FEDERAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS. SO THEN WHAT
DO WE DO WHEN WE HAVE GUN
VIOLENCE WE HAVE TO INVEST IN
THESE PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE KNOW
THEY WORK. AND HERE'S THE TRUTH
THAT NONE OF US LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. IS THAT WHEN WE
SEE THESE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS
THEIR HORRIFIC. WE GET A LOT OF
MEDIA ATTENTION A LOT OF MEDIA
ATTENTION FOR THOSE. BUT HERE'S
THE ACTUAL REALITY. AND R.
BROWN AND BLACK COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY. MANY THOSE
COMMUNITY GUIDELINES EVERY
SINGLE DAY. AND WE ARE LEAVING
THESE COMMUNITIES BEHIND BY NOT
INVESTING IN THESE PROGRAMS AND
THAT IS ON ALL OF US RIGHT NOW
TO MAKE A DECISION THAT WE'RE
GOING TO INVEST IN THESE
PROGRAMS. BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THEY WORK. SO I UNDERSTAND IT'S
A TOUGH VOTE FOR SOME FOLKS BUT
I'M ASKING YOU TO HAVE COURAGE
TO MAKE THAT VOTE. AND TO
INVEST IN A RUN ABOUT
COMMUNITIES THAT BEEN LEFT
BEHIND FOR FAR TOO LONG. I
WOULD HUMBLY ASK THAT YOU VOTE
FIVE UNTIL TWENTY THREE. THANK
YOU MISS WICKS MISTER MATHIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I THANK GOD. A
LOT OF US HAVE A LOT OF
SYMPATHY. WHAT EMPATHY
COMPASSION FOR THE VICTIMS IN
THE FAMILIES RELATED TO GUN
VIOLENCE. WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS IT DOESN'T STOP. THOSE ROOT
CAUSES THE THESE THINGS LIKE
POVERTY. MENTAL HEALTH. THE
THINGS THAT DRIVE PEOPLE TO THE
POINT WHERE THEY USE A TOOL TO
HARM OTHERS. THIS BILL DOESN'T
STOP THAT. WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS CREATE A TAX THAT'S GOING TO
DRIVE UP THE COST. LET'S ALSO
CONSIDER SOME FACTS OVER 60% OF
GUN RELATED DEATHS OR SUICIDES.
WHICH CUTS DEEP FOR ME
PERSONALLY. BECAUSE I'VE LOST
MORE FRIENDS TO SUICIDE THAT I
HAVE FROM COMBAT. LET'S ALSO
THINK OF ANOTHER FAT. THE
PEOPLE WHO DEFEND THEMSELVES
WITH GUNS ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE
KILLED OR INJURED. IN A CRIME.
SO WITH THIS BILL ARE ARE YOU
TAKING AWAY THE ABILITY. BY
DRIVING UP THE COST OF
AMMUNITION. BECAUSE NOW PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
POVERTY PEOPLE LETTER FOR AREAS
OF OUR STATE LIKE MINE. WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS WHO WANT
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES AND
PROTECT THEM FOR FAMILY PROTECT.
THEIR PROPERTY. ARE GOING TO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO SO. IT
YOU KNOW THE CURRENT JOKE OF
TODAY IS THE MOST EXPENSIVE
DATE OUT THERE'S TO GO SHOOT A
NINE MILLIMETER AT A PIECE OF
PLYWOOD. BECAUSE OF THE COST.
THAT'S A FACT. SO WE JUST GOING
TO CONTINUE TO BE TAX A FORMULA.
THEY JUST THROW ANOTHER TAX OUT
THERE ANOTHER PROBLEM
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE ALREADY HAVE
A MASSIVE BUDGET SURPLUS. IS
ANOTHER TAX TRULY WHAT Y'ALL
WANT. I'M GONNA STAND WITH THE
ABILITY TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE CAN
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND WE NEED
TO LOOK AT OTHER WAYS TO
ADDRESS POVERTY. TO ADDRESS
MENTAL HEALTH. THE STOP
VIOLENCE AS A WHOLE. WHETHER
IT'S WITH A GUN A KNIFE
WHATEVER WE HAVE A VIOLENCE
PROBLEM THAT'S A FACT. WHILE
WE'RE AT IT LET'S CONSIDER SOME
OF THE LOGIC THAT WE'VE HEARD.
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO START
TAXING THEM TO PAY FOR GUN
VIOLENCE WHY ARE WE GONNA TAX
SPOONS NEXT TO PAY FOR DIABETES.
THINK ABOUT IT. MS CLARK SILVA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE TWENTY
THREE. RECENTLY JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO ON THE FIFTY FIVE
FREEWAY IN ORANGE COUNTY A SIX
YEAR OLD BOY WAS SHOT AND
KILLED DURING AN APPARENT ROAD
RAGE. INCIDENT IN THE SECONDS
OF ANGER AND FRUSTRATION
COMBINED WITH A GUN LED TO THE
LOSS OF A LIFE FORTY SIX YEAR
OLD BOY NAMED AIDEN. AIDEN'S
LEOS WAS SEATED IN THE BOOSTER
SEAT AND THE RIGHT REAR
PASSENGER SIDE OF HIS MOTHER'S
CAR WHEN HE WAS STRUCK BY GONE
GUNFIRE OFF THE NORTHBOUND
FIFTY FIVE FREEWAY. THE BULLET
HAD ENTERED THE VEHICLE THROUGH
THE LEFT SIDE OF THE TRUNK
GOING THROUGH AIDEN'S BACK. THE
INCIDENT OCCURRED AS THEY WERE
HEADED TO SCHOOL WHEN A CAR CUT
THEM OFF AS THEY TRIED TO EXIT
THE CAR POOL LANE. AIDEN'S
MOTHER GESTURED TO THE TWO
OCCUPANTS A MAN AND A WOMAN AND
WAS EXITING THE LANE WHEN THE
GUNFIRE ERUPTED. THOSE BRIEF
MOMENTS LED TO A TRAGEDY THAT
NO MOTHER SHOULD HAVE TO FACE.
SHE WAS LEFT ON THE SIDE OF THE
FREEWAY HAVING TO HOLD EIGHT IN
INNER ARMS HER DYING SON
HELPLESS WHAT THE LAST WORDS
THAT WERE SPOKEN BY. EIGHT IN
BEING. MOMMY MOMMY MY TUMMY
HURTS. THE GUNMEN WHO TOOK THE
LIFE FOR HER INNOCENT YOUNG BOY
REMAINS AT LARGE. AS MANY
CONTINUE TO FIND THIS
INDIVIDUAL. THE QUESTION WE
HAVE TO ASK US. ALL OF US AND
WHEN DO WE SAY THE CONDOLENCES
ARE NOT ENOUGH. WHEN DO WE SAY
THE TRAGIC EVENTS ON
SCHOOLYARDS PLAYGROUNDS AND
PLACES THAT WE WORSHIP. PLACES
THAT WE EAT AT EVENTS THAT WE
SOCIALIZE BIRTHDAY PARTIES.
WHEN DO WE SAY WE'RE NOT SAFE.
AND AT EVERY FEW WEEKS WE HEAR
YET ANOTHER INCIDENT MANY TIMES
THEY DON'T EVEN MAKE NEWS
ANYMORE. MANY TIMES SOMEBODY
WHO WAS KILLED WITH A GUN IF
IT'S ONE PERSON IT JUST DOESN'T
MAKE NEWS. PARTICULARLY IN OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. NOW
I'M FROM ORANGE COUNTY IN
ORANGE COUNTY PEOPLE DON'T LIKE
TAXES. AND I'VE SAID NO TO
EVERY TAX SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE.
AND ALSO A MORE NO TO MORE
TAXES BUT IN THIS CASE I SAY
YES BECAUSE WE NEED TO MAKE. A
STAND TO SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH
AND WE NEED TO START TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS UN
VIOLENCE WHERE NOW ARE YOUNG
KINDERGARTEN CHILDREN HAVE TO
GO TO ACTIVE SHOOTER TRAINING.
ON OUR CAMPUSES. AS A TEACHER
FOR THIRTY YEARS I HAD TO GO
THROUGH THAT TRAINING. TO
ACTUALLY TEACH CHILDREN NOT TO
DUCK AND COVER FROM
EARTHQUAKES. BUT HOW TO HIDE
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT OUR
CAMPUSES LOOK LIKE WHEN WE GET
THAT SIGNAL THAT THERE'S AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER ON CAMPUS SO I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE
TWENTY THREE AND ASK FOR YOUR
I. A BOAT. THANK YOU MISS CLARK
SILVA MISSED POWER K. HAVE. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I DON'T THINK I
COULD LAY OUT THE PROBLEM ANY
BETTER THAT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
CARSON DID COMING FROM
COMMUNITY PLAGUED. I GUN
VIOLENCE BUT I KNOW. THAT ALL
SEVENTY NINE MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY. LIVE IN COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE GUN VIOLENCE. MINE
PROBABLY HAS ONE OF THE LOWEST
RATES OF GUN VIOLENCE IN THIS
HOUSE. AND YET JUST THIS YEAR A
DEAR FRIEND OF MINE LOST HER
HUSBAND TO GUN VIOLENCE. WELL
HER SON WATCHED. HE RAN INTO
THE FOREST IN HOPES OF FLEEING
FROM THE MAN WHO IS SHOOTING AT
THEM. AND THEN HID FOR DAYS
UNTIL THEY WERE ABLE TO FIND
HIM. WILL NEVER COVER. THIS IS
A REAL I LIKE MY COLLEAGUES
ORANGE COUNTY COME FROM A
DISTRICT. THE DOESN'T LIKE HOW
MUCH WE TAX PEOPLE I VOTE
AGAINST ALMOST EVERY TAXES WELL.
UNLIKE MY COLLEAGUE IN OAKLAND.
BUT EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE. WE
SEE A PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT IS OUR
OBLIGATION TO STEP UP AND SAY
WE WILL DO WHAT IT TAKES WE
WILL PAY FOR THIS PROBLEM TO BE
SOLVED WE WILL SAVE MOTHERS
FROM HAVING TO HOLD THEIR
DYING. CHILDREN WE WILL SAVE
CHILDREN LIKE MINE. FROM
LEARNING TO HIDE. THEY'RE
CALLING FOR ORANGE COUNTY
TALKED ABOUT. BECAUSE THEY
MIGHT BE HUNTED IN THEIR
CLASSROOMS WHERE THEY SHOULD BE
SAFEST. THIS IS OUR MOMENT TO
SAY YES TO SOMETHING THAT FOR
PEOPLE LIKE ME ARE PROBABLY
CURRENT COUNTIES HARD. BUT IT'S
THE RIGHT THING TO DO. WELL
ACTUALLY I JUST WANNA ADD IT'S
ALSO THE FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE
THING TO DO OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE FUNDED THESE CALVET
PROGRAMS HAVE SHOWN THAT FOR
EVERY DOLLAR WE SPEND ON THESE
PROGRAMS WE SAVE THIRTEEN
DOLLARS. IN HOSPITAL COSTS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY COSTS SO WE'RE
SPENDING TO SAVE MONEY. SO NO
MATTER WHERE YOU COME FROM ON
THE IDEOLOGICAL SPECTRUM IF YOU
ARE FISCALLY CONSERVATIVE IF
YOU'RE A LIBERAL THIS IS SMART
TO FISCAL POLICY. BUT IT WILL
SAVE LIVES AND IT WILL SAVE
CALIFORNIANS AND COLLEAGUES
LIKE OURS FROM CURSING CAN
SLEEP BETTER AT NIGHT KNOWING
THEIR CHILDREN WON'T BE
SHOCKED. WALKING DOWN THE
STREET I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ABBOTT. THERE IS BURKE A HEY MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
TWENTY THREE I WANT TO THANK
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM RAN FROM
HAVING THE COURAGE TO BRING
THIS FORWARD. I VERY LITTLE
TOWN TO THE ELOQUENT COMMENTS
THAT SO MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES
HAVE MADE ABOUT THIS MEASURE-
BUT I DID JUST WANT
RESPECTFULLY. RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE COMMENTS FROM A
COLLEAGUE FROM BY SALIA. IT'S
TRUE THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
OTHER UNDERLYING ROOT CAUSES OF
GUN VIOLENCE. POVERTY
INEQUALITY. SUFFERING MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. BUT THOSE
PROBLEMS ARE ALL TOO PERSISTENT
IN OTHER COUNTRIES. ALL OVER
THE WORLD. AND YET THE EPIDEMIC
OF GUN VIOLENCE IS A UNIQUELY
AMERICAN PHENOMENON. CHILDREN
ARE KILLED IN THIS COUNTRY IN A
WAY THAT THEY ARENOT KILLED.
IN ANY OTHER COUNTRY ON EARTH.
SO IF THIS WAS JUST ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH IF THIS WAS JUST
ABOUT POVERTY IF THIS WAS JUST
ABOUT INEQUALITY. THEN WE WOULD
BE IN THE SAME BOAT AS EVERY
OTHER COUNTRY ON EARTH. BUT
WE'RE NOT WE HAVE HEARD THAT
SPOKEN SO POWERFULLY BY OUR
COLLEAGUES. ABOUT THE WAY THAT
IT PLAYED TO PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. ABOUT THE
WAY THAT IT PLACE PEOPLE IN
HIGH INCOME COMMUNITIES ABOUT
HOW STUDENTS ARE FREE TO GO TO
SCHOOL. AND WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT. WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE LIVES I AM
MINDFUL OF THE FACT THAT THIS
INVOLVES TWO THINGS THAT OUR
RADIO ACTIVE IN OUR POLITICS
RIGHT NOW. THE WORD TAXES IN
THE WORD GUNS. BUT YOU HAVE WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY AS OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY
MENTIONED. TO SHOW COURAGE I
WANT TO COMMEND OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM A WINDOW. WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW
COURAGE AND SAVE LIVES. IT'S
HARD RESPECTFULLY SUGGEST ALL
OF MY COLLEAGUES I KNOW THAT
THIS IS A DIFFICULT ABOUT.
PEOPLE ARE MINDFUL OF THE
POLITICS AROUND THIS VOTE BUT
WE HAVE PROGRAMS THAT WORK. YOU
WILL SAVE THE LIVES OF CHILDREN
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BY
VOTING FOR THIS BILL. NO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK IMAGE GABRIEL. MR
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
SON AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY NOTED THIS
IS ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE THIS IS
ABOUT TAXATION AND THIS IS
ABOUT. THE SECOND AMENDMENT
I'LL GET TO THAT TO THE LAST
TWO IN A MINUTE BUT I WOULD
GUESS THAT EVERY SEVENTY NINE
PEOPLE UP HERE WANT TO REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF GUN VIOLENCE.
WITH THEIR IN OUR OWN
COMMUNITIES WHETHER THEY'RE
BECAUSE OF SUICIDE OR VETERANS
THEIR WAY TOO MANY PEOPLE LOST.
UNNECESSARILY AT THE AT THE
HANDS OF GUN VIOLENCE A FIRE
ARE MANY TIMES. IN SOMEONE'S
HANDS WHO WE ALL AGREE
SHOULDN'T HAVE IN THE FIRST
PLACE. I REMEMBER AS A YOUNG
COUNCIL MEMBER JUST A FEW
BLOCKS IN YOUR EYES TO GET
THESE CALLS MAYBE. EVERY OTHER
MONTH FROM OUR EITHER OUR
POLICE CHIEF. OR THE CAPTAIN IN
MY CITY COUNCIL DISTRICT AND
EVERY TIME THAT PHONE RANG. I
DIDN'T WANT TO ANSWER THE CALL
BECAUSE I KNEW THERE ARE
CALLING FOR ONE REASON. A YOUNG
MAN OST LIKELY. YOUNG BROWN A
BLACK MAN WAS SHOT AND KILLED
IN MY DISTRICT. AND I THOUGHT
THIS IS WAY TOO MUCH WHAT COULD
WE DO. SO I THOUGHT TWO THINGS
ONE WE WORKED ON A LOT OF
REGULATE AMMUNITION SALES WITH
LATER BECAME THE MODEL FOR
CALIFORNIA AND TO. I THOUGHT
WHAT CAN WE DO TO SPEND
RESOURCES ON RESEARCH DATA
DRIVEN EFFORTS THAT PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE. WE HAVE A PROGRAM
IGHT HERE THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER THE CAL THE CALVET
PROGRAM FUNDS ADVANCE PEACE
WHICH WE KNOW WORKS. WHICH WE
KNOW WORKS. OUR COLLEAGUE MORAN
IS BRING THIS ISSUE UP SIGN TO
ISSUE MY PREDECESSOR OFFERED
THIS BILL FIVE YEARS AGO. BUT
NOW THE TIME THAT WE CAN REALLY
TAKE A LOOK AS FAR AS WHAT.
REALLY WORKS TO STOP THE FLOW
OF GUNS TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND
STOP GUN VIOLENCE. SO LET'S GET
BACK TO THE ISSUE OF THE SECOND
AMENDMENT. SO THE LETTERSIN
THE OPPOSITION SAYS THIS IS A
RIGHT THEY CAN'T BE INFRINGED
UPON. WE'RE NOT INFRINGING UPON
IT. YOU CAN STILL HAVE THE
RIGHT TO PURCHASE A FIREARM.
AMMUNITION. SO WE GET TO
TAXATION WE KNOW THERE ARE SOME
PRODUCTS IN SOCIETY WHICH WE
PAY SALES TAX FOR BUT IS ALSO
IMPACTS AS WELL. SOME PRODUCTS
HAVE NEGATIVE EXTERNALITIES
WHICH TO PAY AN EXTRA TAX ON.
THINK ABOUT TV'S. BATTERIES
PAINT MATTRESSES YOU PAY SALES
TAX AND YOU PAY A FEW EXTRA
PENNIES PER DOLLAR PER PURCHASE
WHY BECAUSE SALES TAX IS NOT
ENOUGH. TO ADDRESS THE CARNAGE
THAT THAT TAKES PLACE BECAUSE
OF THIS PRODUCT WE'RE NOT
SAYING THAT ALL AMMUNITION AND
GUN SALES COULD PROVIDE
NEGATIVE THINGS IN SOCIETY. A
LOT OF TIMES THEY DO AND SO A
LITTLE EXTRA FOR YOUR PURCHASE.
WHAT COULD I DO IT COULD STOP A
DEATH IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
NEIGHBORS OF CARSON IT COULD
ALSO STOP SUICIDE. THESE MONIES
CAN E SPENT ON RESEARCH DRIVEN
EFFORTS TO STOP GUN VIOLENCE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. THIS IS
NOT SOME CRAZY CRAZY IDEA SURE
THERE IS SALES TAX CURRENTLY ON
FIREARM SALES HANDGUNS LONG
GUNS AND AMMUNITION. BUT ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A- LONG
TERM REVENUE STREAM TO PAY FOR
EFFORTS THAT WORK. AGAIN OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY WORKED
HARD TO GET INTO A PREPARATION
THE BUDGET LAST FEW YEARS. AND
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT THESE
PROGRAMS WORK AND REDUCE GUN
VIOLENCE IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
ASKING RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR MCCARTY MEMBERS IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK PLEASE
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES NOW. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES. MR SAY ARE TELL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES SO I HAD SOME
PREPARED COMMENTS BUT I'M GONNA
LEAVE THOSE DOWN FOR NOW. I
HAVE TO STAND IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS AND I'LL TELL YOU WHY. FOR
ONE THING WE'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT CALVET AND THAT'S A GREAT
PROGRAM AND IT'S VERY EFFECTIVE
AND IT SHOULD BE FUNDED WHAT WE
SHOULD USE DEFINED IT AS
SOMETHING THAT OUR ENTIRE
SOCIETY IN CALIFORNIA. HAS
ALREADY ALREADY GIVEN TO AND
THAT'S OUR TAXES WE HAVE THIRTY
EIGHT BILLION EXTRA DOLLARS
THAT WE DID NOT KNOW WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE THAT WE CAN FUND
THIS PROGRAM AS MUCH AS WE WANT
IF THIS IS THAT IMPORTANT THEN
LET'S DO IT. BUT TRYING TO TAX
AND A TEN AND 11% RATE. A
CERTAIN GROUP OF PEOPLE IS
GOING TO DO THIS IT'S GOING TO
DRIVE THOSE PEOPLE OUT. THEY
WILL DIVIDE THEIR THEIR GUNS ON
THE BLACK MARKET OR THEY WILL
BY- IN ARIZONA OR NEVADA OR
WHEREVER IT IS AND YOU WILL NOT
SEE THAT REVENUE. SO IF THIS IS
IMPORTANT. FOR PETE'S SAKE
FUNDING. THAT'S WHAT THAT
THIRTY EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO.
DON'T STAND HERE AND TELL US
THAT IT'S NOT IMPORTANT TO US
BECAUSE IT IS. WE WANT GUN
VIOLENCE TO BE REDUCED TO
NOTHING ZERO. BUT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO IT WITH THE PROGRAM
THE ALL IT DOES IS SAY WE'RE
GOING TO TAX THESE FOLKS 10% OR
ELEVEN PERCENT. FOR EXERCISING
THEIR SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHT.
FOR PETE'S SAKE THAT'S JUST A
PUNISHMENT FOR DOING THAT. AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO TAKE IT
THOSE PEOPLE WILL GO AWAY. WELL
WON'T SUPPLY THE MONEY THAT YOU
WANT. SO THAT'S WHAT I'M HERE
TO TELL YOU TODAY IF YOU WANT
TO FIND IT FUNDING WE GOT A FEW
DAYS UNTIL THE FIFTEENTH OF
JUNE TAKE IT UP TO THE GOVERNOR
SAY THIS PROGRAM IS SUPER
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT IS. AND
FUND THE THING. MR FRAZIER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- I'VE BEEN A GUN
OWNER AND SHOOTER FOR FIFTY
YEARS MY FATHER TAUGHT ME WHEN
I WAS ELEVEN YEARS OLD. AND I
PROBABLY HAVE MORE GUNS THAN
MOST OF THE REPUBLICANS IN HERE.
AND I PROBABLY SHOOT A LOT MORE
TO- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN CONCERNING TO ME AS
WE HAVE NEVER TAKEN THE
APPROACH. OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
ASPECT WE ALWAYS PERSECUTE THE
GUN OR THE GUN OWNER. BUT WE
HAVE NEVER REALLY TAKEN A
CONCERTED EFFORT BY LOOKING OUT
WHAT MENTAL CAPACITY WE NEED TO
APPROACH OF BEING ABLE TO BE
EFFECTIVE ON THIS FIGHT.
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE. IT'S
ABSURD THAT WE KEEP THROWING
MONEY AT THINGS AND WE GET VERY
MINIMAL RESULTS AND I'M NOT
TRYING TO SAY THAT THE PROGRAMS
THAT YOU HAVE DEMONSTRATORS ARE
MINIMAL RESULTS. WHAT I'M
SAYING IS WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
WAR ON DRUGS. IT'S A VISIBLE
ONLY LOOK AT THE WAR ON
ANYTHING. WE JUST THROW MONEY
AT IT AND NEVER HAVE A METRIC
PLAN TO ACCOMPLISH ANYTHING
WITH. ANTICIPATED EXPECTED
OUTCOMES. WHAT I'M HOPING FOR.
IS THE AUTHOR. IS IT THAT IT'S
MOVES OUT TODAY WILL COMMIT. TO
WORKING WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH
BEHAVIORAL COMPONENT IN THE
BUDGET AND THE DEPARTMENTS AND
THE PROFESSIONALS TO SEEK OUT A
SOLUTION. TO BE ABLE TO WORK
TOWARDS AN ABSOLUTE. PLAN THAT
IS SCRIPTED AND PRESCRIPTIVE
AND WITH ANTICIPATED OUTCOMES A
BRINGS US A VALUE. UNBELIEVABLY
AGAIN AS I'VE SAID BEFORE THE
PEOPLE THAT USE GUNS
RECREATIONALLY. ARE NOT A
PROBLEM IT'S THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH- ANGER
ISSUES OKAY. I USED TO FEED MY
FAMILY I HUNTING. I CAN'T
ANYMORE. BECAUSE I WORK HERE
AND WE'RE ALWAYS HERE. BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO AGAIN SUNDAY. I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT ALSO THE
AUTHOR. COMMITS. TO SOME KIND
OF TRACKING METHODOLOGY
STATEWIDE. THAT IF IT IS NOT
EFFECTIVE. THAT IT IS A PILOT
PROGRAM. AND IT DOES REVERT
BACK BECAUSE THESE THINGS IN
PERPETUITY. THEY HAVE A LIFE OF
THEIR OWN AND IF WE DON'T SAY
THAT IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENTLY IT'LL CONTINUE JUST
TO OF ALL. INTO SOMETHING ELSE.
SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD. AND
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO RESERVE
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE TO
WHAT I'M ASKING FOR. IN THE
SENATE. AND WHEN IT COMES BACK
HERE FOR CONCURRENCE I WILL.
CHANGE MY VOTE. I HAVE NEVER
VOTED ON A GUN BILL IN THIS
HOUSE AS A DEMOCRAT. BECAUSE
I'VE FOUGHT AT ALL TIMES WE
HAVE DONE THIS ABSOLUTELY WRONG
THIS MAY BE THE CHANCE. THIS
VERY WELL MAY BE THE CHANCE.
AND IF WE CAN GET THAT MENTAL
HEALTH COMPONENT AND PLANNED
BACKWARDS I'M ALL IN I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
FRAZIER SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. ON THE
ITEM MR LEVINE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS-
FOR THIS DEEPLY MOVING. FLOOR
DEBATE. FOR THE HUNDREDS OF
CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD WITH YOU
OVER THE COURSE OF THE PAST TWO
WEEKS ABOUT THIS BILL- IN
PARTICULAR MY COLLEAGUE FROM
OAKLEY- DEEPLY MEANINGFUL AND
TRANSFORMATIVE. CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES AND- AND HIS VIEWS
ON HOW WE CAN DO BETTER AND
MENTAL HEALTH. AND ALSO WITH
THE TRAGEDIES THAT WE'VE SEEN
THIS WEEK THAT REPEAT AND
REPEAT AND REPEAT HOW WE HONOR
THE MEMORIES. OF OUR FALLEN
HEROES- INFRSTR SPONSORS WHO
ARE CAUGHT UP IN THIS TRAGIC
VIOLENCE LIKE SO MANY. VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ARE. TOO
MANY SCHOOL CHILDREN ARE. TOO
MANY PEOPLE JUST LIVING THEIR
DAILY LIFE. WE'VE HEARD THE
SAID BEFORE TODAY HOW TOUGH AND
DIFFICULT THIS VOTE IS FOR SO
MANY OF US AND IT'S REALLY ALL
OF US WE HAVE IN FACT SINCE I
WAS FIRST ELECTED CONDITIONED
NOT TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL. IN
IN PARTICULAR. AS ABOUT HALF OF
THIS ROOMY RECALL WHEN OUR
PERSONAL ADDRESSES WERE PUT
PUBLISHED ONLINE. BY GUN RIGHTS
ADVOCATES SAYING THAT DATE THAT
THOSE ADDRESSES WOULD ONLY BE
REMOVED ONCE WE WERE REMOVED
FROM OFFICE. A CHILLING.
MESSAGE TO ALL OF US. AND THAT
WE CAN SHOW THAT WE WILL NOT BE
BULLIED BY THAT. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT WE'VE BEEN CONDITIONED.
NEVER TO VOTE FOR THAT DREADED
Të WORD. WITH A RISK OF OUR
OFFICE- BECAUSE OF IT. BUT THIS
IS SUCH A NARROWLY TAILORED
BILL MODELED AFTER A FEDERAL
PROGRAM THAT EVEN MITCH
MCCONNELL OR PAUL RYAN WHEN
THEY LED CONGRESS NEVER WORKED
TO REPEAL. THAT BAY KEPT THAT
MONEY COMING TO WASHINGTON EVEN
WHEN REPUBLICANS CONTROLLED.
CONGRESS WE CAN DO THE SAME
THING FOR CALIFORNIA KEEP THAT
MONEY IN CALIFORNIA AND WE CAN
CHANGE LIVES WE CAN GIVE PEOPLE
A PATH IN SOCIETY WHERE THEY'RE
NOT CAUSING HARM WERE THAT THEY
KNOW THEY HAVE ALTERNATIVES TO
GUN VIOLENCE WHERE THEY INSTEAD
OF CAUSING PAIN IN THEIR
COMMUNITY CAN BE PRODUCTIVE. IN
THEIR COMMUNITY. MEMBERS THIS
VOTE THIS BILL WILL NOT GET
FIFTY FOUR VOTES. IF YOU DON'T
PRESS THAT GREEN BUTTON. I NEED
YOU TO PRESS THE GREEN BUTTON.
THIS ISN'T A BILL THAT WE JUST
WATCH UP THERE. AND SEE IT UP
THERE. AND IT'S NOT SOME NUMBER.
BUT IT DOESN'T NEED YOU TO
PRESS THIS BUTTON SOMEONE ELSE
IS GOING TO PRESS THAT BUTTON.
THAT'S NOT THIS BILL. THIS BILL
REQUIRES YOU TO PRESS THAT
BUTTON THAT BAND AID OFF PRESS
IT DOWN FAST. CHAU CALIFORNIA
THAT WE HAVE THE COURAGE. THANK
YOU ASK HER AYE VOTE. LOCAL
MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE INSIDE OF A.
THE SHOW OF EMAILS A CALL.
MISS
RAY S. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR'S PLEASE
MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. I ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB FIVE
FIVE ONE. ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN
AB SIX SIX TWO AND ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR AB ELEVEN TWENTY
THREE. ALL BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. AND ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT A. B. FORTY GONZALEZ ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB TWO THIRTY SIX
BERMAN. I ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB
NINE TWENTY ONE MCCARTY. ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY THREE AB NINE
NINE FIVE GONZALEZ. IDM NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE AB SEVEN ONE.
THREE OF US ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT AB SIX FIFTY MARTUCCI.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO GRANT
RECONSIDERATION ON ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
GONZALEZ AND MOVE THE BILL TO
THE AN ACTIVE FILE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED AND THE BILL IS MOVED
TO THE INACTIVE FILE. MEMBERS I
BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO BE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. THIRTY
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE BY MISTER MURATSUCHI. THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN THE
GREENHOUSE GASES THIS RESEARCH
EMAIL. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE CRISIS ACT. LAST APRIL
PRESIDENT BIDEN CONVENE LEADERS
FROM AROUND THE WORLD FOR THE
GLOBAL CLIMATE SUMMIT. TO
ADDRESS A CRISIS THAT IS FACING.
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES IN THIS
LEGISLATURE. AS WELL AS ALL
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE WORLD.
PRESIDENT BIDEN MADE A BOLD
CALL TO ALL AMERICANS. TO CUT
OUR NATION'S EMISSIONS IN HALF
AND LESS THAN TEN YEARS. IN
ORDER TO REACH CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN OUR
OWN GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN ISSUED
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER FOR
CALIFORNIA TO REACH CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. THIS DATE AND THIS TARGET.
IT'S CRITICAL BECAUSE THE
SCIENCE IS CLEAR IF WE BELIEVE
THE SCIENTISTS. WE KNOW THAT IF
WE DON'T REACH CARBON
NEUTRALITY. BYOR BEFORE TWENTY
FORTY FIVE WE WILL MISS THE
POINT OF NO RETURN. I REMEMBER
GOVERNOR BROWN'S DOOMSDAY CLOCK.
BUT THE DOOMSDAY CLOCK IS
TICKING. AND WE NEED TO HAVE
THAT SENSE OF URGENCY THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND LEADERS
FROM AROUND THE WORLD ARE
CALLING FOR. IF WE MISS THIS
POINT OF NO RETURN. WHERE ARE
PLANET OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN. AND THOSE OF US
WHO STILL MAY BE ALIVE. I MAY
NOT BE AROUND BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE BUT I THINK. YOU KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE IN SITTING IN FRONT
OF ME AND MANY OTHERS HOPEFULLY
WILL BE. BUT THOSE OF US WHO
ARE STILL ALIVE WILL SUFFER
MASSIVELY. IF WE DON'T TURN THE
DIRECTION. OF GLOBAL CLIMATE
CHANGE. ALREADY WE ARE SEEING
TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS TOO MANY
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS SUFFERING
FROM THE ALREADY UNFOLDING A
FAX OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
EVERY YEAR MORE DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES MORE LIVES LOST MORE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
DAMAGES SMOKE FILLED ORANGE
SKIES RAINING ASK THAT OUR
CHILDREN IS BREEDING IN. MEGA
DROUGHTS IS AFFECTING FARMING
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS EVERYONE
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE AND OF
COURSE EXTREME HEAT. A HUNDRED
TWENTY DEGREES IN THOUSAND OAKS
A HUNDRED TWENTY DEGREES I
DON'T KNOW HOW WHAT THE
TEMPERATURE IS IN YUCCA VALLEY.
SO WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO WHAT
CAN WE DO. HERE TODAY. AS
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. AS THE LEGISLATURE
THE LEADERS OF THE WORLD'S
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY. TO TURN.
THIS TIDE. AND TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. THIS BILL PROPOSES
THREE MAIN ACTIONS. ONE IS TO
CODIFY. OR STATE'S COMMITMENT
TO ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY BY
OR BEFORE TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
WITH THE NET NEGATIVE EMISSIONS
THEREAFTER. TO REQUIRE THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD THROUGH A LESS
THAN A FRAMEWORK THIS BILL
PROVIDES TO CREATE THE ROADMAP
ON HOW WE GET TO THE CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. COMBINED WITH ANY AND ALL
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE
TECHNOLOGY THAT ARE INNOVATORS
IN OUR STATE CAN COME UP WITH
THE LET ME FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE
OF THE CARBON CAPTURE
TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF FALSE
NARRATIVES THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
OUT THERE BY THE OPPONENTS TO
THIS BILL. NOTHING IN THIS BILL
LIMITS CARBON CAPTURE AND
TECHNOLOGY. I MEAN IF ILAN
MOSQUE OR ANYONE ELSE CAN
FIGURE OUT HOW TO SUCK UP ALL
THE CARBON IN OUR ATMOSPHERE.
TO SAVE THE PLANET MORE POWER
TO THEM THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT
LIMITS CARBON CAPTURE
TECHNOLOGY. AND I WILL COMMIT
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM HEY WORD
AND TO EVERYONE. THAT WE WILL
CLARIFY THAT COMMITMENT IN THE
LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY THAT THERE
IS ABSOLUTELY NO LIMIT. WHY
WOULD I OR ANYONE WANT TO LIMIT
INNOVATION TO SAVE THE PLANET
THAT IS COMPLETELY A FALSE
NARRATIVE THAT OPPONENTS ARE
PUTTING OUT THERE. I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. FAMOUS VERSES YOU
MISS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
SOUTH COAST. SOUTH BAY FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL AS WELL
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF FALSE
NARRATIVES OUT THERE IN THAT
SENSE OF URGENCY IS THAT THE
REALITIES THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
IS HERE IT'S REAL. AND IT'S
AFFECTING US NOW AND IT'S ONLY
GETTING WORSE IN COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE I DEALING WITH THE
BIGGEST BURDEN BUT WE'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN THE LEAST LIKELY
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE TODAY. AND IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT THE HEAT ISLAND
THAT I LIVE AND IT'S NOT THAT
IT GETS SO HOT IT'S NOT THAT I
DON'T HAVE A CONDITIONER AND
THOSE THINGS ARE TRUE. IT'S
THAT WHEN IT GETS SO HOT THAT
ALL THE TOXIC THAT I COUNTY
TALK ABOUT THEY GAVE BACK THEY
GET BAKED IN AND THEY GET
STRONGER AND WE GET SICKER AND
WE'RE DYING SOONER OUT THERE.
IS IT WHEN YOU TAKE ACTION NOW
AND THIS BILL IS ABOUT BEING
SENSIBLE IT'S ABOUT SAYING THAT
FIRST WE NEED TO HAVE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS BEFORE WE MOVE INTO
THE CITY INTO THE SPACE.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT 90% REDUCTIONS THAT'S NOT
A RANDOM NUMBER IT'S WHAT THE
STUDY THAT HAS BEEN- CONDUCTED
HERE BUT IT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
AROUND THE WORLD ALREADY. OUT
THERE AND SO IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT THE CARBON NEUTRALLY THE
REALITIES THAT WE NEED NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS MEANING THAT WE NEED
TO NOT JUST REDUCE OR ELIMINATE
THE CARBON WE'RE PUTTING OUT
TODAY BUT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
ALL THE CARBON THAT'S ALREADY
OUT THERE THAT GOT US TO THIS
POINT ALREADY. SO THAT THEY CAN
OLOGY IS NEEDED WE'RE
DEFINITELY NOT DEFINITELY IN
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE NEEDED TO
MAKE SURE WE ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES OUT THERE WE ARE
CURRENTLY BEING TOLD THAT WE
HAVE TO PICK THESE FALSE
NARRATIVES. BETWEEN ONE AND THE
OTHER AND THE REALITY IS THAT
THIS IS THE FIFTH BIGGEST CASE
STATE BECAUSE WE'RE INNOVATIVE
BECAUSE WE MOVE FORWARD AND WE
CAN FIGURE THIS OUT AND I HAVE
THAT FAITH. AND SO. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU MISS
GARCIA MIS READ. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE I
SUPPORTED THIS AND NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. AND I'M
EXCITED TO SUPPORT THIS AGAIN
ON THE FLOOR. OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE WOULD CODIFY A CARBON
NEUTRALITY GOAL FOR TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. BILL CLIMATE
CHANGE. AS WE ALL KNOW IS
FUELING ENVIRONMENTAL.
DEGRADATION AND SEA LEVEL RISE
WEATHER EXTREMES SUCH AS HE
DROUGHT FOOD- AND WATER AND
SECURITY. IT'S TIME FOR US TO
CONTINUE TAKING BOLD COLLECTIVE
ACTION. AND I REALLY BELIEVE.
THAT THIS BILL WOULD HELP US IN
THAT DIRECTION I READ YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE. THANK
OF HIS RIVASDR QUIRK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SPEAKER
IN MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE FRANKLY
I'VE BEEN TRYING FOR WEEKS TO
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
GET ONE STORY FROM ONE GROUP
AND ONE FROM ANOTHER. AND I WAS
SITTING DOWN WITH THE MEMBER
FROM RANCHO CORDOVA. THIS
MORNING AND WE WERE LOOKING AT
IT AND TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT.
AND I WENT TO THE MEMBER FROM
TORRANCE AND I SAID LOOK. THIS
SECTION AND IT'S FREE. SECTION
THREE IN ITS ON PAGE THREE OF
PRIORITIZE THE USE OF NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS IN CALIFORNIA
TO ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY.
AND THE DIFFICULTY WAS WITH ME
BUT NOW IT'S NOW IT'S NOW IT'S
GOING TO WORK ON IT IS IT'S
HARD TO INTERPRET WHAT
PRIORITIZE MEANS SO I'VE ASKED
HIM TO LOOK AT DIFFERENT
LANGUAGE HE'S GOING TO DO THAT.
SO I WOULD STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
VOTE FOR THIS BECAUSE FRANKLY
ONE OF THE REASONS I CAME HERE
WAS TO WORK ON THIS ONE IS TO
HAVE THESE GOALS AND YOU
ACHIEVE THEM. AND I AM
THOROUGHLY SATISFIED WITH MR
MERECE SU CHI OR EXCUSE ME WITH
THE MEMBER FROM TAURUSES PLEDGE
THANK YOU. MR GALLAGHER. YOU'RE
A CHANCE. YEAH THANK YOU
MEMBERS- AND MISTER SPEAKER-
FIRST OF ALL I I'M GLAD THAT
WE'RE HAVING THIS DEBATE IN
THIS DISCUSSION ON THIS FLOOR.
ABOUT WHAT POLICY SHOULD BE
ABOUT WHAT- BENCHMARKS WE
SHOULD BE SETTING BECAUSE
LATELY THE GOVERNOR'S BEEN THE
ONE MAKING THAT DECISION
HIMSELF. INSTEAD OF THIS BODY.
I JUST WANT TO BEGIN WITH THE
FACT THAT WE SHOULD BE THE ONES
ESTABLISHING WHAT THE POLICY IS.
AND WHAT THE TARGETS ARE. AB
THIRTY TWO WAS LEGISLATION. IT
STARTED IN THIS HOUSE BUT
LATELY WE'VE BEEN ALLOWING THE
GOVERNOR TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS FOR US THAT'S WRONG.
IN THIS BODY SHOULD HAVE LONG
SINCE BEEN PUSHING BACK AGAINST
THAT. AND SAY NO GOVERNOR YOU
DON'T GET TO LEGISLATE. IT'S
BEEN ONE OF MY GREATEST
FRUSTRATIONS AND I JUST WANT TO
START BY SAYING I JUST REALLY
EMPLOYER THIS BODY PLEASE.
PLEASE PUSH BACK. STOP LETTING
THIS GOVERNOR BE THE ONE THAT
MAKES THESE DECISIONS FOR THE
WHOLE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ABOUT
WHEN ELECTRIC CARS YOU KNOW
WILL NO LONGER BE ABLE TO BE
SOLD. WHEN AG EQUIPMENT. WILL
HAVE TO BE TOTALLY ZERO
EMISSION WHICH IS RIGHT BY THE
WAY RIGHT NOW NOT EVEN POSSIBLE
IMPOSSIBLE. TO HAVE THE AG
EQUIPMENT THAT MAKES YOUR THAT
BRINGS FOOD TO YOUR TABLE. AND
AROUND THE WORLD. IS BANNED BY
THIS BY A GOVERNOR BY AN EDICT.
SO I'M GLAD WE'RE HAD AT LEAST
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION THE
LEGISLATURE WERE ELECTED
MEMBERS OF THE ENTIRE STATE.
CAN HELP DETERMINE THIS. BUT A
FORTUNE I THINK THIS THIS BILL
FOR IN PARTICULAR IS WRONG SIDE
AND HERE'S WHY. I THINK CARBON
NEUTRALITY IS A GREAT GOAL FOR
US TO BE A- BUT LIKE WITH. MANY
THINGS WHERE WE'VE GONE WRONG
WE HAVEN'T ALLOWED THE MARKET.
AND WE HAVEN'T ALLOWED THE FULL
AMOUNT OF INNOVATION TO GET US
THERE. YOU KNOW BY THE WAY
WE'VE DONE ALL THIS IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE IS CHINA.
WHERE IS INDIA WHERE'S THE
DEMANDS ON THESE OTHER
COUNTRIES AND STATES WHO ARE
MUCH GREATER CARBON EMITTER IS
THAN ALL OF US. MEANWHILE ALL
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS OF HAVE
HAVE BORNE THE BRUNT. OF THIS
IN COST. COST OF LIVING FOR
ABILITY. AND WE JUST KEEP
STACKING IT ON WALL WE HAVE NO
EXPECTATIONS OF ANYBODYELSE TO
MEET THEIR GOALS. WHERE IS THE
TEETH WERE AS THE TEETH ON ON A
COUNTRY LIKE CHINA WE HAVE WE
DO NOT DEMAND ACCOUNTABILITY ON
THEIR PART. WE DON'T DEMAND
ACCOUNTABILITY ON OTHER STATES
TO MEET THEIR- THEIR LEVELS
MEANWHILE YOU KEEP STACKING ON
US. AND THEN I WILL GET TO THE
ISSUE OF CARBON SEQUESTRATION
BECAUSE THERE IS. A LOT OF
INNOVATION GOING ON RIGHT NOW-
CARBON SEQUESTRATION TECHNOLOGY
AND THIS BILL DOES NOT OF IT
RESTRICTS IT. IT DOES
RESTRICTED. AND WHY IS NOT A
PROBLEM TWO REASONS. THAT'S
BLUE COLLAR JOBS IS GOING TO
COST YOU THAT'S WHY LABOR HAS
BEEN AGAINST THIS BILL. BECAUSE
YOU HAVE BLUE COLLAR JOBS IN
OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY THE COULD
BE PART OF THE CARBON
NEUTRALITY SO. SOLUTION THROUGH
CARBON SQUESTRATION TECHNOLOGY
THAT HELPS TAKE THAT CARBON OUT
OF THE AIR IT'S A QUESTION IT
BACK IN THE GROUND THE NUMBER
TWO AND I'LL THIS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART A MINUTE MOST
IMPORTANT POINT I'M GONNA AND
WITH. BIOMASS RIGHT NOW IT UC
BERKELEY RESEARCHERS ARE
FINDING WAYS TO TAKE BIOMASS
TECHNOLOGY AND SEQUESTER
COMPLETELY IN THE GROUND AND WE
HAVE A WILD FIRE PROBLEM. WE
HAVE A CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE
PROBLEM THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE SHOULD BE WORKING WITH THOSE
RESEARCHERS TO HAVE A BIOMASS
PLANT ALL AROUND THE FOOTHILLS.
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
TAKE THESE FUELS OUT OF THE
FOREST. BURN THEM AND THEN
SEQUESTER THEM. IN THE GROUND
THE TECHNOLOGY IS THERE WE JUST
HAVE TO HAVE THE WILL TO DO IT.
AND WE SHOULDN'T BLOCK THAT
INNOVATION. AND THAT'S WHY I
BELIEVE WE SHOULD VOTE THIS
BILL DOWN TODAY. WE THINK WE
CAN DO BETTER WE CAN HAVE A
BETTER POLICY AND IT SHOULD BE
CREATED BY ALL OF US. BY INPUT
FROM ALL OF US. IN ALL THE
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE AFFECTED
BY THIS AND YOU PAY THE COST OF
THIS. AND NO LONGER BY ONE MAN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. MR COOLEY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HI I HAD A REAL PROBLEM WITH
THIS BILL REALLY BEFORE THE
AMENDMENTS IN MAY. I SAW IT IS
INDEED RESTRICTING. TECHNOLOGY
BASED CARBON SEQUESTRATION 210%
AND MADE ME ASK MYSELF WHY
WOULD ARE WE BECOMING LUDDITES
AND CALIFORNIA ANTI TECHNOLOGY
THE HOME OF TECHNOLOGY SO
PRODUCTIVE AN ECONOMY BUT THAT
THAT ACTUALLY LIMITATION CAME
OUT IN MAY. SO THAT BRINGS ME
BACK TO THE BILL AND SHE- AND
IT SAYS THAT WE'RE GOING TO-
SET THIS BIG STRETCH GOAL OF
REDUCING CARBON REMOVING IT
FROM THE ATMOSPHERE. THAT IT IT
DOES INDEED PRIORITIZE NATURAL
MEANS OF DOING THAT. BUT IT
DOES NOT CRAM DOWN AND LIMIT OF
EFFORTS TO REMOVE CARBON FROM
SORT OF THE PIPELINE BEFORE TEN
THE ATMOSPHERE FOR EXAMPLE 210%
AND IT IS IMPORTANT TO ME
ACTUALLY THAT EXISTING LAW.
I'VE GOT IT HERE ON MY DESK
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE SECTION
THREE EIGHT FIVE SIX ONE.
ALREADY PERMITS UNDER THE MAKE
ALL THE UNDER THE ALL IMPORTANT
SCOPING PLAN THAT AIR BE
ADMINISTERS RECOGNITION OF.
COURTESY QUESTION PROJECTS AND
BEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES SO
ALREADY THE LAW ALLOWS AND
RECOGNIZES THAT THESE SORTS OF
CARBON SEQUESTRATION PROJECTS
FIT WITHIN THE AIR BE SCOPING
PLAN THIS BILL WILL ALLOW IT TO
CONTINUE- I THINK WE DEFINITELY
WANT TO KEEP AN EYE ON HOW THE
A. R. B. ADMINISTERS THESE
PROVISIONS. BUT I SEE IT AS A
STRETCH GOAL. WITH AN EMPHASIS
UPON NATURAL SYSTEMS FOUR
REMOVED FROM THE ATMOSPHERE BUT
ALSO CARBON SEQUESTRATION
SERVER OPERATIVE PLANTED YOU
CAN DEVELOP TECHNOLOGY TO
REDUCE THE FROM BORN IN THE
ATMOSPHERE I DO THINK THAT.
THERE'S A BASIS FOR RECOGNIZE
THAT IN THIS BILL AND UNDER
EXISTING LAW AND I THINK THAT'S
ACTUALLY VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THAT'S A PLACE WHERE INNOVATORS
CAN FOCUS ON SPECIFIC
INDUSTRIAL PROJECTS THE
REVERSAL PROCESS SEES AND LOOK
AT HOW THEY DISTRICT CARVED OUT
AT THAT STAGE BEFORE. GOES IN
THE ATMOSPHERE. I THINK THAT
ACTUALLY FITS WITH. A PROBLEM
OF THIS MAGNITUDE WE NEED EVERY
ARROW IN OUR QUIVER. AND I
THINK PULL IT OUT OF THE AIR IS
GOOD BUT I THINK PULLING IT OUT
OF. THE PIPELINE BEFORE GOES
OUT THE SMOKESTACK IS ALSO GOOD
I THINK THAT'S A PLACE WHERE
TECHNOLOGY CAN PLAY A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE. AND SO I'M
URGEN AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
I FIGUERAS COOLEY MISTER MAYES
YOUR RECOGNIZE AT YOUR DESK I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
MEMBERS I WASN'T PLANNING ON A
SPEAKING ON THIS ITEM BUT JUST-
AFTER HEARING FROM- FROM SOME
OF YOU I THOUGHT I WOULD STAND.
AND I'D SAY A FEW WORDS- I'M
ACTUALLY VERY GLAD WE'RE HAVING
THIS DISCUSSION AND- A DEBATE
FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT BEEN IN
THE LEGISLATURE FOR SOME TIME
YOU KNOW THAT I'VE BEEN A
CONVERT- I WAS A- A CLIMATE
SKEPTIC- WHEN I FIRST GOT
ELECTED. AND THEN WHAT FROM
BECOMING A CLIMATE A CLIMATE
SKEPTIC AS BECOMING SOMEBODY
WHO IS A FIRM BELIEVER. THAT WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY I TO BE
ABLE TO DEAL WITH REDUCING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS TALK
ABOUT THOSE NEGATIVE
EXTERNALITIES. WELL GUESS WHAT
THERE ARE NEGATIVE
EXTERNALITIES AND IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO
RESOLVE THAT. IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THOUGH THAT I'M NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS. AT TODAY
AND THE REASON I'M NOT
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY IS
BECAUSE IT DOES PICK WINNERS
AND LOSERS- I AM SOMEBODY WHO
BELIEVES THAT WE SHOULDN'T JUST
GET TO NET NEUTRAL. WE HAVE TO
GET TO NET NEGATIVE AND THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE EVERY SINGLE
TECHNOLOGY AT OUR DISPOSAL TO
BE ABLE TO GET THERE. A ****
AND IT IS OUR RIGHT I WANTED TO
SPEAK TO MY GOOD FRIEND ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE OR-
BOTH SIDES THE AISLE I GET TO
SAY THAT ON HOW TO DO THAT. AND
NOW BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE- I
KNOW WE'VE HAD SOME DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THIS. THIS FOR YEARS BUT-
THERE IS A RESPONSIBILITY THAT
WE HAVE I'M SOME OF THE
BELIEVES IN BOTH LIBERTY. AND
RESPONSIBILITY AND THIS IS ONE
OF THESE THE THESE ISSUES THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SHOULD
DO BECAUSE IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO REDUCE OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
WE DON'T NEED TO WAIT FOR CHINA
BUT TO BE ABLE TO STEP UP IT'S
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THAT.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE HOWEVER. THIS
IS PICKING. WINNERS AND LOSERS
THE TERM PRIORITIZE OR FOR THAT
MATTER EXCLUDING- THAT CARBON
CAPTURE WE HAVE TO HAVE ALL.
ALL TECHNOLOGIES TO BE ABLE TO
GET THERE AND UNFORTUNATELY.
THE DOESN'T US THERE I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US OVER THE
SUMMER AND EVEN IN THE FALL. TO
HOPEFULLY WORK IN A TRI
PARTISAN WAY. TO COME UP WITH A
WITH. A REAL COHESIVE PLAN. AND
GET RID OF ALL THE POLITICAL
TALK. TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON
HOW TO ADDRESS THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. ISSUE AND I WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR. IN DOING SO. TAKE THIS
RACE MEMBERS IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK ON THE ADAM RAZOR MAKES
NOW. RAZORBACK FUNDS NOW IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PARTICIPATE ON
THIS ITEM MISTER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AYE AYE TO IS
NOT GOING TO SPEAK ON THIS BUT-
LISTENING TO THE DEBATE. AND
FRANKLY REFLECTING BACK ON THE
HELL I'VE GONE THROUGH
PERSONALLY ON MY VOTE ON CAP
AND TRADE- THE- FEEL COMPELLED
TO. YOU KNOW A LOT A FEW OF US
FRANKLY TO MEMBERS OF THIS BODY
OF TAKING PERSONAL TIME TO GO
TO THE DEPARTMENT ENERGY OF
SCHOOL FOR LEGISLATORS- I
HAPPEN TO BE ONE OF THEM IF
THEY CAN A LOT OF PERSONAL
TIME. TO LEARN. ABOUT THIS
ISSUE TO LEARN ABOUT WHAT IS
GOING ON AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO
DIVERSE A FIVE OUR PORTFOLIO TO
BE SMART. ABOUT HOW WE GO AFTER
CLIMATE CHANGE. WE NEED TO
REALIZE THAT 76% OF
CALIFORNIANS BELIEVE CLIMATE
CHANGE IS REAL IN THESE TO BE
AFFECTED. HOWEVER WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION AND A DUTY TO BE
SMART AND EFFECTIVE IN OUR
APPROACH. AND I AGREE. WITH
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
DESERT AREA- TRYING TO MAKE
THINGS TRY PARTISAN. WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY. AND WE HAVE
THIS LIBERTY THAT WE HAVE TO DO
THESE THINGS. BUT WE ARE
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS IN
THIS BILL. MY COLLEAGUE FROM
NICHOLAS BROUGHT UP A GREAT
POINT. ABOUT BIOMASS. ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WE CAN SEQUESTER
CARBON DID THE BURNING FRANKLY
MORE MORE SO THAN ANYTHING ELSE
IN OUR STATE IS AFFECTING US
IT'S RAINING ASH IT IS RAINED
ASH IN MY DISTRICT. EVERY
SINGLE YEAR FOR THE LAST TEN
YEARS WE'VE HAD FOREST FIRES
SINCE BEFORE FOREST FIRES WERE
A COLD POPULAR THING TO TALK
ABOUT ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. WE
HAVE SMART AND CREATIVE AND
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO GO ABOUT
DOING THIS. ONE OF THINGS I
HAVEN'T HEARD ENOUGH ABOUT IS
ABOUT HYDROGEN FUEL AND
HYDROGEN FUTURES JUST THIS WEEK.
A TOYOTA CAR THE SIZE OF THE
CAMERAS DOWN IN THE BASEMENT OF
A LOT OF YOU CRUISE AROUND IN.
BROKE THE LAN MILES RECORD
TRAVELED. ON HYDROGEN. WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT HYDROGEN FUEL
SOLUTIONS INSTEAD WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ELECTRIFICATION AND
BATTERIES AND THAT'S IT. EVEN
THOUGH THE LANGUAGE OF THIS
BILL SAYS NATURAL WAYS. LET'S
BE SMART ABOUT HOW WE GO AFTER.
CARBON SEQUESTRATION LET'S MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT PICKING
WINNERS AND LOSERS LET'S MAKE
SURE THAT ARE INDUSTRIES THAT
MAKE OUR STATE AND PROVIDE
THESE JOBS WERE OR TALK ABOUT
BRINGING JOBS BACK. AFTER COVE
IT BUT YET WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
AT PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS.
MEMBERS WERE SMARTER THAN THIS
WE CAN DO BETTER THAN THIS.
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM NICOLAS
SAID LET'S LET'S ALL GET
TOGETHER LET'S GET AROUND THE
TABLE AND HAVE A REAL
CONVERSATION. AND FIGURE OUT
WAYS TO INCENTIVIZE OUR
INDUSTRIES TO MOVE FORWARD. SO
WE CAN HAVE THAT DIVERSIFIED
PORTFOLIO THAT WE ALL NEED. SO
WE CAN HAVE THAT BETTER
BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR OUR
CHILDREN ASKING FOR NO VOTE.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. ON THE BILL MISTER
MURATSUCHI YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU I AGAIN WANT TO MAKE IT
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR IF IT'S NOT
CLEAR ENOUGH NOW IT WILL BE
MORE CLEAR. WHEN WE AMEND THE
LANGUAGE IN THE SENATE. WE ARE
NOT WE HAVE NO I HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO INTEREST IN
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS
AMONG TECHNOLOGY. F. ILAN MUSK
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO SUCK UP
ALL THE CARBON IN THE
ATMOSPHERE MORE POWER TO HIM.
WE DO NOT WANT TO. DISCOURAGE
ANY KIND OF INNOVATION IN TERMS
OF CAN'T CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE AND SO YOU KNOW I ASK A-
MY COLLEAGUES TO STOP SPREADING
THIS FALSE NARRATIVE THAT THAT
WE ARE- WE WHERE SOMEHOW
LIMITING INNOVATION. THAT THE
BOTTOM LINE THE REASON WHY. BIG
OIL AND- WORKERS AND THE UNIONS
THAT REPRESENT FOSSIL FUEL
WORKERS. ARE OPPOSED TO THIS IS
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO CONTINUE
TO DRILL AND TO BURN FOSSIL
FUELS. AND WE KNOW AGAIN THAT.
IF WE READ IF WE ARE SERIOUS IF
YOU BELIEVE THE SCIENCE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WE CANNOT
CONTINUE WITH BUSINESS AS USUAL.
AND SOMETIMES. YOU KNOW AS
LEADERS. WE HAVE TO TELL OUR
FRIENDS. THAT WE NEED TO DO THE
RIGHT THING. TODAY TO FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE TO SAVE THE
PLANET I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
CARCLUB THE ROLE. MEMBERS WHAT
IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THAT IS OUT OF OUT.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. WELL
CLOSER ALL TIED TO VOTE. HIGHS
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE IS ON FILE
FOR RECONSIDERATION IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO GRANTING MS
FREEDMAN'S REQUEST FOR
RECONSIDERATION ON ITEM. FOR
THIS AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE
SEEING AND HEARING NINE.
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN THE
MEASURES NOW BEFORE THE BODY
YOU MAY TAKE IT UP THE CLERK.
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS IN EQUITY
THE SOLID WASTE. MS FRIEDMAN
MAIL. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND- OF THIS IS A BILL THAT
DEALS WITH A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
THE MATERIAL THAT'S USED IN
PACKAGING NAMELY BUBBLE WRAP
EXPANDABLE MAILERS AND POLY
STYRENE. NOW WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING TO INDUSTRY ABOUT THIS
BILL FOR SEVERAL MONTHS AND
SINCE YESTERDAY WE'VE AGREED TO
TAKE A MEMONS FROM SEVERAL
DIFFERENT GROUPS INCLUDING OF
LIFE SCIENCES AND
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY WE'VE
ACCEPTED THEIR LANGUAGE AND
THEY REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION
FROM THIS BILL. WE'VE AGREED TO
EXEMPT ALL RAW FOOD PRODUCTS
THAT ARE SHIPPED TO EXEMPTS ANY
TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THE BILL
IS NOT GOING TO AFFECT PRODUCTS
THAT ARE USED TO SHIP FOOD TO
KEEP FOOD SAFE TO KEEP FOOD
FRESH OR FROZEN ITEMS FOR FOOD.
BELIEVE ME MEMBERS I AM ANTI
FOOD POISONING THE LAST THING
THAT WE WANT IS FOR PEOPLE'S
ITEMS TO COME SPOILED. WE DON'T
WANT ITEMS TO A ROAD RIDE
BROKEN WHEN INDUSTRY COMES TO
US WITH CONCERNS WE HAVE BEEN
MORE THAN WILLING TO HEAR THEIR
CONCERNS AND ADDRESS THEM AND I
PROMISE YOU. THAT SHOULD THIS
BILL GET OUT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO ENGAGE WITH INDUSTRY TO MAKE
SURE THIS IS DOABLE MEMBERS
THIS BILL IS ABOUT BRINGING
INDUSTRY TO THE TABLE THIS IS
ABOUT BEING SUSTAINABLE AND
PUSHING NOT JUST. UNTIL
COMPANIES ARE ALREADY DOING
THIS ON THEIR OWN IN WHICH
THERE ARE THERE ARE SEVERAL. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN PRODUCTS
ARE SHIPPED INTO CALIFORNIA
FROM CHINA FROM OTHER PLACES IN
THE WORLD THAT THEY MEET THE
SAME STANDARDS THAT SO MANY OF
OUR CALIFORNIA COMPANIES ARE
TAKING UPON THEMSELVES. THIS IS
THE LOW HANGING FRUIT. THE LAST
THING THAT I WILL SAY BESIDES
GIVING YOU MY COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH ALL OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS IN GOOD FAITH
IS I HAVE BEEN DOING. ITS TO
REMIND YOU THAT WHEN THIS
MATERIAL COMES INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES IT GOES TO
LANDFILLS WHERE IT IS NOT
RECYCLABLE WHERE CAUSES
PROBLEMS IN OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
WE'RE ALL OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS
IN ALL OF YOUR REPAIRS. ARE
HAVING TO PAY A 100% OF THE
COST OF THIS MATERIAL. SO THIS
MATERIAL COMING INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES IS NOT. FREE WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE A
REPLACEMENTS THAT TODAY. ARE
THAT ARE ARE THE MARKET. THIS
IS JUST THE TO THE- THAT THE
INTO ME. AND WHAT THAT AND
REMEMBER ALSO. THAT AFTER THIS
BILL GET TO THE SENATE YOU WILL
HAVE ANOTHER BUT THE APPLE WHEN
IT COMES BACK ON CONCURRENCE. I
YOU TO ALLOW US TO CAN. THIS
AND CONVERSE. BY VOTING I ON
THIS BILL TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU AS FRIEDMAN
RESTRICT UBER HERE RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER- WHEN
IT COMES UP FROM THE RECYCLING.
THERE'S WILL THERE'S A WAY-
I'VE DART CONTAINER CORPORATION
MY DISTRICT. THERE'S ONE DOWN
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO WE
HEAR A LOT ABOUT STYROFOAM.
THIS RECYCLE STYROFOAM.
NAVISTAR PHONE DISPOSAL SITE MY
ACTUALLY MY CITY. WERE
RESIDENTS CAN DISPOSE OF
STYROFOAM. PRESIDENTIAL PROP.
WITHOUT OBJECTION OKAY THIS IS
A PICTURE USED FOR RECYCLE STAR.
THERE'S A CLOTHING ROD FOR
REESE TIRE. HERE'S A COMB EVEN
THOUGH I HAVE NO HAIR FROM
RECYCLED. I WISH I USE IT. WELL
HAVE BASEBALL TRIM RULER AND
LYFT ISN'T PROP. AT THE BE RISK
BUT TO IS THERE IF WE DO THAT
SO IT'S TRYING DEMONIZED THESE
THING. BUT TO WORK ON IT AND IN
CAL DRIVEN AWAY- JOBS IN ST.
BUT COME BACK AND DO THIS HAS
BEEN DONE AND CAL RIGHT NOW ONE
DO IT ON A MUST WHOLE LET SO I
UNDERSTAND THE- AUTHORS CAN
POINTS. THERE ARE WAYS TO SOME
PRODUCTS IF CALIFORNIA MUST'VE
WE MADE SO MUCH SO WHY NOT THIS
IS THE PER EXAMPLE LIKE TOWARD
YOU WANNA COME ON A TOUR IS
DONE LOOK LIKE L. EVEN IF CLIP.
IT'S FROM RECYCLE STAR SO THERE
A USED THIS. DR COURT. YOUR
RECOGNIZED. YES A CO AUTHOR AND
OF AB THIRTY NINETY THIRTEEN
SEVEN ONE I WILL POINT OUT THAT
THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
RECYCLABLE THAT CAN'T BE
RECYCLED. THAT'S THE BIG
PROBLEM WE HAVE RIGHT NOW YOU
ALL KNOW THESE CLAM SHELLS THE
FOOD COME IN. YOU KNOW I USED
THEM TO BUT IF YOU TALK TO
SOMEBODY WHO SAID IT IN THE
ACTUAL BUSINESS WHAT THEY WILL
TELL YOU IS YEAH THE RECYCLABLE
BUT THEY'RE NOT. AND THE REASON
IS ECONOMICS IN ORDER TO
RECYCLE A CLAM SHELL YOU HAVE
TO GET THAT PLASTIC AT LEAST
ONE CONTAINERFUL. EVEN THEN YOU
DON'T GET THAT MUCH MONEY FOR
IT SO IT'S BETTER IF YOU HAVE
TO. NOBODY EXCEPT IN THE VERY
LARGEST CITIES IS ABLE TO GET A
CONTAINER FULL OF THOSE. MAYBE
IN NEW YORK CITY. CERTAINLY NOT
IN THE- IN ALAMEDA COUNTY. YOU
CAN'T RECYCLE EVERYTHING THAT'S
RECYCLABLE IT DOESN'T WORK.
PLASTICS ARE VERY HARD TO
RECYCLE ECONOMICALLY. NOT A
QUESTION OF WHAT'S PHYSICALLY
POSSIBLE IT'S QUESTION THE
ECONOMICS AS LONG AS YOU HAVE
THAT ECONOMIC BARRIER WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A LOT OF PLASTICS
THAT ARE GOING TO GO. BE USED
FOR FIVE MINUTES AND THEN B.
AND- A TRASHY FOR THE NEXT
COUPLE THOUSAND YEARS THANK YOU
PLEASE VOTE AYE ON THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. I SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION.
THIS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH I'LL ACCEPT THAT IS MY
CLOTHES AND MY WITH MY
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH INDUSTRY TO MAKE THIS
WORKABLE FOR EVERYBODY. CARCLUB
RURAL. WELL THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A-
THE SENATE IS ALREADY GONE HOME.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
MS
FRIEDMAN. WHAT'S YOUR PLEASURE.
THIS FRIEDMAN WAS A CALL.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN. AB THREE
THREE THREE. KAMLAGER BILL
PRESENTED BY MISTER GRAY
MERCURY. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRD THREE BY FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER AN
ACCOLADE IN THE CRIMINAL GAINES.
MISTER GRAY YOU MAY OPEN
MEMBERS. THE SERGEANTS AND MR
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. AS WE'VE ALREADY
DISCUSSED AB THREE THREE THREE
ON THIS FLOOR I'M GOING TO
LIMIT MY COMMENTS TO DESCRIBE
THE CHANGES SINCE THE LAST TIME
THE BILL WAS UP FOR A VOTE
RECENT AMENDMENTS REFLECT GOOD
FAITH CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. THE ASSOCIATION
REMAINS IN OPPOSITION HOWEVER
WE HAVE TAKEN SEVERAL
AMENDMENTS THE BILL IMPRINT
REMOVES PREVIOUS LANGUAGE WHICH
REQUIRE THE PROSECUTION PROVE
THAT THE GANG OFFENSES
BENEFITED SOMEONE OF THE GANG
OTHER THAN THE PERSON WHO
COMMITTED THE OFFENSES. THE
CURRENT BILL ALSO REMOVES THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE
PROSECUTION PROVE THE ALLEGED
GANG HASN'T ESTABLISHED
HIERARCHY AND ALSO ELIMINATES
ALL OF THE SECTION J. WHICH
INCLUDES REMOVING THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE
PROSECUTION PROVE THE PEOPLE
WHO COMMITTED PREVIOUS OFFENSES
WHERE MEMBERS OF A CRIMINAL
STREET GANG AT THE TIME THOSE.
OFFENSES WERE COMMITTED. AS I
SAID EVEN WITH THESE AMENDMENTS
DISAGREEMENTS CONTINUE TO EXIST
WITH THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY. THIS IS A
COMPLICATED BILL BECAUSE GANG
ENHANCEMENTS ARE COMPLICATED
CHARGE AND MORE WORK REMAINS AS
THIS BILL MOVES TO THE SENATE.
WHEN I ASKED HIM THE AUTHOR-
WELL THE BILL IS STILL IN THE
FAMILY WAS A COMMITMENT TO KEEP
GOOD FAITH OPEN MINDED
NEGOTIATIONS GOING WITH THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY SHE HAS
MADE THAT COMMITMENT. AND
DELIVERED ON THAT COMMITMENT
WITH THIS MOST RECENT EVENTS-
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE- IN CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU MISS GRAY. DR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ONCE AGAIN I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE THREE.
MEMBERS THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
BILL THE WAY THIS AREA OF LAW
CURRENTLY OPERATES ERODES THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR COURT SYSTEM.
WE ARE SIMPLY ASKING JUDGES AND
PROSECUTION TO DO THEIR JOBS.
ONCE AGAIN TO BE CLEAR THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE STILL ON THE
HOOK FOR THEIR UNDERLYING
OFFENSE. NO ONE IS GIVEN A GET
OUT OF JAIL FREE PASS. BUT IT
DOES REQUIRE STANDARDS TO BE
PLACE TO PROVE THAT SOMEONE WHO
IS ACCUSED OF A CRIME IS
AFFILIATED WITH A GANG. HERE
ARE SOME EXAMPLES OF EVIDENCE
THAT WERE USED IN THE PAST TO
PROVE SOMEONE WAS IN A GANG. A
MICKEY MOUSE PEN. ATTENDING A
SINGLE TAMAYO CELEBRATION.
WEARING A SPORTS LOGO. A SPORTS
TEAM LOGO. WEARING A RED A
PRINT TO WORK. ATTENDING A
FUNERAL AND LIVING IN A
PARTICULAR NEIGHBORHOOD. THERE
IS NO EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE THAT
THESE GANG ENHANCEMENTS DETER
SOMEONE FROM JOINING A GANG NOR
THAT THEY MAKE THE COMMUNITY
SAFER. THERE IS HOWEVER VERY
STRONG EVIDENCE THAT THESE GANG
ENHANCEMENTS HAVE BEEN USED AS
A ANOTHER TOOL TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY NEGATIVELY
IMPACT BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
BILL AIMS TO HELP MAKE THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM MORE FAIR
JUST AND HUMANE. AS PREVIOUSLY
STATED THE AUTHOR HAS WORKED ON
THIS BILL AND HAS ADDED
AMENDMENTS AND HAS PLACE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THIS BILL
IF IT'S IF IT REACHES THE
SENATE. I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON
AB THREE THREE THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR WEBER MISTER
BRYANT. YOU'RE RIGHT NEXT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE THREE
AS WELL. WE HAVE GANG
INJUNCTIONS THAT CRIMINALIZE
WHOLE NEIGHBORHOODS. WITH THE
GANG DATABASE WHICH THE LAPD
AND OTHERS HAVE ADMITTED TO
FALSELY CLASSIFYING FOLKS IN
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS IN THAT
DATABASE AND THEN WE SLAP GANG
ENHANCEMENTS ON IT. AND THE
JUDICIARY TO EXACERBATE
SENTENCES THAT COST THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. OUR STATE CORRECTIONS
EXPENDITURES JUST THIS YEAR R.
THIRTEEN PLUS BILLION DOLLARS.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY. TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR COMMUNITIES TO
BRING FOLKS HOME TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY. THESE GANG
ENHANCEMENTS ARE NOT GOING AWAY
WITH THIS BILL. WHICH IS
STANDING TO ME. SIMILAR TO
OTHER BILLS WE TALK ABOUT THE
LAST FEW DAYS IT JUST RAISES
THE STANDARD NEEDED TO PROVE
THAT A PERSON BELONGING AGAIN.
THAT THE ACT WAS COMMITTED ON
BEHALF OF THE GAME. IT IS
COMPLETE REASONABLE APPROPRIATE
AND RESPONSIBLE TO RAISE THAT
STANDARD. AND A STATE WITH
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
INCARCERATED IN THE LARGEST
JAIL SYSTEM ANYWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY. I BELIEVE IN THIS BODY
I STAND STRONG IN SUPPORT I'M
ASKING FOR YOUR I. VOTERS WITH.
THIS BOERNER HORVATH YOUR
RECORD. THANK YOU MEMBERS I'VE
SPENT ABOUT THIRTY HOURS TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT THIS BILL I AM
NOT NEITHER A PUBLIC DEFENDER
NOR PROSECUTOR- BUT I AM A
MEMBER OF THIS BODY AND I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WHAT I
LEARNED FROM THOSE THIRTY HOURS
OF LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU AND
THAT IS IF WE'RE GOING TO ADD
EXTRA YEARS ON TO A SENTENCE IT
IS APPROPRIATE THAT THERE IS A
CLEAR DEFINITION THAT IS USED
CONSISTENTLY AROUND THE STATE.
AND THERE'S DUE PROCESS I KNOW
IN THE OPPOSITION THEY SAY
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
PROVE THAT THIS A MEMBER OF
SOMEBODY WAS A MEMBER OF THE
GANG THEY'RE NOW LITERALLY
DEBATING THREE DIFFERENT WORDS
I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT
THOSE THREE WORDS WILL BE
WORKED OUT IN THE SENATE I
THINK THIS IS SOMETHING WE NEED
TO DO AS A BODY AND I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE AND LET'S CONTINUE TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION THIS
BILL SHOULD NOT THAT A DATE
LET'S MOVE IT TO THE SENATE I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. MISTER.
THANK YOU I AM. I TOTALLY
RESPECT- V. MOTIVATION BEHIND
THIS BILL HI. I JUST THAT THERE
TO MANY BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
IN PARTICULAR THERE ARE. ON THE
RECEIVING END OF THESE GANG
ENHANCEMENTS. AND I KNOW THAT.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE USE THESE
ENHANCEMENTS SHOULD NOT BE USED
TO UNFAIRLY. CALL AFTER.
PICULET COMMUNITIES I JUST WANT
TO SHARE AS- A FORMER LOS
ANGELES CUNTY DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND AS A FORMER LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER. ONE OF MY EARLIEST
EXPERIENCES. AS A PROSECUTOR. I
WAS PROSECUTING. A. FELONY
CHARGE FOR ROBBERY. AGAINST AN
ALLEGED GANG MEMBER. IT WAS A
PRETTY SAID IN A RUN OF THE
MILL ROBBERY. WHERE. I BELIEVE
IS A GROCERY STORE AND A-
PYJAMA LATINO NEIGHBORHOOD. AND
I ASKED THE STORE CLERK WHO WAS
THE TO THE LEAD WITNESS. IN THE
CASE. WHEN I WAS. TALKING WITH
THEM BEFORE I PRESENTED THE
CASE. IS THAT THE GUY THAT'S
SITTING IN THE COURTROOM. THE
THAT'S HIM. YOU READY TO
TESTIFY NO I CAN'T TESTIFY. I
CAN'T TESTIFY BECAUSE I'M TOO
AFRAID. BECAUSE I'M GONNA HAVE
TO GO BACK THAT'S MY JOB THAT'S
MY STORE I HAVE TO GO BACK TO
THAT STORE I KEEP THAT'S MY
COMMUNITY. AND IF I TESTIFY.
THEY'RE GOING TO COME AND GET
ME. AND SO THAT HIGHLIGHTS.
WHAT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION IS HIGHLIGHTING IN
THEIR LETTER OF OPPOSITION.
THAT FEAR AND INTIMIDATION OF
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY WHERE
THEY GANG OPERATES TENDS TO BE
THE PRIMARY MOTIVATION BEHIND
ALL GANG RELATED CRIMES. AGAIN
JUST AS WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE MASS INCARCERATION OF BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE WE NEED TO
REMEMBER THAT THE VICTIMS OF
MANY OF THESE GANG CRIMES ARE
THE SAME BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
THAT LIVE IN THE SAME
COMMUNITIES. I JUST ASK. THAT
AS WE CONTINUE TO DEBATE THESE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM BILLS
THANK YOU NOT JUST THINK ABOUT.
THOSE THAT ARE BEING CHARGED
BUT ALSO THOSE THAT LIVE IN
THESE COMMUNITIES THOSE THAT
ARE VICTIMS OF THESE CRIMES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AND- FIRST OF
ALL TO THE COMMENTS FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM TORRANCE- THE
SCENARIO YOU LAID OUT UNDER AB
THREE THREE THREE WOULD BE ABLE
TO THE CHARGES AGAIN WITH THE
GANG ENHANCEMENT. SO LET'S BE
VERY CLEAR WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FEAR THAT IT'S ABSOLUTELY JIM
AT THAT THERE ARE FOLKS IN
NEIGHBORHOODS- BUT IF YOU'RE-
GLOBAL FEAR CRIME. AND WHAT
HAVE YOU BUT WE SHOULD NOT BE
LEGISLATING WITH FEAR. WE
SHOULD BE LEGISLATING BASED ON
FACT AND THE FACT THE MATTER IS
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON RACIAL
JUSTICE ISSUES IS IMPORTANT
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF THAT COMMITMENT. A
STAGGERING 92% OF PEOPLE
RECEIVING ANNOUNCEMENTS A 95%
OF THOSE IN THE CALGARY
DATABASE OF PEOPLE OF COLOR I
REQUEST PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR
LEVIN YEARS HAD MANY CLIENTS
THAT WERE PUT INTO THE GAME
DATABASE BECAUSE OF THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS. WITH A SCHOOL
WITH WHAT THEY WERE WEARING.
AND ONCE THEY'RE IN THE GANG
DATABASE THAT FOREVER CHANGED
THEIR LIVES AND LET ME TELL YOU
THERE ARE CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOODS
WHERE. YOU'RE GONNA FIND FOLKS
THAT. OUR SUBJECT IS GOING
DATABASE MORE FAR MORE THAN
OTHERS. AND THE REALITY IS THAT
THIS AGAIN IS BASED UPON STUDY
THE COMMITTEE ON REVISION OF
THE PENAL CODE WHICH IS MADE UP
OF FORMER JUDGES ACADEMICS
LEGISLATORS. ARE BEFORE MAKING
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THEY HELD
HEARINGS AND SOLICITED FEEDBACK
FROM PROSECUTORS POLICE JUDGES
VICTIMS VICTIMS FAMILY MEMBERS
AND ADVOCATES AS WELL AS
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS AND IMPACTED
PEOPLE AND SCHOLARS AND THEY
RECOMMENDED A GANG AND HAS A
SHOULD BE LIMITED. TO ONLY THE
MOST CORNER CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES
AB THREE THREE THREE IMPLEMENT
THAT RECOMMENDATION BY
DISTINGUISHING BETWEEN CRIMES
ARE COORDINATED COMPARED TO
CRIMES ARE NOT COORDINATED. A
NOTICE OF NOTABLY DOESN'T EVEN
GO AS FAR AS THE COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDED. WHY SOME CLAIMS AS
THE MAKES AN FOR AND DISCONTENT
PROSTITUTING AND HUSBANDS IS
SIMPLY JUST NOT TRUE. AB THREE
THREE THREE ASSEMBLY REDEFINES
HOW THE PROSECUTION PROVE THE
EXISTENCE OF THE ALLEGED
CRIMINAL STREET GANG THE
REQUIRES THAT GANG CHARGES BE
PRESENTED IN SEPARATE
PROCEEDINGS TO AVOID BIAS. WELL
MANY CRIMINAL JUSTICE EXPERTS
DO BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD DO
AWAY WITH GETTING HOUSES
COMPLETELY THIS IS NOT WHAT A.
B. THREE THREE THREE DOES- AB
THREE THREE THREE ALSO DOES NOT
PREVENT DISCOLORATION PROSECUTE
VIOLATIONS LAW WHATSOEVER AND
DOES NOT LIMIT THE KINDS OF
CRIMES AGAIN HAS TO BE ADDED
TO. THAT AND SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT. ONLY
ABOUT FEAR LOOK LOOK WE HAVE
CREATED THE- WE'VE CREATED THE
ISSUE OF MASS INCARCERATION. IN
OUR STATE BASED MOSTLY ON FEAR
AND FEAR BASED ARGUMENTS NOT
FACT BASED ARGUMENTS THIS STILL
ALLOWS US TO GO OUT TO THOSE
THAT ARE ACTUALLY COMMITTING.
CONDUCT THAT FALLS IN THE
CATEGORY OF GANG CONDUCT THAT
SHOULD HAVE DURING AN HAS. BUT
NOT JUST THROWING ABROAD NOT
OVER ENTIRE COMMUNITY. BASED
UPON FEAR BUT THAT ASPECT YEAH
FOR YOUR VOTE. MISTER COOPER
YOUR BROADCAST THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I DON'T I HEARD
COLLEAGUE FROM TORRANCE TALKING
ABOUT VICTIMS THE DA I DON'T
HER OTHER FOLKS TALKING ABOUT
VICTOR. I SPENT THIRTY YEARS AS
A COP IT'S BEEN TEN YEARS AND
IN OUR CAR. OF THE GETTING THE
GET SARJU I COMMITTED UNIT
FLOOD F. GAME IN AND PUT GAMERS
IN THE DATABASE. THE HURLEY
SOME OF A FEW FOR. DURING GAME
COME. AND GETTING LOCALS THE
MONITORS INTO. YEAH WHEN I DO
YOU THE GETTING THEM. SO IT'S
ABOUT. GANG MEMBER AND- EARLIER
LIKE MEMBER. FOR CARSON TALK
ABOUT THE SHOOTING A WHO THE
BIG. VICTIMS OF AND BROWN
PEOPLE GANGS PREY ON PEOPLE.
LOOK AT THE NUMBER. IT IT'S
BEEN THAT WAY WE GOT A CHAIN
THAT IF GOES BACK TO EARLIER
CALL. ABOUT INVESTING HIS
NEIGHBOR DENTAL TO DO THAT THE
PEOPLE ARE DYING EVERY DAY. IN
HEARD PASSION NEVER CARSON
VOICE ABOUT WHAT HAPPEN.
WELCOME TO MY OLD BIZ GETTING
SO UP. IN VICTIMS ARE AFRAID TO
TESTIFY IN THIS. IT YEAH I HERE
SEVEN YEARS. AND I FOR SOME
ABOUT. EVERYBODY ELSE I REALLY
HEARING. MUCH VICTIM. PARDEE
ALL AND GOOD PASSED THAT BUT IF
VICTOR HELP VIC OUT I DON'T
HAPPEN. THEY VICIOUS. YOU KNOW
MAYBE IF WE HELP WIN IN THE
FIGHT WE'RE SO WORRIED ABOUT
BEING MILLION SO MUCH OF. WE
GOT BUT THIS YEAR. THERE A
SCHOOL TO PRISON. WHAT'S WEIRD
ABOUT AND CONVEY. HOW ABOUT
STOP THE PIPE THE FIRST THE
KIDS I'LL TELL YOU OF WITH
SACRAMENTO THE PRE K. T. K.
THAT IS A- BECAUSE THE NEVER IN
K. RAISE A KID. SO WE'RE
HOPEFULLY RESTORE THAT NOW
COMING YEARS THAT BUT STILL YOU
HAVE SOME BAD OUT THERE DOING
YOU STUFF. AB ONE ONLINE PROP
FOR SEVEN PER. THAT THE PEOPLE
IN JAIL IN PRISON NOW. FOR A
HOLES THE WORD THE WORST. OKAY
GANG MEMBER. MURDER TOM THE BIT
THE- HAS PRETTY MUCH PER.
UNLESS YOU'VE BEEN THAT THAT
THAT'S THE TRUTH LOOK AT EXIT
IT. SO IT'S POINT WHAT'S LEFT.
WE'VE DONE SO MUCH AND WE GOT
SAID IT JUST FOR VICTIMS WHO
INNOVATIVE PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
HERE BECAUSE IF FAIL SOME OF
THE INDUSTRY UP THERE'S BEEN
SOME IF YOU TALK TO THEIR
MOTHER SISTER. ON A REGULAR I
DON'T THINK YOU HAVE SO IT'S A
BIG DIFFERENCE TO SIT HERE AND
TALK ABOUT IT IN THE OFFENSE
WHEN LOOKING HAVEN'T SEEN IT.
AND DEALT WITH IT ON A DAILY
BASIS- PEOPLE AFRAID TO SPEAK
UP IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD THEY
LIVE THERE THEY DON'T SPEAK UP
AND WANNA GET SHOT BECAUSE
GAINES RUN IS NOT OVER CRIME IS
NOT THIS A- OKAY THEY'RE
THEY'RE- AND SO THESE FOLKS ARE
VERY RUTHLESS AND YOU THE GAME
HAS BEEN ON ABSOLUTELY HER
PERCENT. IT SHOULD BE. HELLO OF
THEM JUST DON'T. YOUNGER AND
YOUNGER. THE SHOOTING A FLORIDA
YOU THOUGHT TV RISK. PARTY TO
DEAD TWENTY SHOT UP. PROBABLY
SOME GANGSTA IN THERE. OKAY IT
HAPPENS THAT WAY THE SHOOTINGS
OCCURRED SERVICE REP RIGHT NOW.
A LOT OF INVOLVED INK THAT CARE
A LOT IS NOT TO THEM. FLESSEL
WE DEAL WITH IN. IT IS HARD PUT
YOURSELF IN THE IN THEIR SHOES
BUT THAT'S ALSO PEOPLE THINK.
SO CHANGE IT THANK AND COULD
FOCUS IN ON THE ON THE END
RESULT. IT'S FROM THE BEGINNING
WE'VE DONE NOTHING ABSOLUTE.
RECORD BUDGET. BUT WILL STAY
NEIGHBORHOODS. THAT ARE SCREWED
UP WE'RE GONNA BE THAT WAY
BECAUSE WE DON'T INVEST ENOUGH.
SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO GET WE'VE
GOTTEN IN THE PAST THIRTY FORTY
FIFTY YEARS THE SAME
NEIGHBORHOODS LET'S CHANGE THAT
THIS ENHANCEMENT STUFF I MEAN
GOD. GIVE ME A BREAK THINK
ABOUT A VICTIM LIKE MIKE SORRY
THE NUMBER FROM CARSON SAID.
HOPE IS NOT YOUR FILM YOU HAVE
AN EXPERIENCE THAT. YOU HAVE NO
IDEA. SO I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS
BILL. MR VOEPEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES. WE'RE
GETTING TOWARDS THE END OF
SERGEANTS ARE B. AS BRIEF AS I
CAN. BUT WE PASSED BILL AFTER
BILL AFTER BILL AFTER BILL
RESTRICTING POLICE OFFICERS.
SOFTENING UP THE WHOLE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM WE'VE GOT LAYER UPON
LAYER THAT WE'VE DONE IN THE
LAST THREE DAYS TWO DAYS. AND
I'D LIKE TO REMIND EVERYONE.
THAT THIS BILL WILL CUT SLACK.
NOT JUST FOR THE GANGS OF COLOR.
BUT I REMIND YOU AND I'VE.
CROSTON WHEN I WAS THE MAYOR OF
MY CITY THERE ARE.
FUNDAMENTALLY CAUCASIAN BIKER
GANGS THERE ARE VIETNAMESE
GANGS THERE ARE. ALL SORTS OF
GAMES OUT THERE AND THIS WILL
GIVE THEM ADVANTAGES. AND THE
INTIMIDATION FACTOR IS A REAL.
AND IF YOU CROSS SOME. THEY
WILL COME AFTER YOU. SO KEEP
THAT IN MIND THANK YOU. YEAH
THANKS FOR VOEPEL MISTER K.
HAND YOU RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I HAVE TO
JUST BE HONEST I THOUGHT THERE
COMMITTEE AT THAT OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY AS MANY OF YOU KNOW. I
THOUGHT THROUGH THE- WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO NICE TO BE TODAY
NO OF THIS IS HARD TO LISTEN TO
THIS ONE SAY THAT. I HAVE.
INDIVIDUALS ARE CHOI WITH.
RELATED GANGS. AND I JUST WANT
TO TALK WITH HUMANITY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS FOR ONE SECOND
BECAUSE THEIR PEOPLE. AND THEIR
PEOPLE WHO DONE YOU'VE MADE
MISTAKES HAVE DONE HORRIBLE
THINGS AT TIMES. BUT THERE
PEOPLE IN THE FUNDS. NATURE OF
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
I WANT TO BE CLEAR USE JUSTICE
LOOSELY THERE THEY DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'S MUCH JUSTICE IN
OUR SYSTEM RIGHT NOW. IS THAT
WE DO NOT TAKE SOMEONE'S
FREEDOM AWAY FROM THEM. AND
LESS. THE PROSECUTOR HAS
PROVEN. BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT. THAT THAT PERSON
COMMITTED THE CRIME. WE DEMAND
UNANIMITY IN A JURY WE DEMAND
THAT THE- PROSECUTOR DO HIS OR
HER JOB. BEFORE WE TAKE
SOMEONE'S FREEDOM. BEFORE WE
TAKE THEM AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILY AND THEIR JOB AND THEIR
LIFE. BECAUSE YES. THEY'RE
CALLING FROM SACRAMENTO SAID
VICTIMS DESERVE. JUSTICE
ANOTHER COLLEAGUE SAN DIEGO
SAID THE UNDERLYING CRIME HERE
WILL BE SERVED IN EFFECT IN
MANY CASES THERE MIGHT BE A GUN
ENHANCEMENT AS WELL BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T TAKE ABOUT A HALF AN
AWAY. BUT WE SHOULD NOT BE
TAKING YEARS. WILL BE CLEAR
YEARS AWAY FROM INDIVIDUALS AND
LESS THE PROSECUTOR HAS DONE
JOB THAT IS THE FUNDAMENTAL
BASIS OF OUR SYSTEM AND ALL
THAT THIS BILL ASKS FOR
PROSECUTORS TO DO IS DO THEIR
JOB AND IF THEY DO IT. IN THE
GARDEN HAS BEEN WILL BE PLACED
IN THE INDIVIDUAL SERVER
DIFFERENT ADDITIONAL TIME. BUT
IF THEY CAN'T DO THEIR JOB WE
WILL NOT DENY THEM FREEDOM FOR
ADDITIONAL YEARS. SO MEMBERS I
PERSONALLY DON'T THINK THAT'S
TOO MUCH TO ASK I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE AMERICAN SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE DEMANDS OF US. SO YES
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION OF FEAR. AND WHEN
MORE THAN 90% OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
GETTING THIS PLACE ON THE MORE
PEOPLE OF COLOR WE NEED TO ASK
YOURSELF IF WHAT WE'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW IS JUST IN HIS RIGHT
AND THE ANSWER TO ME IS CLEARLY
NO. AND SO I ASKED HER AYE VOTE
TODAY BECAUSE IT IS INCUMBENT
UPON US TO LOOK AT OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAKE IT MORE JUST FOR THOSE WHO
ARE PLACED INTO IT. AND THE
BURDEN OF PROOF. IS THE
FUNDAMENTAL THING THAT SHOULD
MAKE IT JUST AND THAT IS ALL
THIS BILL DOES IS DEMAND WHAT
IS ALREADY PLACED IN OUR SYSTEM
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANKS
FOR KI<c.cyan> SEEING NO</c>
ADDITIONAL. DEBATE ON THE
MATTER. MISTER GRAY YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO'VE SPOKEN THIS AFTER
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND- AND
TO THOSE OF YOU WHO'VE SPOKEN
OPPOSITION INCLUDING MY
COLLEAGUE AND GOOD FRIEND FROM
ELK GROVE. SOME MEMBERS MIGHT
SAID APPEARED. COUNTY YOUR
ARGUMENTS I'M NOT GONNA DO THAT
BECAUSE YOUR ARGUMENTS ARE
SOUND. ISSUES RAISED BY MY
COLLEGE MORE GROVE ARE ACCURATE.
AT THE SAME TIME WE DO HAVE
INSTITUTIONALIZED RACISM IN
THIS COUNTRY AND IN OUR SYSTEM
OF JUSTICE AND IT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. IN THIS CASE WE HAVE
AN AUTHOR WHO IS WORKING IN
GOOD FAITH WITH THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY WE HAVE A
MEMBER ACTING AS A FOR JACKIE
HERE WHO HAS A STRONGER PRO LAW
ENFORCEMENT RECORD THAT
PROBABLY MOST THE FOLKS ON THIS
FLOOR. WE HAVE TO DO THE WORK
IT'S HARD WORK AND WE'VE TAKEN
SOME AMENDMENTS HERE IN THIS
HOUSE. I'M IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS. IN THE
SENATE AND I HOPE WE BRING A
BILL BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THAT
HAS NO OPPOSITION. THAT WE DO
THE WORK. TO BUILD CONSENSUS
SOMETIMES THE UNBRIDLED
ARROGANCE OF THE MAJORITY OF
WHICH I'M A PART OF. RUNS RIGHT
OVER PEOPLE ON BILLS THAT'S NOT
HOW I DO BUSINESS IT'S NOT HOW
I'M GONNA DO BUSINESS WITH- THE
GOOD SENATOR ON THIS BILL-
WE'RE GOING TO DO THE WORK AND
HOPEFULLY. WE'LL COME BACK WITH
THE PRODUCT IT'S EVEN BETTER
THAN THE ONE YOU'RE GOING TO
VOTE ON TODAY AND I ASKED
RESPECTFULLY MEMBERS. GIVE US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT WORK
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. AND
WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
OKAY. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SERVER. MR
PRAYER. THIS WEEK I THINK WE
HAVE- SEVERAL MEMBERS ALL FOR
TOMORROW IT WILL MOVE THE CALL
AND- RETURNED WITH THE FULL
VOTES HERE MOMENTARILY MISTER
GRAY MOST OF CALL.
I AM
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON MR
GRAY'S ITEM CARPOOL POSTS. AB
THREE THREE THREE ALL MEMBERS
WHO WISH TO VOTE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED UP AS FORTY ONE
KNOWS TWENTY SIX THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE A MIS CORREOS ITEM. THIS
IS FILE ITEM. TWENTY ONE. AB.
NINE THIRTY SEVEN. QUACKERY
ASSEMBLY GO NINE THIRTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO AND
OTHER PERSON ACCORDING TO
ENFORCEMENT MISS KOREA. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
SO PROUD AND HONORED 2%
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THREE SEVEN
THE VISION ACT. WHICH WOULD
PROTECT REFUGEE AND IMMIGRANT
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE BEEN
DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR RELEASE
FROM BEING FUNNELED INTO
IMMIGRATION DETENTION BY
CALIFORNIA LOCAL JAILS AND
PRISONS. THERE CALIFORNIANS WHO
HAVE COMPLETED THEIR TIME
EARNED PAROLE OR HAVE HAD THEIR
SENTENCES COMMUTED BY GOVERNOR
BY A GOVERNOR AFTER A CLOSE
REVIEW OF THEIR CLEMENCY
APPLICATION. ONE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF CAL AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ASSIST WHICH
TRANSFERS OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
TO ICE THEY IGNORE THE RECORD
OF REHABILITATION STABLE RE
ENTRY PLANS. AND THEIR NETWORK
OF COMMUNITY AND FAMILY
SUPPORT. MANY CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES INCLUDING LOS ANGELES
SANTA CLARA SAN FRANCISCO
HUMBOLDT SAN JOAQUIN SANTA CRUZ
CONTRA COSTA HAVE ALREADY
RECOGNIZE THIS AND HAVE ENDED I
AND HAVE ENDED TRANSFERS TO
ICE. MEMBERS IF NOT FOR WHERE
THESE INDIVIDUALS WERE BORN
THEY WOULD BE ALLOWED TO RETURN
HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. AB NINE THREE
SEVEN WILL MOVE OUR STATE
CLOSER TO FULFILLING ITS
COMMITMENT TO IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS DISPROPORTIONATELY
HARMING BLACK LATINO INDIGENOUS
AND AAPI COMMUNITIES IN RECENT
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE IN
CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED A COMMITMENT AND
WILLINGNESS TO REFORM OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND
END MASS INCARCERATION. HOWEVER
FOR IN WHO HAVE EARNED RELEASE.
THIS JUST MEANS THEY'RE GOING
TO BE HANDED OVER TO ICE AND
FACE PERMANENT SEPARATION FROM
THEIR FAMILIES AND FROM THEIR
COMMUNITIES. LET ME BE CLEAR.
CALIFORNIA IS UNDER NO
OBLIGATION TO ASSIST THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WITH
DEPORTATIONS THIS BILL ALSO
DOESN'T PRECLUDE THE STATE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
RESPONDING TO A CRIMINAL
WARRANT OR PARTICIPATING IN
JOINT TASK FORCES. IF THE
PURPOSE OF THAT TASK FORCE IT'S
CRIMINAL LAW ENFORCEMENT NOT
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT. MANY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVE AN INTER MINUTE
SENTENCES MEANING THAT MEANING
THAT THEIR ONLY OPPORTUNITY TO
RETURN TO THE COMMUNITY AFTER
GOING THROUGH THE RIGOROUS
PAROLE PROCESS WHERE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THEIR CASE ON
THE RECORD OF REHABILITATION
ARE CLOSELY. REVIEWED ONLY
ABOUT ONE IN FIVE THAT HAVE
THEIR CASES REVIEWED BY THE
PAROLE BOARD EARNS RELEASE.
IMMIGRANT CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
SERVED OUT THEIR SENTENCES OR
HAVE BEEN PAROLED SHOULD NOT
FACE DOUBLE PUNISHMENT. THERE
ARE PLENTY OF WELL DOCUMENTED
EXAMPLES IN WHICH IS THE
TENSION HAS SHOWN SYSTEMIC
ABUSES IN HUMANE CONDITIONS AND
EVEN INVOLUNTARY FORCED
STERILIZATION. I WANT TO SHARE
THE STORY OF PARASAILING CAL
CAME TO THE UNITED STATES AS A
CHILD AS A REFUGEE FROM LAOS HE
WASN'T ON HOUSE TEAM LIVE IN
FRESNO WHEN HE WAS ARRESTED AND
INCARCERATED AT THE AGE. IN
CDCR CUSTODY AND HE WAS
SELECTED FOR A FIRE CAN
PLACEMENT WHERE HE SPENT LONG
HOURS AS AN INCARCERATED
FIREFIGHTER ON THE FRONT LINES
OF SOME OF THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
FIRES THAT OUR STATE. HAS EVER
SEEN. CAL EARNED HIS RELEASE
FROM CDC ARE BUT HE DID NOT GET
TO RETURN TO HIS FAMILY. IN
FRESNO RATHER CDC ARE
FACILITATED HIS TRANSFER TO ICE
WHERE HE SPENT TEN MONTHS IN A
DETENTION FACILITY IN
LOUISIANA. DURING THE DEPTHS OF
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
HOW RECENTLY RECEIVE A PARDON
FROM GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN
RECOGNITION. OF HIS RECORD OF
SERVICE AND REHABILITATION. I
AM THANKFUL TO THE GOVERNOR FOR
USING HIS EXECUTIVE POWER
TOWARDS JUSTICE. BUT PARITY
BETWEEN CITIZEN. AND NONCITIZEN
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD BE THE NORM
NOT THE EXCEPTION. THE VISION
NOT COLD AND ICE TRANSFERS FROM
OUR LOCAL JAILS AND CDCR. AND
PRACTICE A TREATMENT. AND IT'LL
END THE PRACTICE OF TREATMENT
WHERE PEOPLE ARE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY JUST SIMPLY BASED
ON WHERE THEY WERE BORN. I HAVE
SPOKEN WITH AND HEARD FROM
SEVERAL OF OUR COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT THE SPIRIT OF THIS BILL
WHO HAVE SUGGESTED CARVE OUTS
FOR CERTAIN CATEGORIES OF
CRIMES INCLUDING SEX CRIMES.
AND OTHER OFFENSES I WANT TO
SAY CLEARLY IN CLOSING HOW WE
WILL ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS AS
THE BILL MOVES OUT OF THIS
CHAMBER BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND
AND APPRECIATE THOSE MEMBERS
WHO WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
BUT HAVE RESERVATIONS THERE. AS
BILL HEADS TO THE SENATE I
FULLY INTEND TO WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
FELLOW MEMBERS AND THE AMAZING
COMMUNITY COALITION THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT HAS PROPELLED
THE LEGISLATION FORWARD TO FINE
TUNE THE LANGUAGE. SO THAT WE
CAN GET THIS BILL SIGNED INTO
LAW THIS YEAR BECAUSE WE CAN'T
LET ANOTHER YEAR GO BY WHERE
THOUSANDS OF IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES. ARE BEING TURNED OVER
TO ICE BY OUR STATE. I COMMIT
TO A GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO
FACILITATE THAT PROCESS
INCLUDING THROUGH MUTUALLY.
AGREEABLE AMENDMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISS CARILLO
MISTER GIBSON. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH FOR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
ONE OF THINK THE OFFER FROM LOS-
FOR BRINGING THERE'S A BILL
BEFORE US TODAY ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE THIRTY SEVEN I AM A PROUD
CO AUTHOR OF HIS BILL WHICH
WOULD ENSURE. NO LET ME TALK
ABOUT A STORY. A STORY THAT I
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU ABOUT
THAT INDIVIDUAL BY NAME OF
JOAQUIN. A NAVY VETERAN. WHO
SERVE THIS COUNTRY NOTABLY. BUT
NEARLY. ALMOST A PORTED BECAUSE
OF CDCR WORKING WITH ICE.
ARCHANA RYAN ARRIVED HERE THE
UNITED STATES WHEN HE WAS TEN
YEARS OLD. HE WAS BROUGHT HERE
FROM MEXICO TO CALIFORNIA. HE
SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
NAVY I BROUGHT. ON A BATTLESHIP
AND WAS DEPLOYED TO IRAQ KUWAIT
AFGHANISTAN AND RECEIVED
SEVERAL. SEVERAL MEDALS OF
VALOR. HE WAS ALSO PROMISE.
CITIZENSHIP FOR LIFTING. BUT
NEVER RECEIVED ANY CHANGES AND
IT'S IMMIGRATION STATUS. AFTER
WALKING WAS HONORABLY
DISCHARGED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX. HE HAD TO ACCESS HERE NO
ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE
SERVICES TO HELP HIM DEAL WITH
THE IMPACT OF HIS SERVICE. TO
THIS COUNTRY. BECAUSE OF THE
MENTAL. ISSUES THAT HE WAS
DEALING WITH JOAQUIN DEALT WITH
THE STRESS THE TRAUMA AND
EXPERIENCE DURING HIS
ENLISTMENT BY MEDICATING
HIMSELF WITH ALCOHOL AND BECAME
INCARCERATED FOR THREE YEARS.
HE WAS RELEASED EARLY FOR GOOD
BEHAVIOR. BY THE STATE
AUTHORITIES BUT CITIES THEY ARE
IMMEDIATELY HANDED HIM OVER TO
ICE. IF NOT FOR THE
INTERVENTION BY IMMIGRATION
RIGHTS ADVOCATES JOAQUIN WOULD
HAVE BEEN DEPORTED AFTER MORE
YEARS. A FIGHTING HIS
IMMIGRATION CASE WORKING
FINALLY WON HIS CASE TO STAY
WITH HIS FAMILY AND CHILDREN
HERE IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. HE
WAS GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BECOME A UNITED STATES CITIZEN
BECAUSE OF HIS SERVICE. WE MUST
PASS THE VISION ACT SO THAT NO
ONE ELSE HAS TO SUFFER THROUGH
WHAT JOAQUIN EXPERIENCE. AT
HONOR THE SERVICE OF OUR
IMMIGRANT VETERANS MEMBERS THIS
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR STRONG AYE
VOTE OR AB NINE THIRTY SEVEN.
MISTER DAVID CHIU YEAR
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. COLLEAGUES I KNOW IT'S
EASY TO GET LOST OFTENTIMES IN
LEGAL ARCANA OF THE DISCUSSIONS
WE HAVE AROUND POLICY BUT I
WANT TO JOIN IN SUPPORT OF THE
VISION ACTS. BY SHARING.
ANOTHER HUMAN STORY ABOUT WHO
THIS IMPACTS IT CONSTRUCTION OF
MINE WHO WORKS AS A SUBSTANCE
ABUSE COUNSELOR AT A TREATMENT
CENTER IN SAN FRANCISCO A
CAMBODIAN REFUGEE TE TAAN.
SINCE BIRTH HIS LIFE WAS
DEFINED BY VIOLENCE. AFTER HE
FLED THE GENOCIDE IN CAMBODIA.
SURVIVE THE GANG WARS IN FRESNO
AS A CHILD. AT THE AGE OF
SIXTEEN A JUDGE SENTENCED HIM
TO LIFE IN PRISON. FOR KILLING
A RIVAL GANG MEMBER. TWENTY
FIVE YEARS LATER IF GREW UP I
BECAME A FULL TIME CERTIFIED
SUBSTANCE ABUSE COUNSELOR HE'S
HELPED INCARCERATED PEOPLE
BREAK THE SAME CYCLE OF TRAUMA
VIOLENCE THAT HE HAD GOTTEN
CAUGHT IN. THE PAROLE BOARD
FOUND THAT HE POSE NO RISK TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND RECOMMENDED
THAT HE BE RELEASED. BUT
INSTEAD OF ALLOWING HIM TO USE
HIS TRAINING AND HIS EXPERIENCE
TO MAKE OUR SOCIETY SAFER. CDCR
CALLED ICE ON TEST RELEASE
DATE. AND DECEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN. TO BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF DEPORTING HIM TO A COUNTRY
THAT HE FLED AS A CHILD TO A
COUNTRY WHERE WE NO LONGER HAD
TIES. NOW BECAUSE OF HIS
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS.
HE WAS FORTUNATELY RELEASED
FROM ICE CUSTODY BUT THIS STORY
IS NOT UNIQUE. SOUTHEAST ASIAN
REFUGEES ARE THREE TO FOUR
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE
DEPORTED FOR PAST CONVICTIONS
THAN OTHER IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND A RECENT YEARS
WE'VE SEEN A HUGE SPIKE IN
THESE NUMBERS BETWEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN A
TWO HUNDRED AND 79% SPIKE IN
THE DEPORTATION OF CAMBODIAN
REFUGEES. A 58% INCREASE IN THE
DEPORTATION OF VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN REFUGEES. AND THIS
TARGETING OF THE SOUTHEAST
ASIAN REFUGEE COMMUNITY HAS
CONTINUED TO THIS DAY. FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
MARCH. THE SAME WEEK AS THE
HORRIFIC ATLANTA SHOOTING AND
DURING OUR PRESIDENT'S FIRST
HUNDRED DAYS IN OFFICE. THERE
WERE THIRTY THREE MEMBERS OF
OUR VIETNAMESE REFUGEE
COMMUNITY WHO WERE DEPORTED.
AND I WAS- API COMMUNITY
EXPERIENCE IS A VERY DISTURBING
RISE IN ANTI ASIAN HATE. MANY
OF US BELIEVE THAT WE NEED
POLICIES TO UPLIFT OUR
COMMUNITIES. TO UPLIFT
INDIVIDUALS LIKE TO TAUNT. AND
I BELIEVE THAT THE VISION ACT
CAN HELP DO THAT I BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS HOW WE REFLECT A-
SOCIETY AND WITHOUT I'M PROUD
TO BE PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR THIS
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MISTER LEE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SIR I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
NINE THREE SEVEN THE VISION ACT
BUILDING UPON WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES TALK ABOUT CONGRESS
AND JUST GOES TALKING ABOUT ON
A HIGHLAND HUMAN. OF A
SOUTHEAST ASIAN ARM OF ON WHEN
ON WHEN IS A VIETNAMESE REFUGEE
WHO CAME TO THE UNITED STATES
AS A CHILD IN NINETEEN NINETY
TO BE REUNITED WITH HIS FAMILY
WHO MIGRATED TO THE U. S. JUST
FIVE YEARS BEFORE HIM AS A
YOUTH ON FAMILY STRUGGLE THE
POVERTY AND ADJUSTING TO LIFE
IN A NEW COUNTRY. AND FACING
ANTI ASIAN RACISM EVEN THEN AND
BOWLING AS A YOUTH HE
ULTIMATELY MADE A MISTAKE THAT
RESULTED IN FEWER ROBBERIES ON
SERVED OVER TWENTY YEARS TWENTY
YEARS IN PRISON FOR THOSE
ROBBERIES AND CHOSE TO TURN HIS
LIFE AROUND HE PARTICIPATED
MULTIPLE SELF HELP PROGRAMS
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ACTIONS WORKED
MULTIPLE JOBS. AND ENROLLED IN
JOB SKILLS TRAINING. AND THEN
IN OCTOBER TWENTY NINETEEN. I
COMPLETED HIS. HOW AND OF BEING.
TO IS FOR. ON WAS TRY. TO ICE
CUSTODY DEEP. PROCEEDINGS SO ON
HAS BEEN RELEASED TODAY HE
STILL FACES THE POSSIBILITY OF
BEING DEPORTED TO THE COUNTRY
HE LEFT AS A CHILD. AND MEMBERS
I THINK ABOUT HOW. UTTERLY
INHUMANE AND CRUEL IS. AFTER
SERVING YOUR TIME IN PRISON
DECADES OF YOUR LIFE FOR A
MISTAKE THAT YOU MADE AND TO
TURN YOUR LIFE AROUND TO BE
SENT BACK TO A COUNTRY. WHERE
YOU HAVE NO TIES ANYMORE
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF MILES
ACROSS THE PACIFIC AND THAT IS
THE REALITY FOR SO MANY ASIAN
AMERICANS. THAT COULD BE FACING
DEPORTATION THAT ARE STILL
RIGHT NOW. FACING POTENTIALLY
OF MEDIEVAL KIND OF PUNISHMENT
OF EXILE I THINK ABOUT THAT
ESPECIALLY IN THE CONTEXT OF.
RISING ANTI ASIAN SENTIMENT AND
I'LL DO YOU ALTHOUGH THE COMP
THE MOST COMMON REFRAIN AGAINST
ASIAN AMERICANS THIS. IS GO
BACK TO YOUR COUNTRY. THIS WHAT
THIS BILL IS DOING IS SEEKING
TO NSA COMPLICITY OF RECORD OF
UPHOLDING THAT STEREOTYPE
LITERALLY SENDING US BACK TO A
THE COUNTRY WERE BORN IN
PERHAPS JUST LIKE IN NEW IN
CASE BUT WE HAVE NO MORE TIES
HERE WE ARE AMERICAN OR ASIAN
AMERICANS AND THAT'S WHY WE
NEED TO END THE STATE SPONSORED
DEPORTATIONS ENDING THE SENDING
PEOPLE BACK WHERE THEY CAME
FROM STEREOTYPE. THE VISION X.
SUPPORTS THE ASIAN A ASIAN
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION DEPORTATION WHO
ARE OFTEN THEMSELVES VICTIMS OF
ANTI ASIAN VIOLENCE AS YOU UP
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE ADVOCACY TO
STOP ASIAN HATE MUST INCLUDE
PEOPLE LIKE ON THE TALK ABOUT
THE VISION AS A CORE BILL THIS
THE CYCLE VIOLENCE AND HATE ON
EMMERICH INCLUDING PLEASE
ACCOUNT RIGHT NOW SO I ASK FOR
YOUR ITEM. THANK YOU MISTER LEE.
MISTER SANTIAGO YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU S. ARRIVED SUPPORT OF
THE ACT AND THAT ALL MY
COLLEAGUES WE WOULD DO SAME AND
OF SUPPORTING A AND I'M NOT
SURE SO ABOUT ONE ARKANSAS-
MUNOZ IS ONE OF OUR TO STAY. I
WHO NOW AS A SO TO ARE. CAME
THE US ABOUT FIVE YEAR OF AGE.
WHO IN HIS MOTHER'S IN THE-
HOUSEHOLD HE GROUP IN LOS
ANGELES- A IT THE GAME-
ENVIRONMENT. ANY JOINED AGAIN
TO SURVIVE. AS WAS IN CARS
GIVEN LAW AND- IN PRISON HE
GREW AND IT. GREW UP FOR
SPEAKING ATTENDED MANY PROGRAM.
AMONG COMPLIMENTS FOUNDED A
CUSHION GROUP THAT IMPLEMENTED
RESTORED OF. AND ALL THESE
IDENTITY GROUP CLOSE WERE DOING
TO ME VET. HEY CARLOS WAS ABLE
TO LEAVE HAS NOW A PRODUCTIVE
MEMBER OF SOCIETY. BY THE TIME
THAT HE WAS LEAVING. HE WAS
HELD A BLANKS. HE WAS FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO BE BACK
THE- AND WAS ABLE TO STAY. BUT
THAT'S NOT THE CASE WITH MANY
PEOPLE. AND HERE'S THE BOTTOM
LINE. HEY. FAIRNESS THE
FAIRNESS A AND IF YOU BELIEVE
IN THE QUALITY YOU BELIEVE IT
INEQUALITY FOR ALL. AND WE'RE
NOT SAYING GIVE ANYBODY A GET
AWAY JAIL FREE CARD WE'RE NOT
SAYING. IN THIS BILL REDUCE A
SENTENCE NOT SAYING IN THIS
BILL. A PERSON HE SHOULD BE
SENTENCED FOR THE CRIME THEY
DID WHAT WE ARE SAYING NOW IS
VERY CLEAR. THAT PERSON HAS
SERVED THEIR TIME. THAT PERSON
HAS UNDERGONE REHABILITATION.
AND IF WE'RE REALLY GONNA VALUE
IMMIGRANTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REALLY GOING TO SAY
THAT THAT THEY'RE EQUAL AND WE
FOUGHT IN. GOD KNOWS LOTS OF
LEGISLATION COMES OUT OF THIS
BUILDING IS AIMED. AT AT
EQUALITY. LOTS MORE WORK TO DO
BUT THAT'S WHAT THE AIM IS.
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME
EQUALITY FOR IMMIGRANTS AS WELL.
IF THEY HAVE SERVED THEIR TIME.
THEN WHEN THEY HAVE SERVED
THEIR TIME. THEY SHOULD NOT BE
TREATED ANY DIFFERENTLY THAN
ANYONE ELSE. THAT'S A SIMPLE.
PROMISE OF THIS BILL TREAT THEM
LIKE YOU WOULD ANYONE ELSE. I
RESPECT LAST NIGHT OF. I THANK
MR SANTIAGO SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE MISCREANT YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND TO THE MEMBERS
THAT- SPOKE IN SUPPORT AND I
RECOGNIZE THE TIME AND FOR
THOSE THAT PUT THE MICROPHONE
DOWN AND HAD ADDITIONAL STORIES
TO SHARE AS WELL. WE ALL KNOW
AS A GREAT DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER
KING SAID. THE ARC OF MORAL.
THE ARC OF THE MORAL UNIVERSE
IS LONG BUT IT BENDS TOWARDS
JUSTICE REPRESENTATION MATTERS
AND WE THIS BODY MUST ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS THAT HAVE
SERVED THEIR TIME WILL BE
DENIED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REUNITE WITH THEIR FAMILIES AND
HAVE A SECOND CHANCE SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF WHERE THEY WERE
BORN. THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
TRADITIONALLY DISCRETION
SENTENCING THE POWER THE PAROLE
BOARD OR THE OR IMMIGRATION
CUSTOMS AND ENFORCEMENT FROM
DOING THEIR JOB. I ESPECIALLY
WANT TO THANK THE JOINT AUTHORS
AND THE CO AUTHORS OF THIS BILL
THE LATINO AND A. P. I.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUSES THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
BLACK LIVES MATTER CALIFORNIA
BEND TE ARC THE I SAID LOOK I
THOUGHT A CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
COALITION FOR THEIR SUPPORT. OF
THE VISION ACT WHICH WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE
A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AND NOT
JUST THE CALIFORNIA FOR SOME.
AND ENSURE THAT NO ARM OF THE
STATE OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL
BE USED TO FUNNEL INDIVIDUALS
INTO IMMIGRATION DETENTION AND
DEPORTATION IN THIS GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. GLOBAL OF THE ROLE. ALL
THOSE THE DESIRE TO GO. ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO THE- ALL
THOSE THE IT IS TO VOTE.
THE
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTES I'D
FORTY TWO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MITTERAND LIBERAL
CHANGE- CHANGE AB NINE THREE
SEVEN ALL RIGHT TO NOT. BURKE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FIFTY SEVEN
I CANNOT VOTING. CORRECTION THE
SUMMIT- NINE THIRTY SEVEN I TO
NOT VOTING. THIS ONE MOTIONS
BOTH CHANGE AB TEN THREE NO TO
NOT VOTING. BROOCH CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FORTY THREE NO TO NOT
VOTING. MR VOEPEL. AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX NO TWO I. WELL CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL SOME AGO
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX NO TÁI.
MISTER JOHN VOCE WILL CHANGE
ITEM TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY SEVEN FROM I TO NOT
LOADING. BURKE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO ASSEMBLY GO NINE
THIRTY SEVEN I TO NOT VOTING.
MEMBERS WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON
CALL. I'M PREPARED WITH THE
CALL. ON FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
TWO FIVE SEVEN MS GONZALEZ CORP
WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
SHOULD WISH TO WELL.
MS
GONZALEZ REPLACES THE CALL.
THERE IS A REPAIR TO LIVE THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM. FORTY THREE
AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE MISTER
LEVIN'S MEASURE CARPOOL POSTS.
ALL MEMBERS ROAD WHICH TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
I FORTY NINE KNOWS NINETEENTH
THAT MEASURE FAILS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION MR LEVINE IS ASKING
FOR IMMEDIATE RECONSIDERATION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED. AND
MEMBERS WE HAVE A THIRD ITEM.
AND WE HAVE A THIRD AMONG CALL
MEMBERS THIS IS MISS FRIEDMAN
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE CLERK WILL
POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTER WHICH
DEVELOPED. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
WHICH DEVELOPED. CLARK WELL
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
THIRTY SO KNOWS TO EIGHT. THAT
MEASURE FAILS.
MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWO FIVE FIVE
MURATSUCHI IS ON FILE FOR
RECONSIDERATION IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO GRANTING MISTER
MERCY CHIEF. AT HIS REQUEST FOR
RECONSIDERATION. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT REQUEST IS
GRANTED. MS REYES JUST GAVE ME
A TIME OUT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS
ARE PREPARED TO LIVE THE CALL.
ONCE AGAIN I FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB TWO FIVE SEVEN
THIS GONZALEZ CLERK POSTS. ALL
MEMBERS WOULD WISH TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE.
CLOSE
THE ROLE. ENTELLA THE VOTE
HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS TWENTY
SEVEN THE MEASURE FAILS. MS
CONSULTS NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION. THE.
ISRAEL'S
HUGH ARE RECOGNIZED FOR MOTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR'S PLEASE
MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE
INACTIVE FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
EIGHTY SIX SEVEN NINE FRIEDMAN
ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB ELEVEN
NINETY TWO KALRA ITEM THIRTY
SIX EIGHTY THREE EIGHTEEN
LEVINE. THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
MEMBERS. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY JUNE
FOURTH NO FLOOR SESSION. NO
CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY JUNE
SEVENTH FLOOR SESSION. TO ONE
PM ARE THE ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TO RETAIN A MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN MS REYES MOVES. WE WERE
SO CLOSE. ISRAEL'S YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
MISTER SPEAKER WE ASK WITHOUT
OBJECTION THREE AFTER
RECONSIDERATION WAS GRANTED
THAT AB TWO FIFTY FIVE OR TWO
TO BE MOVED TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. THE CLERK WILL NOTE. ON
THE MOTION TO ADJOURN. THIS
PARA QUE HAN MOOSE. AND MISTER
BLOOM SECONDS. THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED. UNTIL MONDAY
JUNE SO AT ONE PM THE QUORUM
CALL LIFTED.
YES. THE CHANGE
BETWEEN AB AT TWELVE TWENTY I
NOT QUOTING. TURCHIN ASSUMING
PREACHING SOME LEGAL TO TWENTY
I TO NOT VOTE.
TOM DALY ANA. A.
B. ONE TWO TWO THREE CHANGE
FROM YES. TO ABSTAIN. BOTH
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE TWENTY
THREE I TO NOT VOTING. THANK
YOU. PERFECT I WILL.
GRAYSON
EIGHTY ONE AB ONE TWO TWO THREE
FROM ITEM NUMBER. OKAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE TWENTY THREE I TO NOT
VOTING.